according to the cia the film angels in
paradise development of the u2 at area
51 was produced for family members of
those working on the secret spy plane at
the u.s military facility in nevada the
film tells the story of the design
manufacture and testing of the plane
between 1954 and 1960. the u2 could fly
and take photographs
at an unprecedented 70 thousand feet
it's believed that sightings of the
secret u2 flights in nevada were the
source of many 1950s and 60s ufo stories
this is the desert of western nevada
already well known for its nuclear tests
by the atomic energy commission here at
yucca flats
adjoining this aec test site is an
active aerial gunnery range
early in 1955 by presidential order 60
square miles of this prohibited area
were set aside for a special purpose
there's a narrow air corridor to reach
this spot on the map air charts order
closed to all personnel and aircraft
except on orders from the chief of staff
u.s air force
the name of this isolated spot in nevada
is watertown
and its very isolation is of the
greatest importance
the specialists that come off this
transport are hand-picked
they are checked every time they arrive
at watertown overall security in this
area is the highest yet to be maintained
in this country even higher than that of
the manhattan project
selection of watertown was dictated by
several unique considerations
the area is isolated from prying eyes by
the aec range with lethal reminders of
past atomic explosions
aec guards maintain regular patrols
supplies destined for watertown channel
into the area through regular aec routes
watertown radio and teletype
communications the angel is referred to
as an article
her pilots are called drivers
the geographical spot of groom lake is
called home plate
the angel was designed to do a single
job
obtain the largest amount of
reconnaissance information ever
collected on any single flight
for the first time in jet history it is
possible to inspect 400 square miles
with a single cartographic photograph
for the first time in jet history
sensitive electronic equipment is being
carried to heights where it can search
for any number of radio tv or radar
signals and record this information for
detailed analysis
there are already 12 alternate equipment
loads for the u2
development of the angel and the
information gathering equipment that it
carries is the result of the most
experienced judgment applied at every
critical point
a select group of capable dedicated men
in industry and government working with
trust and cooperation completed this
specific project at the utmost speed
the idea for the angel itself was born
when lockheed started a design study on
the maximum altitude possible from a jet
airframe for reconnaissance purposes
the angel then called the cl282
took sufficient form to be presented as
a proposal
members of the killian committee a
portion of the scientific advisory group
defined the technical feasibility and
urgency of the program
the optical and photographic concepts
were envisioned by dr james baker and dr
edwin h land
the original cl 282 proposal was then
modified to produce even more
spectacular results
on december 9 1954 the go-ahead was
given
and lockheed's chief engineer kelly
johnson called together his tiny 26-man
special projects engineering group
here with the problems they faced
to design build an airplane and fly it
in eight months
an airplane that would cruise well above
seventy thousand feet
one that would travel almost as far as a
b-52 and remain in the air for ten hours
a plane that would be completely
reliable with forced landings out of the
question
a plane that would be the world's most
stable aircraft for high altitude
photography
a plane that would be flexible in
concept to carry at least 12 different
equipment loads and have no one penalize
the others in weight
a plane that would weigh only one and
one half times the weight of the power
plant
weight was the critical factor in the
whole project
designers said they would trade their
collective grandmothers for 10 pounds of
empty weight
pounds in fact were called grandmothers
but weight could not be saved at the
expense of reliability a real
engineering challenge met with proven
know-how and a basic design so simple
that it was almost revolutionary
the angel is simplicity itself
all controlled surfaces are cable
operated
the tail section of the fuselage
attaches with only three bolts
the inside of the 80-foot wing is just
four big fuel tanks
the interior of the fuselage is plain
and uncluttered
the cockpit canopy stressed to handle a
pressure differential of five pounds per
square inch is operated by hand
the pant leg engine intake ducts
presented a problem
at altitude near perfect ram air
distribution was needed to keep the
engine running
the final intake on the angel gives as
good pressure distribution as would be
found in a power plant wind tunnel
a unique gust relieving feature was
designed into the wing of the angel to
reduce tail loads and wing bending in
turbulence
the flaps tilt 4 degrees upward and the
ailerons tilt 10 degrees to completely
change the airfoil characteristics
during development of the angel kelly
johnson met with each member of the
special projects group at seven every
morning
any problems occurring on the previous
day were discussed and corrective
decisions were made immediately
subcontracting was virtually impossible
87 percent of the prototype angel was
fabricated in one building in burbank
components were run through the
company's big presses at night and on
sundays then hidden from day shift
workers
the c j manufacturing company for
clarence johnson
was formed in an unmarked downtown
warehouse to handle shipments from
vendors in unmarked trucks designers of
the angel couldn't even get into a
high-speed wind tunnel so calculations
were made with computers
fifty percent of production took place
in this building at bakersfield
at peak production of the 50 u2's only
600 people were involved just one man in
every 60 on the lockheed payroll
the angels were completely assembled
here
checked out disassembled and shrouded in
canvas for airlift to watertown
fuel and hydraulic fluid were added for
the first time at watertown and the
angels were tested by company pilots
because of its long thin wings the angel
has been referred to as a jet glider
it has the world's most efficient lift
drag ratio for powered aircraft
twenty five point six to one
that's better than many competition sail
planes
from seventy thousand feet the angel can
glide three hundred miles without power
the engine for this aircraft was
originally the pratt and whitney j
57-37
a ten thousand five hundred pound thrust
unit built for the b-52
a later 11 500 pound version known as
the dash 31
was developed specifically for the angel
pratt whitney president jack horner and
chief engineer wright parkins crammed a
normal three-year engine development
program into 12 months
the new engine has a 16 stage compressor
with nine stages in the low range and
seven in the high pressure chamber
the low range compressor is driven by a
hollow shaft and turns at a lower speed
than the high compressors
the pratt whitney engine operates at
full power for the duration of the
flight
at sea level this unit gulps nearly 9
000 pounds of fuel per hour at seventy
thousand feet this drops to seven
hundred pounds per hour
at seventy four thousand six hundred
feet the engine will quit from oxygen
starvation
in early stages of the program as many
as six flame outs occurred on a single
flight
with the new fuel system and turbine
design of the dash 31 engine flameouts
have ceased to be a critical problem
an improved ignition system ensures air
restarts at high altitudes
in the first 20 months that the angel
flew logging over 5 000 hours in the air
there were just two forced landings away
from watertown
both planes equipped with the older dash
37 engines landed at kirkland air force
base albuquerque new mexico
after each development flight a careful
accounting is made of fuel consumption
a special fuel dubbed lighter fluid was
developed by shell oil company
specifically for the angel and the
finished product was shipped to nevada
in tank cars labeled lf-1a
this blend will not boil at the low
pressures encountered at altitude yet
will still give adequate air starts
it is so in volatile that fire seldom
follows a mishap
a simple 100 gallon slipper tank has
been developed to fit each wing for
extremely long flights
these pressurized tanks contain enough
fuel to carry the angel to cruising
altitude
where they have no significant effect on
speed or range
even after the addition of an external
drag chute three times the normal oxygen
supply
improved braking and an autopilot the
final all up weight was within 10 pounds
of the original proposal
the angel exceeded original performance
limits in both ceiling and range
when the prototype angel was flown
across death valley to watertown
lockheed also found itself in the
transportation business
their own dc-3 made almost daily flights
to watertown with a hand-picked crew of
flight line mechanics
the first unofficial name for watertown
was paradise ranch
this description was dreamed up
tongue-in-cheek to encourage key
personnel to accept assignment on this
special project before they could be
told what it involved
anyone for golf
many newcomers guessed that the project
involved an atomic-powered aircraft and
were astonished to find that they were
to work with
two days later in a rainstorm the angel
went to eight thousand feet
that day it took five attempts to land
the plane because it would fly on idle
engine thrust
the unusual bicycle landing gear
designed for the lightest possible
structure weighs
257 pounds
a conventional gear on a comparable
aircraft would weigh 750 pounds and take
room out of the wings that is vital for
fuel
wing mounted pogos drop off during
takeoff
again in the interest of saving weight
weight and space that paid off in an
extra 1500 feet of altitude and 100
miles in cruising radius
as the operation at watertown grew in
scope more transportation was required
a daily military air transport shuttle
system was begun with c-54s from burbank
in bad weather one of these transports
crashed into charleston peak a few miles
north of las vegas
14 members of the watertown project were
aboard
program has not been without other
casualties
one angel crashed at watertown
another disintegrated over an indian
village named wide ruin in arizona
a third with lockheed pilot robert
seeker aboard disappeared near watertown
by the time this plane was found some
information about the project at
watertown reached the public
this nearly three years after its
conception
that dust cloud is an actual crash
rescue crews rushed to the end of the
runway where an angel has landed short
the pilot here was uninjured but
emergency crews take no chances with
leaking fuel
salvage operations mean that this fallen
angel will soon fly again to rejoin its
sister ships already in the air
this project has had fewer mishaps and
is normal with new aircraft
yet unique ground handling equipment
designed solely for the angel
operates as well at this crash scene as
it does on the flight line
not all the difficulties at watertown
have come from the angel herself
extremes in weather
wind
sand and heat
snow
cloud burst
biting cold
an ever-present headache
but the angels must be ready for
tomorrow's flight
it's almost all work and no play for the
temporary desert dwellers at watertown
just 72 airline miles distant is las
vegas
however none of watertown's workers can
visit these bright lights
or refreshing scenery security is just
that rigid
meanwhile
back at the ranch
volleyball
pool
a 16 millimeter movie in a tiny
converted mess hall are just about the
only diversions
those who remain over a weekend may
explore long deserted gold mines
remnants from another era of rugged
desert pioneers
here as seen by few men is what the
world looks like from seventy thousand
feet
these scenes were photographed over
arizona by ray gowdy one of the five
lockheed test pilots who have handled
all development and production testing
of the angel
training of new pilots begins with the
t-33 for familiarization flights
the pilot must be able to hold the
t-bird inches in the air for the length
of the lake so that he will be able to
hold the angel at the same altitude
until its broad wings lose all their
lift
this mastered he graduates to the angel
and transition landings on the dry lake
a chase car and chase plane both with
two-way radio are used during this phase
of training
seat belts in the chase car are good
insurance
the new angel pilot makes at least three
landings with the pogo's install she's a
little easier to handle that way
takeoffs are smooth from groom lake
a wide circle as the chase plane plays
follow the leader
now turn in on final approach says the
instructor in the chase plane
your air speed is 92 knots
the chase car pulls into line and picks
up speed
he's leveling off
just a little high
and at 72 knots
here comes the stall
the best way to land the angel is in a
full stall just like the old fashioned
airplanes with tail wheels
the broad dry lake at watertown makes an
ideal location for this type of
transition training
after the landings improve the pogo
safety pins are removed and the new
pilot is on his own
sometimes the drivers taxi right up to
the hangar doors
not bad at all for an airplane that's
supposed to be hard to handle on the
ground
after a number of day flights the new
angel pilots are ready for night
transition and long cross country flight
it's no accident
that the complete angel and all its
intricate cargo can be disassembled and
packed quickly ready for airborne
transport
everything about the angel can go aboard
a cargo plane
cameras in their doghouses
engines
lab equipment and supply
ground support equipment
and of course the angel
the result of foresight and planning
engineering precise and rapid
manufacturing
that's it
what it is and what it can do a vital
chapter in modern american achievement
from the desert wastelands of watertown
it's but a matter of hours to anywhere
in the world where reconnaissance might
be desired
the most important airplane the most
important cargo in the air today is in
this single package the inquisitive
angel
[Music]
you can watch archival films on public
affairs in their entirety on our weekly
series real america
saturday at 10 p.m and sunday at 4 p.m
eastern here on american history tv
sculptor saban howard discusses the
process behind creating assaults at
eight eastern and pacific time
and sundays at nine pm eastern end
pacific
next david darlington discusses his book
area 51 the dreamland chronicles the
books about a military installation in
nevada and the speculation that's
developed about its operation
david darlington is a journalist and the
author of three previous books he spoke
at printers inc book store in palo alto
california
[Music]
good evening and welcome to printers inc
tonight we're very pleased to welcome
author david darlington who will discuss
his new book area 51 the dreamland
chronicles
area 51 also known as dreamland paradise
ranch and the box is the mysterious
top-secret military installation located
in the midst of the nevada desert
funded by the u.s government's 30
billion dollar black budget
a bevy of speculations and legends have
been offered to explain this notorious
covert facility
are aliens or ufos being hidden within
its confines
is at these headquarters of clandestine
satellite government
on just what are the billions of dollars
of our tax dollars being spent
through eyewitness testimony interviews
leaked documents and personal
observations david darlington has
crafted a compelling account that
answers
boundless questions provoked by area 51.
darlington skillfully portrays the
landscape people and often outlandish
ideas that surround dreamland at the
same time explores larger concerns about
who controls our technologies and our
government and in whose interest
as publishers weekly observes darlington
explains not only the history of area 51
but the budgetary and political
advantages of secrecy throughout he
brings a reporter's balanced eye to his
material and to the people involved
so that believers and skeptics alike
should take to his account
critically acclaimed author david
darlington has written three previous
books the mojave in condor country and
angels visits would you please join me
in welcoming david darlington
[Applause]
thank you
which one of these i guess it doesn't
matter though it's a
parabolic situation
uh thank you for coming
um
interesting they were being filmed here
by c-span i didn't know that was
gonna happen but uh
we do have some congressional issues
to discuss so
that'll be great
um
i'm just uh kind of curious sometimes
about uh
about people in the audience and one one
thing i
i wonder is uh um has anybody here ever
been to area 51
but in what capacity
directly over it
no
[Laughter]
what do you mean
when i saw it
what i knew it when i saw it
you were you're a pilot
not just a passenger in an airplane okay
so fine off to the side of it i think
yeah
yeah it's uh supposedly if you fly
over area 51 you can be shot down
unless you turn around there was a
there was a story at one point that um
some people on a
round the world or cross-country weather
balloon
were being blown by the wind directly
toward area 51
and
they were in danger of
of being shot down until the wind
changed
so they lucked down
but
we can discuss some more of those
stories and
concepts
anybody else
bind area 51 or nearby
you've been to rachel yeah
okay rachel is the little town that uh
is the nearest town to area 51. it has a
hundred citizens
um no post office no bank no no brothel
which is
a big deal in nevada
it's brothels are illegal in lincoln
county
which is the county that area 51 is part
of
but anyway
i'm going to
i think just read the prologue
of the book
uh which is called millennial nightmares
and uh
then i'll uh maybe discuss a little bit
of background
and uh see how the time goes sometimes i
read another section uh
about a guy named bob lazar
next question how many people here have
heard of bob lazar
ah
a goodly number okay
well maybe you don't need to hear that
part
um
so i'll read the i'll read the prologue
and then
talk a little bit and see how the time
goes
it started with the cold war
not only area 51 the black budget and
the cia
but all the business about flying
saucers
when an idaho pilot named kenneth arnold
saw nine objects in the sky near mount
rainier washington on june 24 1947
and a mysterious craft came down on a
ranch near roswell new mexico one week
later it marked the opening of an era
one ushered in through channels both
scientific and psychological
by the atomic bomb
i'm not referring to the mere fact of
the sightings themselves
as any ufo book will eagerly tell you
records of unexplained airborne objects
can be traced back to ancient times
popping up throughout the history of art
and religion
nor do i mean the recent rash of alien
abduction stories which have plenty of
predecessors and folk tales about
fairies and goblins
i'm talking about the modern
relationship between these things in
technology
specifically a type of technology that
can destroy the world
and the culture of secrecy that it
created
the cold war justified the dangerous
urge of a democratic government to hide
its workings from the public
in the process it convinced american
citizens that the government was hiding
its workings from them
this destruction of mutual trust was
intrinsic to the way in which the flood
of ufo sightings that followed world war
ii was handled
both by the government and by the
citizens
though whether the bomb and the specter
of communism actually made people see
flying saucers is not a question i'm
prepared to answer
could the phenomenon itself have been
physically triggered by atomic
explosions
was some kind of metaphysical
intelligence disturbed by the path that
homo sapiens was taking
might actual extraterrestrial beings
have been attracted to earth by sudden
flashes appearing over interstellar
distances
or was the collective terrestrial
imagination simply so traumatized by the
techno politics of the time
that it responded hysterically conjuring
visions of alien intruders
much psychological analysis has been
applied to the science fiction films of
the 1950s
invasion of the body snatchers that came
from outer space
which we are told served as a pressure
valve for cold war tensions
portraying an incomprehensible enemy
that threatened everything americans
held dear
but what about the parallel fact that
the real life human witnesses of the
time
george adamsky truman bethurum orfeo
angelucci and george van tassel
people who claim to have had actual
contact with extraterrestrials
described the visitors as a kind of
cross between mahatma gandhi and marilyn
monroe
kind wise beautiful and blonde
or the subsequent reversal that as time
went on the cinematic aliens became
friendly
if still ugly
e.t it is ilk
while the real world tales turn
terrifying with bizarre sexual
experiments being conducted in
antiseptic laboratories
for the now with the likes of saddam
hussein playing the boogeyman role
vacated by the soviets
and a cia veteran seeding the presidency
to a ravenous baby boomer
united across their generations by yale
degrees
our most popular on-screen
entertainments are the sinister
conspiracies of the x-files
and a fourth of july showdown between
all consuming extraterrestrials and a
spineless young chief executive who is
nevertheless a veteran combat pilot
calling shots from the most top secret
research site of the cold war era
with this is our cellulite sublimation
are the real-life stories about to
resume an aspect of reassurance
the answer depends on who you talk to
i'm in contact with certain authorities
who insist there is no cause for
consolation
some believe that extraterrestrials on
the downside of an evolutionary curve
are here for our dna
others deny that the creatures in
question come from outer space at all
rather they are being manufactured in
frankenstein factories at area 51 the
secret the celebrated government
installation at groomed dry lake in
southern nevada
as part of an elaborate hoax designed to
enslave the world population before a
bogus extraterrestrial threat
still others straddle the fence between
these anxious positions combining them
with the conviction that mass mental
slavery is indeed the aim of an evil
illuminati
the validity of these viewpoints is in
my opinion undercut by the fact that the
people who hold them are deeply
disturbed
with the help of ostensibly more
level-headed researchers however i have
assembled a less sensational if equally
incredible story
the popular intelligence has advanced by
the movie independence day
holds that alien corpses and technology
from roswell are being housed at area
51.
according to my sources this claim is
false
the disk came not from roswell but but
from a crash near kingman arizona
and they've been housed not at groom but
papoose lake
also known as area s4 south of area 51.
actually there is a little likelihood
that the material is even at s4 anymore
now that so much attention has been
directed to that region
since 1953 the satellite government
outside the control of washington dc has
pursued this matter in a secret program
which may or may not be descended from
the fabled majestic 12 committee
allegedly mandated by president truman
headquartered at los alamos new mexico
directed in part by dr edward teller
and created by then vice president
richard nixon
moreover this program has been conducted
not by our species alone but with the
limited cooperation of extraterrestrial
biological entities
ebe's from the zeta reticuli star system
who incidentally are not slimy and
reptilian but answer to the classic
description of the typical grey alien
hairless and roughly four feet tall with
big dark wrap around eyes
for reasons not yet fully explained
these beings have a pressing need for
the element boron which is found
throughout the american southwest
this fact together with the
concentration of top-secret military
facilities in that part of the country
partly explains why so much ufo activity
has been reported there
there is some speculation that a deal
was struck between the visitors and the
u.s government allowing the extraction
of boron in exchange for advanced
technology
but this allegation extends beyond the
knowledge of my sources
neither can they confirm or deny the
existence of underground installations
linked by an extensive tunnel system
much less stories of subterranean bats
containing human body parts
which in light of the alien abduction
trend have arisen from the charge also
unconfirmed by my informants that the
bargain involves human research
specimens
this is the basic outline of the
scenario that my contacts have been
scrutinizing
some of it is based on the testimony of
a disreputable young technician who
claims to have been employed in the
secret program
more of it comes from a conservative
elderly engineer who says he worked for
30 years in the satellite organization
and purportedly has the permission of
his supervisors to begin discussing
details of the experience
this man's background is itself somewhat
murky as might be expected one must
acknowledge if someone has spent half
his life in such a covert endeavor
his name however is not a secret
he's a frequent speaker at ufo
conventions and symposia where he
usually ranks the most down-to-earth
participant among a fraternity of
fantastic theorists
radical researchers and out in and out
charlatans
these gatherings which tend to celebrate
the evolvement of stridency and
gullibility provide forums for people
with big answers to confront people with
big questions
invariably they anticipate that some
very big news is going to be revealed in
the very near future
my colleagues are disposed to distance
themselves from this sort of thing
they don't consider themselves
ufologists so much as amateur detectives
with eccentric interests
wary of obsession or conversion they try
not to identify too much with the
mystery that they're pursuing
making it a constant exercise for
example to employ the term
folklore like the reality of flying
saucers themselves which despite
widespread testimony remains
unaccompanied by physical proof
the question of whether this tale is
true or has some been
somehow been summoned up from a
labyrinth of psychosocial forces
is not one that my sources are prepared
to answer
everybody seems to agree however that
it's a heck of a yarn
as the team leader himself has said all
we're looking for is a good story
which is something so rare in this life
that when one finally comes along we
wouldn't want to mess it up with
evidence
one of the fields less reliable
researchers recently announced that the
next 18 months will be pivotal to
execution of the hidden agenda he
predicts a paradigm shift for the year
1998
which when divided by the number of the
trinity equals the satanic figure 666.
in other words the cat's about to get
out of the bag
it's time to surround ourselves with
gold guns groceries and god
with the approach of the year 2000 we
can expect such revelations to rise like
a lake full of hungry trout
rippling the surface of popular
consciousness with expanding poor tents
and prophecies
the cold war might be over but the
millennium is about to arrive
and even if the culture of secrecy is
under fire
paranoia is alive and well hold up in
the desert north of las vegas
under an assumed name
dreamland
i think actually what i'll do is i'm
going to read a little bit of the next
first chapter which is called freedom
ridge
uh
the um
that was the prologue and now begun the
dreamland chronicles which
since you are the select uh
few here tonight of the vulch was my
title for the book uh
area 51 got stopped on top of that by my
publisher for
obvious reasons of wanting to uh
tell people what it was about
but anyway uh
just passed uh just before the first
chapter
i quote from a poem by edgar alpo
which coincidentally is called dreamland
by a root obscure and lonely
haunted by ill angels only where an
idolan named knight on a black throne
reigns upright
i have reached these lands but newly
from an ultimate dim tully
from a weird climb that lieth sublime
out of space out of time
for the heart whose woes are allegiant
as a peaceful soothing region
for the spirit that walks in shadow tis
oh it is an el dorado
but the traveler traveling through it
may not dare not openly view it
never its mysteries are exposed to the
weak human eye unclosed
so wills its king who hath forbid the
uplifting of the fringed lid
and thus the sad soul that here passes
beholds it but through darkened glasses
one day in october in 1993
i left my home in northern california
drove east through the great central
valley through the burnished gold rush
foothills
past the polish granite of yosemite
over the region of sierra nevada crest
past the blue expanse of mono lake and
streak cinder slopes of its adjoining
craters
through the forest that give way to
sagebrush west of benton hot springs
below cloud-capped boundary peak in the
bristlecone dotted white mountains
and into that vast and vacant territory
that wide open alternation of elevation
and depression
that enormous interior drainage bowl of
dry-like dotted desert
that congenitally uncontrolled kingdom
which despite being composed almost
wholly of federal land and a
vociferously unpatriotic american
populace hardly seems part of the united
states
realm of the pinyon pine and juniper
scourge of gamblers and 49ers
home to untamed mustangs unrained
brothels and unbridled atomic bombs
the fastest growing state in the union
the silver state that sovereign state of
mind called nevada
the welcome sign to tonopah high school
said home of the muckers
east of town along u.s highway 6 was the
missile flanked entrance to the tonopah
test range from which squadrons of
stealth fighters embarked for the
persian gulf in 1990
the most common road sign contained the
black silhouette of a prancing bull
within the customary yellow diamond
underscored by the words open
range wild horses gambled on the plains
fighter jets carved the sky with
contrails
mountains sucked streaks out of the
clouds to pummel the darkened earth with
storms
in places where rain had recently fallen
the surface of the two-lane blacktop
steamed in the sun
rainbows shimmered above shining maces
the air was rattling of sage
as i turned south on nevada 375 at warm
springs an unpeopled intersection with a
collection of cottonwoods and an
abandoned pool of hot water
i entered the fallout zone
the swath of the west that took the
brunt of atmospheric testing the 1950s
when nuclear bombs were detonated only
if the wind was blowing this
way as i topped plutonium-tinged queen
city summit and crossed the line between
nia and lincoln counties
ahead and below in the gathering dusk
adjacent to an unnamed playa
i could see the scattered trailer homes
that comprise the town of rachel
population 100
elevation
4970 feet
established approximately 1978.
within the enormity of sand springs
valley it looked like some research
compound on a distant planet
luckily the red white and blue sign in
front of the little alien said
earthlings welcome
i pulled into the parking lot and went
inside the building
which was actually a double wide house
trailer
the only people in the room were a stout
pretty dark-haired barmaid and a guy in
a baseball head who was playing the slot
machine
the jukebox had a few recent pop tunes
augmenting its staple diet of hank
williams dolly parton
merle haggard and randy travis
the walls were decorated with pictures
of fighter planes from nearby nellis air
force range
little grey aliens with big dark eyes
and local terrestrial luminaries
the science buff bob lazar
the pilot john lear
the tv reporter george knapp
the radio host anthony hilder
the funeral director norio hayakawa
and the self-proclaimed world's foremost
ufo researcher sean david morton
who was shown meditating beneath the
pyramid
t-shirts bumper stickers and u.s
geological survey maps of the area were
for sale
on one wall was a six-foot panoramic
photo of the secret base at area 51
located 25 miles to the south
there was also an extensive library
containing books and magazines and a
stack of binders
most of this was the property of one
glenn campbell
not the noted pop country troubadour who
spells his name with only one end
i asked the guy in the baseball cap if
he'd ever been near the secret base
he said that one night when he was drunk
he crossed the boundary and been caught
by the guards but they decided to let
him go
he showed me a copy of a form he'd
signed admitting that what he'd done was
illegal and subject to a 500 fine
i went back outside and drove half a
mile down the road to another trailer
whose sign said area 51 research center
the yard was filled with cacti cattle
skulls a miniature windmill a pair of
plastic smokey sam rockets and a piece
of airplane fuselage bearing the letters
af 51.
a camper was parked in the driveway
and a bald mustachioed man in his 30s
was out in front
this was glenn campbell
whose voice betrayed northeastern roots
when he said welcome to rachel
i had phoned campbell ahead of time to
tell him i was coming
i never met him but knew him as the
author of the area 51 viewers guide
a collection of information about the
basin region beginning with commonly
asked questions such as what is the best
time to look for flying saucers
and what will happen if i intrude into
the restricted zone
and continuing with advice to visitors a
mile by mile guide to points along
highway 375 and meditations on
everything from local government to
extraterrestrial intelligence
i learned about area 51 at a cocktail
party a few months earlier
at the time i was working on a book
about the mojave desert one of its
chapters concerned a structure in
california called the integratron
which has served as a focal point for
the ufo crates of the 1950s
when i mentioned this at the party the
woman asked if i knew about rachel and
the little alien i soon learned that the
town the bar and the base had been
featured on a current affair in the los
angeles times
even in business week in an article
entitled little grey men made my eyes
turn
within
red
next few months the subject would also
find its way into the new york times
magazine and under the cover of popular
science and within a couple of years
would be investigated on 60 minutes
portrayed in the movie independence day
and chosen as the location for a
three-hour ufo special
on larry king live
there wasn't much consistency to these
dispatches some of which focused on
flying saucers while some didn't mention
ufos at all
choosing instead to dwell on issues
involving government secrecy
but there seemed to be something here
for everybody
all peaked by the allure in the words of
the times of a base so secret that it
doesn't exist
as i pieced it together over time the
outline of the overall story went like
this
area 51 was located next door to the
nevada test site
where the government experimented with
nuclear bombs since 1951.
although it has never appeared on
aviation charts or u.s geological survey
maps a base was built in the mid 50s
alongside groom lake
a remote playa ringed by parched
mountains for the u2 spy plane
after francis gary powers was shot down
of the soviet union in 1960
the place continued to serve as the test
site for black budget or secretly funded
intelligence and defense projects
including the a12 and sr-71 blackbirds
the f-117 stealth fighter
and a rumored hypersonic spy plane
called the aurora
for decades it was known to insiders
watertown strip or the ranch
to aircraft buffs and military pilots as
dreamland for the box
the latter names referring respectively
to the call sign of its control tower
and its off-limits status on
aeronautical maps
even noaa's fighter pilots taking part
in red flag war games were grounded
interrogated if they overflew the
restricted airspace
the base had also reportedly been used
for strategic defense initiative or sdi
research and nasa and commando training
which combined with the nellis
aeronautical activity sometimes rendered
the local night skies a virtual
fireworks display of flashing and
streaming lights
unmarked 737 flights from las vegas 100
miles to the south and palmdale
california location of the skunk works
headquarters for lockheed advanced
development projects
dispensed a daily workforce of between
one and two 000 employees
who were required to sign security oaths
prohibiting them from even mentioning
the place
violations subject to 10 years in jail
and a fine of 10 000
in 1984 without the required approval of
congress
the air force seized control of 89 000
acres of public land around the base to
prevent people from coming near it
this inspired a series of hearings in
washington dc during which the air force
representative john rittenhouse
told the chairman of the house
subcommittee on lands and national parks
representative john cyberling of ohio
that he could explain the reasons for
the withdrawal only in a closed briefing
when written house said that the
decision to take the land had been made
at a higher level than his
cyberlink responded that there is no
higher level than the laws of the united
states
signifying in the minds of some that
area 51 was outside the control of the
u.s government
and by extension the american people
the controversy was exacerbated by the
air force's ongoing refusal to
acknowledge the existence of any
military facility in the area
the intrigue escalated to a new and
different level in 1989
when an obscure las vegas technician
named bob lazar
appeared on a local television news show
and claimed that on the recommendation
of edward teller the so-called father of
the hydrogen bomb
and chief proponent of star wars defense
technology
he had been hired to work at area 51.
mazar said that when he reported to the
base he was taken in a bus with blacked
out windows to another smaller playa
called papoose lake
s4 an alleged classified parlance
where he learned that his task was to
research the propulsion systems of
recovered alien spacecraft
with disarming lucidity lazar delivered
a detailed recital of a fantastic story
touching off a frenzy in the ufo
subculture
seekers from around the world soon began
making pilgrimages to rachel
where they gathered at a black mailbox
in the desert south of town
near the spot on highway 375 where lazar
said he'd taken his friends to watch
flight tests of the spacecraft on
wednesday nights
a misstep that supposedly led to his
severance from the program
quick on the uptake the rachel bar and
grill expeditiously renamed itself the
little alien
declaring its candidacy as mecca to ufo
believers
meanwhile back in washington dc a class
action suit was filed
alleging that area 51 employees had
sustained long-term health damage from
toxic materials illegally burned in open
pits at the base
claiming that any disclosures about
classified activities would jeopardize
national security the government
declined to address the charges
adding yet more acetylene to the inferno
unfortunately for the air force its 1984
land withdrawal had neglected a
promontory called white sides mountain
an unobstructed viewpoint just outside
the border of area 51.
photos of hangers runways and towers at
the non-existent base soon began
appearing in
magazines
as curious hikers and correspondents
converged on the peak
a private enterprise called secret
saucer-based expeditions even offered
guided tours promising disclosure of
previously withheld government
information on extraterrestrials
whenever people were at large in the
area
operations of the base had to be delayed
or cancelled
playing havoc with operations
hence in 1993
the air force filed a new application
for 4 000 more restricted acres
citing the need to ensure the public
safety and safe and secure operation of
activities in the nellis air force range
complex
this time watchdogs were waiting
citizen alert a nancy nuclear
organization in reno in las vegas
that had protested the earlier closure
and an ad hoc group called the rural
alliance for military accountability
lobbied against the new withdrawal
proponents of the neo-sagebrush
rebellion which holds that the federal
government has no legal claim to western
lands
declared the proposal unconstitutional
lincoln county 99 of which is public
property and whose commissioners hadn't
initially been notified of the plan
registered a formal protest
and citizen glenn campbell lured by the
legends
moved from his home in boston to rachel
where operating from a corner table in
the little alien
he set up the secrecy oversight council
and whiteside's defense committee
both of which consisted entirely of he
himself and him
in the forays along the border that
culminated in his viewers guide
campbell succeeded in becoming a
good-sized thorn in the side of the
government
he furnished visitors with directions to
the border and counseled them about
their rights if they were challenged he
tied ribbons around joshua trees to mark
the route up white side's mountain
when those were removed he spray-painted
arrows on the rocks
and when those were eradicated
he replaced them with larger more
numerous ones
he dismantled motion sensors on public
land along the groom-like access road a
buffer zone for the buffer zone he
charged
and published the arrival and departure
times for the flights that shuttled
workers to the base
as well as the radio frequencies used by
the groom lake air control tower
security guards and the lincoln county
sheriff
in short he pushed the jurisdiction of
the government as far as he could within
the limits of the law and framework of
the constitution
most irksome of all to authorities
campbell discovered an even better
vantage point in white side's mountain
a ridgeline only a dozen miles from
groom lake with a bleacher seat view of
the base
in october 1993 he announced that he
would lead a camp out on this legal
overlook which he had christened freedom
ridge
i had driven to rachel in order to take
part
so the rest of that chapter goes on to
describe
our hike
to freedom ridge
before it was closed which it was
uh about a year later
after a couple of uh sort of cursory
public hearings
that were required by law the first one
took place in the little the county seat
of uh
caliente in lincoln county
and the second one
uh was in las vegas and that was quite a
uh
quite a circus
um i have a blow-by-blow description of
both of those hearings in the book
that was where i came across
a guy named anthony hilder
who uh is a radio talk show host and
conspiracy theorist and sort of uh
expert on the new world order
which you may or may not know is the um
clandestine uh
cabal and conspiracy that is uh
as he puts it planning to take away
everything we have
um he uh says that area 51 is
is a uh
sort of nexus for their operations and
claims that among other things
they uh have a frankenstein factory
where they are bioengineering
sort of quasi
or faux
extraterrestrials for the purpose of
freaking us all out
but
he is only one of many
colorful characters that i came in
contact with and
as i went on to uh research this book i
uh i originally took this trip to
freedom ridge that i just described
or just introduced
for my book on the mojave desert
but once i got there and spent a month
or two researching this subject i
realized that it was much too
big and complex to be just part of one
chapter
and a book about the desert that it
really deserved a whole book on its own
and uh so as soon as i finished the
mojave i uh set right to work on on this
book
um essentially what i've
what i've tried to do is is give a
compilation of information
about the base and its history to the
extent that it's known
uh the next chapter after freedom bridge
is called paradise ranch and that was
the name that uh kelly johnson applied
to
area 51 kelly johnson was the head of
skunk works which is the legendary
experimental arm of lockheed
which uh developed the u2 and the a12
blackbird
and the stealth fighter all of which
were tested and housed at area 51 before
they uh were made publicly known
um and basically what the the the
situation with with the base is
uh that it was built in 1955 by the cia
for the specifically for the u2
and um after that
it was uh basically i think known
mostly to a sort of you know select
codery of aviation buffs people who
followed
aerospace technology and
secret airplanes knew that there was
this place in the nevada desert at groom
lake which was where these things were
tested
but
gradually over time
there are developed uh rumors
of uh
flying saucers that uh
were had been seen around the base or in
that area or uh that people had seen
things
inside the base stories and a number of
them are
are catalogued here uh stories like you
know a worker at the base
uh went into a hangar by mistake where
he wasn't supposed to be and he saw a
disc
uh hovering you know three feet off the
ground um and the stories get wilder
from there
um you know another one that uh that i
heard was that a bunch of people were
taken out to the tone of test range one
day and were made to encircle a disc uh
which suddenly disappeared
before their eyes
and that they were guinea pigs in an
experiment uh
about perception of these things
but
these stories kind of grew up over time
and
one of the people sort of one of the
early people who
who promulgated a lot of these tales was
john lear who was the son of william
lear who invented the lear jet
and john lear is a very accomplished
pilot in his own right he holds a whole
lot of
speed records and all kinds of uh
aviation licenses
from the faa and he did it he's phoned a
number of missions for the cia
but apparently uh sometime in the
mid 80s early to mid 80s he talked to
some
british military people who told him
about a ufo landing that they had
witnessed
and he
began to look into this and he became
so avid about it that he became the
um sort of conduit for some of the most
fantastic
and uh and horrifying
uh stories about uh extraterrestrial
visitors that that i've ever heard uh
the ones that i referred to in the
prologue about
subterranean bats full of human body
parts
um
things like that those stories come from
john lear that uh
clear said that uh that the he was also
the one who said that the the the
visitors are on the downside of an
evolutionary curve
and uh
and they're here for our dna the one one
thing that they try to that they need is
they they combine human body tissue with
uh
with peroxide and they spread this on
their own skin and that preserves it
um
now uh and this is you know related to
the alien abduction stories that the
government okayed but it got out of
control um it turned out that these
things were not benign as the government
believed and there was a whole uh
uh battle that took place underground at
dulce new mexico which is a famous place
for another underground site
um
all kinds of wild tales anyway what
eventually happened was
was lear uh met
this guy named bob lazar
who was a sort of obscure technician who
had worked at los alamos
and uh
um
had moved to las vegas where he had a
photo processing business
and uh lira lazar at first considered
lear to be a total crackpot and lazar
was a real debunker of
flying saucer stories but in 1989 lazar
went on george knapp's tv show
and told the story that he had been
hired to work at area 51 and when he
reported to work he found that his
his job was to recover the
research the
propulsion systems on recovered alien
spacecraft and he told such an amazingly
detailed
uh vivid story
that um
that he immediately uh became a a sort
of um
uh sinusoid to uh people from all over
the world
and um
lazar uh uh he since it produced his own
videotape which you can uh purchase and
it's been rumored for years that new
line cinema was going to come out with a
movie telling bob was our story which
would be a fantastic movie
but um when some people started looking
into lazar's background after he went
public like this
uh there were some things that kind of
came up short for example
he claims to have degrees in physics
from mit and caltech the two best
engineering schools in the country
and when people uh
consulted the
admissions departments or the archives
of those schools there was no record of
his attendance
now lazar claims that his records were
expunged
after he
told this story after he went public
but some of these people there's a whole
group of people
who study area 51 and they call
themselves the interceptors
now uh i've become in my course of my
research i've become
a sort of honorary interceptor myself as
you can see from the patch that i have
on my jacket it says dreamland
interceptors
semper suspiciary
but it's a group of actually very
bright and down to earth people these
are the ones i refer to in the prologue
as my colleagues
who basically are just so intrigued
by these tales and had situations where
they were
able to uh not do anything else that
they just devoted their lives for a
couple of years to doing nothing but
studying area 51
and all of these stories
uh the primary one is glenn campbell who
uh is probably really the central figure
in this book who was a very uh
witty writer and published a newsletter
called the groom like desert rat
which i quote from pretty liberally in
the book another one is tom mahood
who did a whole lot of detective work he
was a civil engineer in orange county he
retired from his job when he was about
40 years old and he devoted his time to
studying bob lazar
and uh turned out that
um
that he went to uh he found out that
lazar well after lazar went public with
all of this and became so famous
he was actually busted for pandering
in las vegas he uh he admitted to being
involved with a brothel
um so he had a uh you know court
appearances and those were public
records
and wazar's background
was a public record as a result of these
court appearances so tom went to the
clark county courthouse in las vegas and
started studying up on lazar's
background where he learned that
lazar for
for example had
at one time been married to two women
simultaneously
one of whom killed herself two days
after he married the other one
and he
also owed a lot of people money he had
declared bankruptcy and um
he had a lot of things
in his background that uh made him seem
like a pretty shady character
now all of this
uh might be explained in a lot of ways
and one one theory that was advanced by
george knapp the tv reporter who
originally interviewed lazar
was that maybe lazar was hand-picked
by the people running the secret program
for exactly this reason
that he was so disreputable
that if he were to spill the beans
he could easily be discredited
now that's all well and good that's a
pretty good story too
but it turns out that if you go to the
most fundamental level of was our story
which is
physics
lazar claims that he is a physicist
and he gives an explanation of what he
found out about these craft and how they
propel themselves through space
which basically says that
there's an element numbered 115
on the uh
periodic table
referring to the number of protons in an
atom it's higher than anything that we
have on earth i think now that our
periodic chart goes up to 112 just
recently
this is 115 he says that
it emits gravity waves
that extend beyond the perimeter of its
atom where they can be accessed and
amplified in a reactor that's about the
size of a basketball
he gives a detailed description of what
all this stuff looks like
and those waves can be focused on on a
distant point in space
and uh by that they're so strong that
they distort space and time
at all points in between
so effectively a craft
can be pulled
instantly and appear in another place
with no passage of time
you know millions of miles away
now
you know it's all tied up with
einstein's theory of relativity and
things that i'm not very conversant on
because i don't have a scientific
background
but tom mahood
after giving up his career as a civil
engineer has since gone back to graduate
school in physics
and uh
and he soon learned that
i also had some physicist friends
analyze this stuff with me
and if you apply for example the
fundamental theory or the fundamental
formula e equals m c squared
to the amount of matter in this element
115 that lazar says each craft contained
you find that it's really if it was
totally converted to energy
a totally efficient uh reaction it could
uh it would give off enough power
to just um to run all the households in
the united states for about a year and a
half
now that's pretty good
but it's still probably not enough
to um
distort space and time over 200 trillion
miles
which is the distance between here and
the zeta reticuli star system which is
where lazar says that these craft
originated um so there's other things
too that kind of don't hold water in
lazar's story and at this point he's
been pretty well discredited
but uh he's sort of functioned as a uh
um i say in the beginning of that shot i
never met lazar because he has a
sort of a very obnoxious uh guy named
jean huff who is sort of his manager and
you have to go through huff to get to
lazar
and um huff sort of makes a practice of
blowing people off in a very rude manner
and he did that to me
so i never got to interview wizard but i
but i say that you know lazar
meeting meeting lazar at this point it's
kind of like meeting bob dylan
um you know he's such a reclusive
superstar and a legend in his own time
that you know you'd almost rather not
meet him you know but just
sort of
uh analyze the story from afar which is
what i did
but the um the interceptors also include
a guy
who calls himself agent x
he's uh an ex-coast guard uh
guy from juneau alaska who i spent a few
days in the desert with a sort of expert
on secret aviation technology and
uh hustler troubleshooter i have a
picture of him
a picture of him in the book um
here uh where we camped down on delamar
dry lake and we did see some interesting
things that night uh there was we there
was a three planes came over us really
fast
in the dark and one of them had no
lights at all he said he'd never seen
that before another one had a green
diamond light pattern he didn't know
what that was
but um
i have a picture of him here
standing in his camouflage garb
on top of
a mustang rental convertible
which is
his vehicle of choice when he does his
reconnaissance in the desert
um he likes to uh he lives in he says in
alaska he he ran for mayor of juneau
and he said that his first act
um actually his first act because when
he lost the election he declared himself
emperor of juno
his his first act was to change the name
of juno in the interest of honesty and
accountability he changed the name to
reign
so he says when he's in the desert he
rents convertibles
so he can get as much sun as possible
his interesting thing has happened to
him since he's come down with the
disease
and i forget the name of it but
all his hair has fallen out
it's very very peculiar um
but
who knows why that might be but that's
not in the book because it's happened
since the book was published
the picture right underneath that is
this pyramid is the luxor casino
how many people have been to las vegas
here
the
the luxor casino is a big black pyramid
with a stink sound in front
and uh
one of the chapters in the book is is
takes place inside the pyramid where
glenn campbell kind of gave me a tour uh
pointing out various
um
points about las vegas culture but
taking off right in front of the pyramid
is a boeing 737
bound for groom lake
this terminal here is the mccarran
uh airport eg g terminal the company
that uh
um used to run operations at the test
site and employees at area 51 who live
in las vegas park here and take these
jets the area 51 100 miles to the north
but they're unmarked they're called
janet flights
uh just as you know something might be
called uh you know southwest or twa
um
but they for a long time in the early
days of ufo interest in area 51
these flights would come in at 4 45 in
the morning
before dawn
and
from the direction of white side
mountain which was the main viewpoint
for ufo watchers they would thing would
be coming in from the south and it would
appear to be totally
uh stationary
you know it wasn't going sideways it was
coming right at you so this big going
light a lot of people thought they
called it old faithful
and it was the morning ufo
uh but it turned out it was boeing 737
the interceptors have
there's a couple of guys
who i call their elders
jim goodall and
john andrews andrews was the person who
uh three years before the
stealth fighter was revealed by the
government andrew was designed a model
toy of it
and sold it to the tester toy company he
and his friend jim goodall are experts
on long-time watchers of aviation secret
aviation projects and i have a long
interview with them in the book
um
the longest chapter is probably
uh called loose fur rising which is
a play on uh the last chapter of arthur
c clarke's book 2010 which is called
lucifer rising
it describes a ufo convention in the
town of rachel that i went to
which uh i got a great year full of uh
conspiracy theories and learned a lot
about the new world order
um
and
the other big ufo story in the book is
told by a guy named bill you house he's
that elderly engineer i referred to in
the prologue
the chapter is called a higher form of
hungarian
and this is the reference to the fact
that uh uh tells an involved story about
his 30 years of
of employment in the secret satellite
government
where he was
supposed to help duplicate a
flying saucer and uh somebody asked him
at one point how the aliens communicate
among themselves and he said well
you know what the most difficult
language on earth is to learn
and someone said hungarian and he said
that's right
the aliens speak a higher form of
hungarian
and there's all kinds of theories and
background for
how this might have come about
turns out that the los alamos scientists
during the manhattan project the
hungarian zionists were fond of uh
calling themselves uh martians
which is a whole other story
but um
with all these fanciful things there are
some pretty serious issues involved
with the base basically the fact that
it's uh
that it's funded by what we call the
black budget
um which is a secret program for
technology and intelligence and defense
spending
uh only a very select number of people
in congress
know the funds and what they're going
toward
most congress members and american
taxpayers have no idea how much money is
even going into these secret programs
much less what the programs themselves
are
and there have been estimates made of
this
um over the years that are basically
done by subtracting the amount of uh
um
known expenditures from the total budget
and it's come out
to uh lately over the last decade or so
it's been in the neighborhood in the mid
30 billion dollar range per year
there's been one estimate that area 51
itself cost a billion dollars a year
just to run the base and there's a lot
of tales of extravagance among the
military personnel who have run the
place over time
there was one allegation that the
bottled water bill for the base
was 50 000 a month
um
but anyway
to me the um
the toxic waste suit which has been in
the news you might have heard of it it
was thrown out of court these people
claim their health had been damaged by
toxic burning and two of them have since
died
um it was thrown out of court in las
vegas after president clinton signed an
exemption
excusing area 51
from complying with environmental law
because it would endanger national
security this was on 60 minutes
now of course they didn't call area 51
in the exemption because they still
don't admit that there is such a base as
area 51.
they say have gone so far now is to
admit that there is what they call an
operating location
near groomed dry lake
but uh
um this the the case was appealed it's
now at the ninth uh circuit district
court in san francisco and the first
hearing or the only hearing took place
about a month ago
and uh jonathan turley the lawyer for
the plaintiffs
got quite a uh
it was really put through his paces by
the one of the three judges
on the panel
and it looked like she was not much
disposed to
give his uh claims much
much credence but um we're much uh
uh wait
but um whatever happens and that
decision should come down in the next
month
month or two
it's probably going to be appealed and
go to the supreme court because this
question of whether a secret classified
facility
can
basically hide allegations
of
environmental crimes or any kind of
criminal activity for that matter
uh
under the uh cloak of national security
is an important question
and um it'll be interesting to see how
the supreme court deals with it which
will probably happen sometime next year
i guess i'll just
close by saying that to me
uh the real they're really two
interesting topics and i mean there's a
lot of interesting topics you know all
the stuff about ufos is fascinating even
if you don't believe
that flying saucers exist or come from
outer space it's fascinating to me
to consider
um
things implications that these stories
have uh you know there's always people
always speculating why would these
extraterrestrials come so far just to be
around us you know what is it about
human life that's so fascinating um or
just the physics of how something like
that could happen
but also
um even if you just consider it folklore
the most fascinating thing to me is the
parallels between
the flying saucers stories and the folk
war and the cold war itself
because area 51 itself
is purely and simply an artifact of the
cold war it was built for a spy plane to
overfly the soviet union
and um
you know the roswell story the roswell
crash happened in 1947 which was the
year of the cia act
uh when the black budget began and at
that time roswell was the headquarters
for the i think the 509th bomber wing
which was the only strategic air command
battalion of airplanes that were
authorized to drop nuclear bombs
so those kind of parallels to me are
fascinating
and i wish i could have gone into it
more in the book than i actually did
but it's really a story about the uh
the paranoid mentality of the cold war i
think that's what area 51 is all about
both on the inside and the outside you
know paranoia i think created area 51
continues to uh foster it and also uh
feeds the people outside the base who
are uh have so many fantastic theories
for what's going on there and they're
allowed to have these fantastic theories
by the fact
that the government won't admit that
there's anything there so you know it's
just a kind of a blank slate
for the uh paranoid imagination
to uh come up with any sort of uh
activity you might uh imagine and the
other thing to me that was always the
most uh interesting and maybe important
uh aspect of the story is really from
the level of lincoln county
and uh glenn campbell who was busted for
obstructing the police officer because
he locked the doors of a tv van so it
couldn't be searched without a warrant
and he was convicted
um
all the way up to congress the pentagon
and the president it's a story about
democracy
and what place
secrecy has
in a democratic society
[Music]
the interceptors people like glenn
campbell who have stormed the gates of
area 51 and of government secrecy are
basically
doing it in the name of democracy
and uh whatever your perspective is on
that will determine you know i think how
uh
how how much you believe that the um
a place like this should continue to
function in such absolute secrecy as it
does in the wake of the cold war
so uh
i'll uh stop talking there i don't know
how much time we have for questions
but uh maybe a few
[Music]
yeah it's more like
yeah it's more it's more like between a
thousand and two thousand
yeah it's a really big place
yeah and um
basically people who uh who work at
facilities like this are required to
take a security oath
um
where they uh i said before they're
they're uh they're subject to 10 years
in jail and a fine of 10 000
if they
if they disclose classified information
supposedly if they even mention area 51
by name and i have talked to some people
who it was obvious had worked at the
base but even though they were talking
to me and telling me stuff about it they
still wouldn't admit that that's where
they worked they wouldn't say
area 51. um they would just say oh let's
just say it's a base that you know
in the desert that may or may not exist
you know um so it's a pretty strong
threat they have a penalty and they and
they can use lose their pensions you
know that's a big threat um you know
what bob lazar says people said one of
my questions was
well if lazar violated his security oath
when he did when he disclosed his
classified information why didn't they
put him in jail and his answer is well
because then everyone know i was telling
the truth
but
you know anyone could say that about
who's in any classified program but
glenn campbell uh said that one of his
questions when he first moved there
and this is a lot of people ask this how
could the government keep a secret as
big as alien contact
for 50 years you know
and glenn said that he had that
question too when he moved there but
after spending a couple of years around
rachel and around the border area 51 and
trying to find out about it and talk to
people he concluded that
they could keep a secret like that
because security was so
uh rigidly enforced and so effective and
the place is so big the nellis air force
range is as big as switzerland
um and it's the desert so it's you know
it's unpopulated so uh
it's a pla it's a really good place for
keeping secrets
most of my information came from this
group of people who call themselves the
interceptors
you could call it secondary sources in
that sense basically and basically my
feeling about them is the same criteria
that they apply to people that they talk
to
which is essentially just a kind of
intuition
um you know talking to someone and and
you know just how do they strike you do
they seem believable or not now for a
long time they thought this guy bill you
house was believable a guy 70 year old
guy who said he worked in the secret
saucer program u-house never struck me
as too reliable from the first time i
met him and it turns out in the end he
kind of told a lot of fibs
but
you know all of these things basically
the way that
that glenn describes it is
um
the uh
he said the truth holds together over
time
whereas lies and falsehoods fall apart
on their own if you collect enough
stories and compare them to each other
um the ones that that seem to ring true
and are consistent um hang together and
you know and the ones that aren't don't
um
but
i have
not interviewed
i've hardly anyone who has actually
worked at the base or you know it's like
when i ask people here
who's been area 51
for all i know there are people here who
didn't raise their hand because they've
worked at area 51 you know but um so i
don't uh
i haven't had that much direct contact
with these sources myself i get i've
gotten most of my information through
the interceptors and i apply my
standards to that their stuff the same
way that they do to their sources i i
did participate in one exercise where
once these people became public figures
like glenn campbell and tom mahood and
and uh whatnot they started beca you
know they were a focal point for
receiving information themselves so
people would email them or get in touch
with them and send them stuff
saying you know
this one example that i that i was uh
going to tell you about is a guy
said that he uh
had worked at los alamos i guess it was
in the late 40s early 50s and that here
at this particular technical area 33
of los alamos there was a um
a hangar built down in a canyon and this
is where uh
it was the underground entrance there
was a big hangar door where they took
the recovered saucers okay
so i happened to be going to new mexico
at about that time and so they said oh
hey you want to look for a secret saucer
base i said
sure why not
so i would happen to be right next door
to bandolier national monument where you
can camp on public land
and look straight into that canyon and
so i just went with my binoculars and i
looked down and there was no evidence at
all of any disturbance of the earth uh
certainly no big hangar door um and it's
you know that's the way these things
kind of go is that when you check out
the stories yourself
they don't hold together too well
um
and uh
you know same thing with papua's lake
where bob lazar says that he worked if
you look at satellite photos
there's no evidence of any land
disturbance there there's certainly no
hangars although bazar says they were
disguised to look like the desert
there's another place that tom muhood
knows about area 19. of the nevada test
site which he thinks is the su really
super secret place
where he heard tales of something that
he calls the cheshire runway
because
he heard stories of pilots who would be
coming into this place and they'd be
they would have a an assignment to land
and just you know certain coordinates
and they would come in
and they wouldn't see the runway until
the last second because sprinklers would
come on
and show them
wet wet the pavement and show them where
it was
um
but that's just
uh
tom is still trying to get into area 19.
it's a place that even on press tours
you can go almost anywhere at the test
site
except there so that's still a place
that holds some uh intrigue
um
you sound rather
um
suspicious of things that like you um
it's fun
you know
um
it's uh
it's just i the way that i see it it's
just part of the spirit of the whole
thing
i've got a dreamland patch and i've got
a
i've got an alien face you know it's all
part of the uh
part of the same story
um
and that to me is you know a lot of what
makes made this book so much
uh so interesting to to write
is that it has so many weird angles
um and it's and and they're all
entertaining you know
so um
i mean
you know i've learned a lot about aliens
over the last couple of years you know
even though i've never seen one but
you know the folklore of it again
it's uh
um you know i think
you can enjoy
uh folk tales and myths even if you
don't necessarily believe them you know
and it's not you or even if you're
agnostic it's not a question of do i
believe it or not i mean i still you
know people ask me if i believe in
fine saucers or extraterrestrials my
answer is still i don't know i mean i it
the the evidence seems to be
from what we've been able to see
that it's not true of area 51 or at
least they've really got it well hidden
to the extent that you know once you
check it out you still there's no
evidence of it but there's no evidence
of any
extraterrestrial
life you know there's all the ufo
sightings that have been made and there
have been thousands
there's no evidence or physical proof
for any of it
um
you know that doesn't mean that
people didn't really see things you know
and and you know there are some very
convincing stories about things that
have been tracked on radar by the air
force and then disappeared
that you know that you can't explain
so um
you know it's basically at this point
it's i i remain agnostic you know
on those questions
of the author of the day after yeah a
lot of people have asked me that but i
don't really have one i haven't read
that book the the book was it's the day
after roswell
yeah and um this is the guy who i think
he says that uh
that our civilization got things like
the laser and the silicon chip from the
extraterrestrials um and
uh
i i'm i don't know that much about
roswell i was there for a signing
last month first time i'd ever been
there and you know i was at the museum
and i i have to say that
if you talk to people in roswell
very much you know you'll come away a
believer i mean there's so much
uh
there's so much um
anecdotal evidence for uh
for that incident that um it's pretty
convincing
but
you know i base really had to limit
myself i'm not a ufologist you know i'm
not a i'm not an expert on flying saucer
uh lore in general i mean basically i've
just studied up on area 51.
so you're alluding to that next year the
congress is about to come around perhaps
the supreme court to actually talk about
the official manner so are you saying
that the government is sort of running
out of moves
and
i have to come out and say something and
is that something going to be a whole
other story well not necessarily because
the supreme court
might find
they could refuse to hear the case
in which case that would be that
although of course the decision that
happens before that at the ninth circuit
court level would determine
what happens
um
or if they consider the case they could
find that in fact
it was a proper decision to
keep these matters classified and that
it does endanger national security and
that uh
and that therefore no information about
the about the base
will be released so i don't think it's
something like
that they're coming to their end of the
rope it's
it's more a uh um you know it's a legal
question although the it's interesting
to consider that you know various arms
of the uh government you know that have
the judiciary and
and how much they're going to be
influenced by uh
um
you know the other uh
aspects of uh you know political uh
pressure in washington d.c and you know
this makeup of the supreme court is
you know a major factor and
um one more question anyone
okay
no more questions
all right well thank you uh for your
attention and uh
i'll sign any books for anybody who
would like one
thank you very much david darlington
area 50 wants the book and if you'd like
to come up along the side here if you
want to ask any further questions right
up at this table you can come along this
side thank you very much
david
maureen did say she couldn't can we get
for decades people have reported seeing
ufos in part of the nevada desert called
area 51. the government has denied the
existence of a military base in that
location
this past year the atomic testing museum
in las vegas held a forum with former
air force and cia personnel involved in
top secret spy plane projects
it was the first time they spoke about
their work in public
this is about two hours
i see that i see this truck
ladies and gentlemen thank you
thank you very much for uh for being
here today
i didn't uh
stumble although damn near and you
notice i'm putting on my glasses
my name's troy wade i am chairman of the
nts historical foundation
um
and the atomic testing museum
and it is our great pleasure to welcome
you all here tonight for
for what is a
signal signature event for us
this year
we believe that
if you have not been through the museum
then shame on you you need to do that
we believe it is one of the
uh
best
representations
of the cold war that there is in in this
country
and we're very pleased that it's a
uh
an affiliate of the smithsonian and the
smithsonian believes it's a signature
facility
uh i i went to work at the test site in
1958 april of 1958
and so some of you in the audience have
heard me say this that that qualifies me
to be
either a speaker
for the museum or an artifact standing
inside
in any case when i went to the test site
i
knew shortly about this place that we
call watertown in those days
and its name has changed over the years
all classified
like like much of the things i did at
the test site
in my career at the test site i i
subsequently had a lot to do with
with the things that went on in in area
51.
classification is an important part of
this nation's history
and the success of this nation but but
declassification is also important
and the history of the roadrunners
uh the roadrunners are here and this
place this this event is taking place
tonight
and the subsequent event will take a
play take place tomorrow because of of
declassification rules
which are just
just wonderful it's it's it's great that
we're able to talk about some of these
things now we have
two panels one tonight
and one tomorrow
the panel tomorrow is going to be
chaired by
just a wonderful lady from
from l.a
a
very well-known reporter and
historian and you'll see her tomorrow
annie jacobson
give her a hand please
[Applause]
the panel tonight is chaired by an old
friend
nemesis perhaps
named george knapp
[Applause]
in all the years that i've been here i
can't tell you how many times i've
talked with george and how many times
he's put me on the spot and how many
times i've not answered
or let him down the primrose path but i
will tell you one thing that when we
started
talking about this museum
i talked with george and george knapp
has been
a big supporter of this museum since
since its inception since the opening
he's uh he's had uh events here he's
supported this
and and so uh let me just ask you one
more time to welcome george
[Applause]
t.d barnes is another old friend
i've known td from
with with several different hats on his
hat on when he was in area 51 is
his his hat when he came over and worked
on the nuclear rocket program
and his hat when he worked on the
underground test program which is where
i was
where i was very involved he as most of
you know he's a retired army officer
after he retired he became an
electronics specialist and that got him
associated with
with everything from the x-15 to the to
the kb 70 to the a12 to the yf-12 to the
blackbird
[Music]
he's had all the clearances in the world
and
and
he now can talk because of the
declassification rules
we think it's a great honor for this
museum to be hosting this event
we think it's a great honor for us to
have somebody like td barnes
td one of the things that the museum has
done
uh and as i welcome you and george to
the podium i'm gonna present to you
a lifetime membership in the
atomic testing museum
nts historical foundation
presented to you for your continued
support
so
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
two good
good good friends of the museum
uh george knapp and uh
a great american td barnes
[Applause]
thank you troy
i echo your sentiments uh
in regard to the atomic testing museum
hosting this uh
for the roadrunners this is a very
special event for us and
we're particularly pleased to be able to
talk for the first time in 50 years to
the public freely without
revealing any national security uh
secrets we
for 50 years our wives did not know
where we worked or what we did this all
changed
october 19
2007 when the cia
flew us back to langley and the uh the
director hugged their next and
told us what a great job we did and
declassified our name so we could
finally admit that what we did back in
those days
i'm particularly honored to have um
my good friend george knapp he's been a
very trusted ally of the road runners
long before we became declassified
we were free to talk with with george
without worried about him
uh spilling the beans on us it was a
mutual
thing he uh he helped us do what we were
doing because we are have embarked on a
program
now that we can finally talk about it of
letting the public know
what we did because it's important for
the sake of history we've been working
uh with dr mary polowski with unlv for
about six years
trying to get some of the stories that's
known only in our heads they um we back
in those days when we had a meeting you
did not take a piece of paper you did
not take a pen you did not talk outside
the room and in many cases you did not
talk to each other unless you had a need
to know you didn't talk about it i don't
care how good of friends you were you
spent all weekend on the lake and to
this day there are certain things that
we do not talk about even among
ourselves
we got a very distinguished panel up
here that will be speaking to you
tonight and we've got a wide array i'll
introduce them in a moment but
likewise out in the audience here we've
got just the equally
amount of people that it should be on
this panel there's one room for it i
wish we could have each and every one of
you the road runners are the the best
band of brothers imaginable we
we uh worked together in the 1960s and
we have never parted and
we lost 20 of our pilots in the program
we've lost a few along the way
the cia did such a good job of selecting
the people for the program that even
today the widows of the pilots we lost
50 years ago
are still here they're here tonight
they're at our every event
they're on our email circus the family
has never parted
and we it's such a mix of of people
we've got uh air force pilots that were
sheep dipped into that meant they uh
resigned their commission and became cia
pilots for the cia and then they uh
at the end of the program they went back
into the service and completed a
military career
we got lockheed people we got pratt and
whitney the people built the engines we
got the uh
mission planners the air force people uh
camera people i won't try to name them
all we just and in those days
we you did not necessarily even know who
each other was with each other
on the premises and you know well that's
a camera guy that's the engine guy but
you didn't actually want you know what
just what are you doing or whatever
which which plane are you working on if
you didn't have a note you didn't
actually even even
if you wrote up there on the same plane
together you just did not and it still
to that certain extent that way today
on certain certain things will never be
declassified and that's areas that we do
not go into even among ourselves
so i won't talk too long i will mention
that a little bit about the uh
uh youtube program it started in 1955
and um we trained three detachments of
ca pilots uh out of area 51 we called it
watertown then
and they were dispatched to various
locations um
as weathermen for nasa and they started
flying over the soviet union uh several
of them are here tonight that were the
first ones to fly over certain areas of
the soviet union and our enemies at the
time
the um
we also got the the the pilots here we
got the youtube we got some of the air
force pilots that flew cuba and the
different places the trouble spots
around the world keeping the eye on our
enemies but what few people realize is
out of every 51 we had a titanium plane
that we built first one of its kind ever
built it's so unique every tool that it
took to build that plane had to be
invented
we built the plane that when once we got
it built we didn't have a fuel for it
for the plane flew hot it's like uh up
to 800 degrees or better so we had to
design any fuel that's part of what some
of the people here did they designed the
fuel for the plane same way with your
hydraulics you had cameras to build this
thing flew at 2200 miles an hour
at 80 thousand feet or above
they had to be able to take a photograph
at that speed
mining with the lens cover maybe the
temperature on it was 1100 degrees and
they had to be able to read the car tag
from 80 000 feet
traveling at that speed
out of room late we flew 2 850 missions
that no one ever knew about until just
recently and this is a as george would
like to uh talk about this was a lot of
the uh ufo sightings the you've always
heard the ufo stories about drew lake
that started out with the u2 plane they
were flying at 80 000 feet
and we did not paint them at that time
and they would just shine at certain
circumstances they didn't shine like a
silver dollar and that was a ufo
and then when the a12 started flying it
too was a a a ufo except it didn't
zigzag around like uh some were reported
because uh to turn this plane around at
speed
minimum was probably 85 miles the more
normal would be 125 miles it took to
turn this plane around which limited it
severely to where it could be engaged
the plane was built
to overfly the soviet union
when we started building it the titanium
was being processed here in henderson at
the time that
the it was substandard for this plane we
we learned
we got our
titanium out of soviet union to build a
plane
and
so so this is some of the a few of the
interesting facts about this plane and i
won't go into all the details that's
what we got the experts here for but uh
i will briefly introduce the panel just
briefly and then i'll let george say
here because george uh knows the story
of us just about as well as anyone but
uh i'll start with the dennis uh
gen bridger general dennis sullivan he
was one of our
ci 812 pilots
back to him with lockheed engineer he
worked on the um
uh a12 uh article number 121 we called
the plains articles
the uh the pilots were called drivers
and the cameras were called packages uh
he he worked on article 121 he also
worked on the
yf-12 which was the experimental
modified a12 the air force was
interested in it getting the
mark iii
interceptor fighter and he worked on
that and a little bit on the
d21 program which was a drone that we
would launch at mark 3 off the back of
the
mother ship a modified a12
and then send it over to china or any of
the bad boys and take a picture of them
and then drop it off at sea and pick it
up and get it developed so that's what
some of what robert did we got frank
murray
[Applause]
frank murray is a dear old friend of
mine also he lived up to gardner bill
he was also a cia pilot
frank murray one of his claims to fame
was when the us
uh uss pueblo was seized in 1968 he flew
the second mission over north korea to
see what was going on we didn't know
whether it was an incident or a act of
war so he went in and took a peek to see
if they were mobilizing for war
he probably even looked around the
neighborhood a little bit further than
that but he won't admit it nor will ca
but anyway he um he did come back and uh
one thing he did learn on this mission
is they had moved the boat the ship uh
we had flown the mission two weeks
earlier with a
former pilot named jack weeks who uh
unfortunately we lost just that the uh
project was ending we lost him into in
the pacific ocean
but uh jack did find the the ship uh
frank did not he found that it had been
moved
uh the next uh gentleman is a lieutenant
general uh lord levitt did levitt
uh he flew the u2
[Applause]
and then we and the last one i'll let
him tell more about himself because i
don't talk lieutenant general's a little
bit above my pay grade i'm just not
gonna talk about what all he did
uh
then we got ron gerard ron gerard was
one of our
navigators
[Applause]
ron's job
at the area was to plan routes for this
plane flying at 2200 miles an hour which
is faster than a bullet
to avoid going over any large populated
cities here in the in the united states
including here in the
uh in nevada so there's a picture out
that would
cause the least impact on the uh the
people
it was also his job when the uh
the reports for the dishonored boom
started pouring into nellis and other
places to look to lay the blame on the
navy it's valid we did not exist
so i i'm going to turn it over to george
but george knows the rest of it and he
pulled the story out because each of
these gentlemen has got some great
stories uh that they need needs to be
told and we do appreciate this
opportunity to
inform you and give our people i wish we
could do the same for the rest of the
people out here they'll some will have
their chance tomorrow and we hope some
of you will come tomorrow and talk to
the rest of our people that could not be
on the panels they will be setting the
tables out in the lobby and be glad to
answer any questions you have so
george knapp have at it
[Applause]
good evening everyone thanks for being
here the the atomic testing museum of
course uh appreciate you all being here
i know a lot of you are drawn by this
particular event because it is going to
be really interesting but i hope if you
haven't had a chance to tour the museum
you take a look either this time or the
next time you come back because it is a
world-class facility
we expect to
have an invigorating and enlightening uh
cacophony of conversation here tonight
with a panel of these cold war warriors
to talk about the most famous best known
secret base in the world uh and what
went on out there
uh groom lake area 51 whatever name you
use it's been sort of part of my life
for more than 20 years not in the same
way as for
the folks up here on tonight's panel i
guess i've been out there maybe a
hundred times you know uh dodging uh
dust devils and security patrols uh over
the years just to see what we could see
from the outside
and while i realized i'm never going to
be allowed to go inside and look around
it still played a big role in my life
and probably when i die there'll be
something about area 51 in my obituary
rightly or wrongly
it hasn't been that long ago that
tonight's uh events simply would not
have been possible as td mentioned the
government i think still gets a little
lump in its throat a little cough in its
throat when it has to admit that there's
anything out there other than
coyotes and dirt clods
the men on tonight's panel were sworn to
secrecy and oath so serious that as
mentioned they couldn't even tell their
own spouses what was going on out there
or what they did but as we now know some
of the secrets of groom lake some of
them have been declassified to an extent
in recent times in part because of the
efforts of of td and some of the other
roadrunners and it's a story that needs
to be told
the folks who toiled in obscurity out in
area 51 to a large degree and i'm not
exaggerating are responsible for our
side winning the cold war and as we're
going to hear tonight cold war is not
always an accurate term it was a hot war
at a lot of times although the american
public wasn't allowed to hear those
stories about what was going on
these folks developed the eyes and ears
of our intelligence agencies developed
them right out there in the nevada
desert
they were and are the most amazing
planes ever built
and until that day arrives when you know
they allow me to go into the base and
kick open the doors to the hangar where
they keep all the flying saucers i would
say
i would say that these flying machines
developed there there are still the best
the world has ever produced our world
anyway and uh i am very thankful to td
for helping to uh
convince the rest of the roadrunners to
forgive me my earlier transgressions
regarding stories i've aired about area
51 over the years uh over the last
couple of years as mentioned i've had a
chance to get to know he and some of the
other roadrunners that show up at their
events and you know there's a couple of
raised eyebrows here and there once in a
while but i'll tell you without
exaggeration i can't get enough of this
stuff uh the stories are wonderful and
important and they're funny and tonight
you get to hear them too you might have
mentioned i'll give a plug to the cia
store it's like crazy eddie's house of
spy stuff if you want to buy something
out there and of course the museum has a
store of its own
i also want to recognize susan peterson
she's here representing congresswoman
dina titus who's a major supporter susan
say hi
dina titus is a major supporter of the
atomic testing museum i think she's got
a reading room over there and has
written a book about the test site and
i'm sure would be here tonight if she
could now as for proceeding tonight
there is no procedure as far as i know
it's sort of like what they did out at
area 51 we're flying by the seat of our
pants here so i'm going to start with uh
starting this way we're going to tell
some stories later on you'll have a
chance to ask your own questions
starting on the other end let's let's do
it this way let's start with how you
were recruited to work out there what
they told you you were going to do or
what they didn't tell you what you're
going to do and what did you actually do
starting at the end
well i was at
large air force base
just a crew dog navigator
and one day
personnel called me and said
we have this twix
for you and it's
can you hear me now
i was a crew dog navigator a b-52 at
march air force base and one day
personnel called me and said we have
this message in
and i went down there real quick and it
said
would you be interested in working on a
classified project in the western united
states
yes
so anyway i went back
several weeks later i went back to
washington dc
not knowing any more than
that
and um
from the pentagon i went to this other
little building someplace up there in
washington dc
and in this room this guy said would you
be interested in working for the cia
and i said yeah i would because it
doesn't sound like the thing to do
so the next morning i went
from the pentagon down
that concourse or whatever it was below
there
and got on this little unmarked thing
and went out to langley the cia
headquarters
and for the next
three or four days
i was in the black box with i was wired
for sound
and they asked me every question
they knew people that i had forgotten
everybody did
and they said okay that'll be all so i
went back to riverside march
and for the next month or so i knew that
with all these bad answers that i gave
them that would be the end of it
and
lo and behold here come this order to go
to las vegas nevada
post office box 882
1129th
special activity square
well actually i was assigned to bowling
air force base
but permanent duty station post office
box 88 to
1129 special activities squadron las
vegas
so i showed up and then
i called this number
and the next morning
this walt smith was not here tonight
came by and picked me up and
he said do you know anything about this
and i said no i don't he said we'll
brief you on the way
so we rode 60 miles out to mercury and
uh on the way he said do you know
anything about
project and i said no i don't
but anyway after 60 miles this is not
too far to go
but then we entered the test site we
drove another 60 miles up to
area 51
and we got there and i
uh
he took me out and showed me the a12
and to me it was the most beautiful
thing i've ever seen in my life it was
also a little sinister looking but i i
said that's it
and after that uh he took me the chow
hall and
murphy green gave me some good food
i said this is what i want to do
and until the very last until they
kicked me out of the area 51 in november
of
69 i was a lawyer member i went on
several
black shield
deployments planning missions over
vietnam and
thoroughly thoroughly enjoyed it it was
the highlight of my 20 years in the air
force
[Applause]
go ahead
general
i'm going to digress from the
makeshift uh script that we have here
for a moment
we had a little discussion about this
i'm not as strong an advocate as what
started this thing as some people might
be
so i want to go back to the beginning
if you go back to late
1940s we were the dominant nuclear power
in the world in fact the only one
in 1953 i believe it was
the soviets took away our thermonuclear
monopoly by exploding a nuclear
thermonuclear weapon
earlier it exploded a
nagasaki-sized weapon but the first time
they really
had hit with a big time with the
thermonuclear was i believe in 1953.
there was a great concern in the air
force and elsewhere about how far along
were the
the soviets with developing
an air force to carry these tnn weapons
and there was a disagreement about did
they or did they not have a long-range
bomber
eisenhower was president at that time
and he was very concerned about it
because one of the the chief of staff of
the air force had been over to moscow
and had seen an airshow with some
bombers in it but we weren't sure what
the bombers were and what the
capabilities were
so when they came back they decided that
we had to know more about the soviets
now you have to remember at that time we
tried to find a lot about the soviets
eisenhower had asked for open skies
politician policy so we could overfly
him soviets declined
we tried floating balloons over the
soviet union
and like most balloons they didn't work
very well so
you couldn't really describe the path of
and forecast the path of a balloon so
that didn't work out very well
the next thing that was talked about was
well let's get an airplane over there
and that's when he had asked for a
khrushchev to go for open skies policy
khrushchev as i mentioned decline
and so i said okay we've got to get some
inter intelligence about this and the
cia
then came forward why don't we fly
airplanes over there
and then there came a big argument
between the air force and the cia about
who would develop the airplane and who
would be responsible for it
by the laws at that time and being
and i hope i don't step on too many cia
toes now but this is what the law said
that was an air force responsibility
uh the cia persuaded uh
eisenhower that really that the
important development aspect of it could
be handled better by industry and to
some extent at least they were true of
that
as far as the aircraft development
the air force thought it was our job
according to the agreements that had
been signed at that time that the air
force should develop the airplane
the air force was shot down on the idea
and despite the fact that we depended
upon air force of people
in the sense of pilots and whatnot to uh
to man these things
so
leaping ahead eisner had a
election
facing him in 1956
and he wanted to solve this problem by
that time
so he put a very tight time constraint
on
lockheed who got the contract to build
this airplane
and as one of that was the seventh air
force pilot to fly the u2 and when i
left the year i left the youtube program
i had more time in the u-2 than anybody
did
but be that as it may
the airplane that we got from the
original development was not a very good
airplane in terms of safety
the cia got an airplane with a better
engine in it the air force got the
older and less less effective engine
and there were a lot of things in the
design of the airplane that were bad in
the original
in the original u2 a lot of good things
i'm very proud to have been with that
program at that time but nevertheless
there were a lot of mistakes in the
original u2 no ejection seat an airplane
that flamed out at altitude if it was
throttled was moving in the wrong
direction until we got the
the newer engine uh i had a very
interesting experience on a test up with
that new
with the first of the new engines
i'd been flying the u2 about a little
over three months i guess at that point
i was on a test top
and i was at about 70 thousand feet
and the engine quit
and
that didn't bother me too much except
it started to frost over inside the
cockpit and i couldn't see very well
so i called the tower and called him and
told him i would flame it out and i'd go
down to 35 000 where we could relight it
the tower kept talking to me i finally
told him never mind i know how to
re-light the airplane so i got down to
35 000
and it wouldn't relate and then then the
tower really got excited what are you
doing wrong you know what do you know
you can imagine the things i said look i
know how to re-light this thing it won't
rely
well it turned out that
i gave up on that and they finally shut
up and i was able to find the rio grande
river and
by scraping uh the side of the
canopy i could look out and find the rio
grande and i
managed to
find
laughlin from that point and and we was
able to dead stick it into laughlin by
landing it and looking out the left
window where i'd scrape the hole
and it turned out pretty well
but that was just one of the problems we
had another we didn't have ejection seat
we had one guy that was clearly killed
because he didn't have ejection seat
we had another group of people that were
killed because the oxygen system was a
high pressure oxygen system and they had
impurities in it
and they froze the
uh
the valve that that let let the air get
up to the pilot's place so we had a lot
of complaints about the original
airplane out of the first
i wrote the number down here i think it
was out of the first 38 pilots at the
air force train
eight of them were killed in the first
two years
and four more were eliminated from the
program
and then as the years went by
as the years went by and the airplane
improved we stopped some of that
slaughter if you want to call it that
but we were kind of used to losing
pilots in those days i was in the f-84f
program before that we lost 55 pilots in
one year if you can imagine in that
airplane so the u2 looked like a good
deal compared
how did i find out about the youtube
program well guys like gary power and
knutson and other people that i knew at
tournament turned around all of a sudden
disappearing they were all reserve
officers
and the reserve officer could revert to
his
reserve commission and leave active duty
and that's what's what they were
promised that they could do and they
would also get paid while they're there
by by lockheed
so these guys
left and and we were kind of wondering
where they went and pretty soon somebody
figured out that there was a project
called dragon lady and they all seemed
to be going to that
so a good friend of mine and i figured
out what driving lady was it was like
the flying tigers in world war ii we
were going to go over kimoy and matsu
and fight the chinese
and we're pretty confident that that was
it then we found out we had to get
pressure suits and we didn't know an
airplane that would fly high enough to
need a pressure suit but we thought well
maybe they've got something to do that
and it'd be great to have a fighter that
you could swoop down from way up high
and you know get
well anyhow the first time that i ever
actually got involved closely closer
with it my squadron commander called me
one day we were still back at turner and
i already passed the physical and got
the pressure suit and all that
and uh he said dick are you are you
ready to go out to
project dragon lady i said yeah i've
been ready now for four or five months
and he said well
i watched this was a thursday he said i
want you to be out of march field on
monday
and this was in albany georgia i said no
problem is it temporary duty tdy he said
no pcs
well i
it was late in the afternoon when this
happened right after lunch actually i
called the moving man
my i told my wife get ready to go we're
leaving right away the movie man came
that afternoon
and i was on the road the next morning
with boyd driving out to marshfield and
the uh
my wife threw all her clothes in the in
the bathtub so the packers wouldn't pack
him
and we left and i didn't see her again
for five months
but uh when we uh
when we finally got to the ranch
uh from march field
uh i i still hadn't seen the airplane
didn't have a real good idea
what it looked like
and uh
the first thing that happened when i got
out of the airplane they had a little
hut let me say near the where the
airplanes were being pulled out of the
c124s
and they said levitt go over there and
get in that hut and somebody wants to
talk to you so i got in the hut here's a
guy in a dark room
with a light behind him sitting at a
desk and he said
captain levitt i'm going to cut out the
bad words he said kevin levin i want you
to understand you volunteered for this
very high classified program and if you
ever say a word about this to anybody
including your wife
they'll never see your
in this world again
he said do you understand that and i
said yes sir
so they said they were going to watch us
all the time on weekends and everything
else well it turned out that
we got run out of the ranch by the about
the time that we finished the program
because one of the one of the
explosions that were going on there got
a little too hot for us and it started
contaminating the area around there and
so we had to move to a different place
and that's when we moved to the laughlin
air force base
so i went down to lofton air force base
and spent the next three and a half
years
i was chief of standardization down
there and wrote
the good youtube handbook lockheed gave
us one that wasn't worth a damn and it
didn't apply to the air force policies
or whatnot so we fat haller and i and
steve eiser and another guy rewrote the
book
and that was a project and we pulled a
lot of tdy doing
what they called hass which was high
altitude nuclear sampling we did that
all over the world i had any one day uh
the air force the u2s would fly
starting from uh
uh
this going south first they would fly
from down to puerto rico and then from
puerto rico down to buenos aires and
from buenos aires down to the down to
antarctica
then at the same time another set of
u2's would fly up to plattsburgh air
force base and then up from there to the
arctic circle and then back down
and somewhere in there was a puerto rico
too
so we did that off and on for uh
particularly during the
international
geophysical year because we could
disguise it
and that's where some of this talk about
the we were doing weather sampling came
actually we were looking for high
altitude nuclear glass now somebody
might say well why did you split the
hemispheres like that
we split the hemispheres very good very
good reason we didn't know where the
nuclear debris from
south america the french were
detonating nuclear weapons in the in the
south pacific we didn't know where that
nuclear debris was going
we weren't real sure where the stuff in
the north was going either to come from
the things in the pacific
so we chased those things endless hours
and it was a pretty good thing we found
out more about how they were building
their weapons
where the debris was going and later on
when i became vice commander of sac it
was very useful information to us
because it told us where the hot spots
would be
where we could best keep our aircraft if
we were under a nuclear nuclear attack
and so on so those are very interesting
years to me
i left the u2 program under kind of
strange circumstances
i was flying a mission we had a we had a
u2 detachment from laughlin it was
flying missions over
the northern part of the soviet union
the arctic
area
at the same time flying down the
siberian coast
i had a mission one day
it happened to be the last day of april
where my mission was to fly down to
petropovlas which is down in the
on the those geographical you know
everybody knows where that is i'm sure
and you know it's a big seaport on the
on the pacific side of the of that
peninsula
and i flew that mission down there was a
long mission got chased by migs or
whatever they were on the way back and
it always gave me kind of a satisfying
feeling to look down and see those
suckers trying to come up and get me and
i couldn't get me
so anyhow when i got back and landed in
uh in alaska
uh we didn't know what had happened but
all of a sudden we were grounded
and and then the next day we read in the
magazines that one of the uh
weather reconnaissance aircraft out
flying out of turkey had gotten lost and
was
was down somewhere in the sea of aden or
wherever they said it was
it turned about
turned out to be gary power
who was in my flight in f-84s before he
went to the civilian life so to speak
we didn't know as soon as we knew that
it was a u2 we were worried about who
this was and then they came out with a
broadcast that it was
doing
wasn't doing a reconnaissance it was
just on a some kind of a test i forget
exactly how they were but it wasn't
anything that would involve the soviet
union and i felt this is one of the
biggest mistakes
cia ever made
because they convinced eisenhower that
that
nobody could survive if they were hit by
a missile
and nobody then the airplane the pilot
would
perhaps kill himself because there was a
place in youtube you could pull a handle
and the airplane would blow up i always
felt the guy who designed that never
been in an airplane where he was in
really trouble
i i had a bailout during the korean war
and it was all i could do to get out of
the airplane there was so many g's on
the airplane when it blew up
and uh you know i couldn't even move my
arm much less reach over and think oh it
only takes 40 seconds to pull this you
know
so we all ridiculed that and i and power
didn't try that either but it's tough to
get out of an airplane when it's out of
control just it's not the kind of thing
that you want to be in
so anyhow
the next day we found out that uh it was
our friend gary bar
and then they grounded us and wouldn't
let us fly even over canada for a while
and then finally we could do a few
missions
in northern canada but we were not
allowed to fly back over canada when we
returned the united states
at that point i decided that eisenhower
said we weren't going to do that more
unfortunately khrushchev took him to a
task in the paris convention or meeting
that was there that year and we were
caught with a big lie and a big disgrace
to the united states
and i can't understand until this day
how the cia could cook up a [ __ ] and
bull story like they had you know just
ridiculous and crew chef caught us with
her
pants down you might say and
and uh the idea was that nobody could
survive a thing like that and
you know just and nobody could shoot it
down and we'd known for years that they
could be shot down and from the first
flights over
over europe the soviets attracted and
caught him
so uh
i don't know i felt that was a real
black mark on the united states and one
that i
i i'm not critic criticizing the people
that work with people in the cia but the
top guys in there that went fed
fed eisenhower that
vote of baloney we really did this
country in this service hey general
levitt we're going to move on we'll come
back to you if you don't mind i'm lying
okay
we your some of your colleagues might
like to say something though
i'm glad but this is what we had
discussed earlier sure i want to leap
ahead now uh a statement was made
earlier that was very important
uh that we hold the technology edge in
the world and we did that with the
follow-on aircraft that were built for
for reconnaissance
there's no doubt that the a12
the sr-71
the f-12 and
and other spin-offs of these aircraft
were technically the best aircraft in
the world and we led that lead that
league forever it seemed like until
finally after the cold war ended it
became apparent that they were too
expensive to keep
and
the congress felt that it was more
important
that we developed the satellite
capabilities and one thing that people
don't understand about satellites and
i'm going to say this sure
satellite is on a predictable path
and you can't take a reconnaissance
aircraft it's loose and say it's on a
predictable path sometimes we wish they
were more predictable than they are but
anyhow
and the
the satellites cannot solve all the
problems in the world
you can take a if you know a satellite
is going to fly over you every 24 hours
what you do is you close the hangar
doors
or you move whatever it is or whatever
is necessary you take a reconnaissance
aircraft like a812 or sr-71 and you can
spot it
while i was in vice commander sack the
issue came up what are we going to do
with the sr-71
i'd flown the sr-71 wasn't a crew in it
but i'd flown it and i was convinced we
had to keep the airplane but there was a
lot of pressure to sell off some of them
so we we agreed to take it down to half
strength and we took i think
12 of them got rid of them kept the
other 12 something like that
then after
after carter came in office the pressure
was put on again to get rid of the
others the air force was given a choice
do you want to get rid of a bomb wing or
do you want to get rid of the remaining
sr-71s
and uh and we got rid of the other 71s
so that was too bad but it was an end of
a wonderful era in terms of american
engineering
uh the flying the people that flew the
airplanes and everything the maintenance
people that flew the airplanes and so on
and if i could take one more minute i
got one sure
during the vietnam war i was a fighter
wing commander and when i left the wing
i
i wrote an editorial which i want to
read just part of and i want to talk to
the people of how many people were
enlisted people
or ncos and so on and so on and here
great
here's what i wrote and this is just
part of there
air war is teamwork with a gallon of
sweat on the ground for a drop of sweat
in the air
the linebackers in this ball game pump
fuel the safety walks a canine through
the dark knight
the offensive line fixes telephones
repairs
airplanes loads 500 pounders
cooks meals orders parts shuffles paper
the coach sits at 25 000 in hillsborough
orbit and a quarterback drops bombs
instead of throwing them we don't have
any breakup breakaway runners there are
none
and that's the way i feel about the
enlisted force
i think we depend greatly on them
thanks general
frank
frank
i bet you can hear me
can you hear me mike
okay
uh frank murray
the junior ranking man on the board here
and uh
i'll be brief about how i got involved
with oxcart
uh
it came about
in 1962 when they were i think looking
for
support people for the program
not project pilots in my case
and i was enlisted and went through the
same things i think that ron did about
going up the agency and filling out a
questionnaire longer than
the bed sheet
which told them the same thing end to
end
it ended up out there as a chase pilot
primarily at 51. this is in the summer
of
63.
and i did that for a couple of years and
then they had some losses within the
program people go on and people died and
crashed and whatnot and they needed
another body or two
and here uh within their group was a guy
who could probably do that and the
general in charge of the whole thing
jack ledford
said asked me one day you want to fly
that thing
yeah throw me in that puddle
so that's how i got started it was i was
an inside job
all the other project pilots had been
selected with great uh skill and cunning
from everywhere and they went through
all kinds of selection testing and all
of that and i i sneaked in under the
door like the camel's nose under the
tent
and i stayed to the end of the program i
was one of the six operational a12
pilots that did the mission
there was about 11 total started and
trained in various ways some quit some
died some left i don't know what
happened but there were six of us that
did the job three of them are in the
room tonight
jack layton over in the corner
put your hand up jack
and of course uh denny sullivan and
yours truly
at the end of the program i went back in
the air force and went back to flying my
favorite fighters and did that until 77
and then i retired
[Applause]
my name is bob rodert
i'm kind of alone up here and that
i'm one of the guys that helped
kick the tires and light the fires on
the airplane but um i um
i went to ucla and uh went to work for
lockheed burbank in about 1960 and in
the middle of 61
boss of mine got recruited into the
skunk works which is a part of lockheed
burbank
it's headed by kelly johnson and a team
of people but anyhow my boss got
recruited into the skunk works and he
just went away he said hey see you guys
later and a week or so later we'll uh i
got a phone call from him that said
you want to come over and join me and i
said what are you doing he said i can't
tell you but it's pretty good and so
bottom line is uh i had been working on
electro's and f-104s and i'm an
aeronautic aeronautical engineer so any
of this stuff is like great toys and i
love to fly
and so he said come on over go pick up a
badge and report for duty i got a badge
just a little round thing this big that
you pinned to your shirt with some
pictures on it and i was allowed to walk
through the door of a hangar that was
built in a-12s it was
obviously very secure because it worked
but i'll never forget the day that i
walked through that door there was a
guard there that just looked at my
picture badge and i walked in and was
like jules vern
there were airplanes in that hangar
getting built
all different stages nobody met me at
the door
and uh i walked up to a mezzanine and
and i got introduced i got a little tour
of it but i had no idea up to that point
what was going on at lockheed everybody
wanted to know of course all over
burbank all over la what's going on
in that skunk works because there were
cars parked out there and there were
connie's coming and going all day long
but they kept the secret very well
six months later after i got my
clearance
i just got a chat that said you can
climb on a connie at seven in the
morning and nobody told me where i was
going i just uh climbed on they said
you're going to come back on friday or
saturday and say goodbye to everybody
and uh you know go to work
we initially had one super connie
operating out of burbank flew into the
area every morning came back every night
and so i i'll never forget the first
flight we just took off from burbank and
flew kind of a dynamic profile that took
us up over
uh the the hills next to burbank and up
to about 10 000 feet or so and then we
started letting down
next thing you know i'm touching down on
a runway that looks like it goes forever
and i had no idea that this place
existed or where i was going but
i was met by a security guy at the other
end and said come with me son took a
picture of me gave me a badge and i went
to work it was area 51 and
the airplane which is article 121 had
just made its first flight so this was
in about april of 62.
there was a lot of talk about
how it was flying the first flight was
an accident the second flight was on
purpose
but it was actually up and flying on the
uh the j75 engines
uh i went to work on instrumentation so
the uh the guy that i was working for
and i were in charge of all of the
instrumentation on the first article
which meant that we had hundreds if not
thousands of measurements big bundles of
wire
and and uh
what was called the cube a which is
where the photographic payload
eventually went was full of recorders
and we basically were in charge of
kicking the tires and lighting the fires
as far as instrumentation was concerned
so every flight that came back we had to
download all of the data processed it
through photographically and send it to
burbank on the next shuttle so the
bottom line is i was out there for about
two two and a half years
i had an opportunity to go to edwards
when lbj announced the uh yf-12 program
and so
he released that to the public and i
went to edwards got married spent a year
or so we we flew the yf-12 on some
incredible missions i know that's kind
of
off the table a little bit here but the
yf12 did start out there at area 51
and
it was it turned out to be an excellent
interceptor very few people knew about
it it was not really classified but we
were we were flying it uh just as a
separate project but with just the
typical mission for the yf12 and then
i'll shut up but uh
we would uh tow the thing out of the
barn at about six in the morning kick it
loose it'd probably be airborne by 7 or
7 30 with a missile loaded up in a
missile bay
it would fly
across the u.s
get a get a refueling over texas as i
recall
go across the rest of the us and launch
against the drone out over the atlantic
missile range which was off of florida
he'd turn around pick up another drink
over texas and be back on the hank back
on the ground and in the hangar by noon
so that's what that airplane would do
and we had several direct hits
uh the thing that makes you a little bit
um
i guess aware of what the politics were
uh a fellow by the name of mcnamara was
our secretary of defense at the time
and he had an airplane that was called
f-111
and his 111 was supposed to do
everything for everybody
and we proved that it couldn't do
anything and we had an airplane that was
excellent they'd worked the bugs out the
missile and the radar had been developed
by hughes for the f-108 mcnamara was not
section
well he's the one that canceled it oh
okay
i'm sorry that guy that canceled it
was uh
his successor afterwards
okay
yeah okay well and
then we've been cussing out the wrong
guy
oh he might have had it too
kelly got kind of tweaked by that whole
process and as i understand it he cut up
the tooling for the airplane and so
there was never going to be any more of
them built so at any rate i was a happy
young engineer i wanted to get out of
the desert so after a year or so at
edwards i moved up to sunnyvale ended up
working on several more skunk works
programs because i knew the guys and i
had the clearances and
we did some things still out at area 51
that as far as i know i'm not supposed
to talk about but anyhow come on it was
it was a
it was really a great place to work uh i
didn't realize how exciting the the
project was in terms of technology for
probably a few more years because it was
all titanium it had fluids and wires and
the whole airplane was basically
invented from the ground up and uh the
people that made it work were excellent
and you know it starts with the people
back at adp skunk works but included the
folks at pratt whitney and ham standard
and just an incredible team of people
and kelly johnson at the top of it was a
tyrant but sometimes that's what it
takes you've got to be be able to yell
and scream and be heard down the hall
but he made people get the job done and
that's what can happen if you have a
person like kelly
leading the pack
so anyhow that's how i got on it and uh
and i've been a nice 40-year program as
a systems engineer thanks bob
general sullivan
i should probably start and tell you how
i got into the program
very briefly i i was flying f-106 as a
very nice airplane really up in mccord
air force base and i got a message
addressed to me personally
it is one sentence long
the chief of staff united states air
force would like to know if you would
volunteer for a program of great
interest to him
now how do you answer that
other than
the way i did i sent the one word
message back
yes
and that triggered off uh
sending me through what
at that time was the
entire
astronaut physical and mental
requirement programming went through the
whole shebang just like an astronaut
and eventually they fitted me up with a
pressure suit and told me
[Music]
that i had been selected for this
program
and that i should find a place to live
in the los angeles area and move my
family down there and
go from there
and that's what happened i went to the
area which is the first time i've ever
seen the place
and had all these nice black airplanes
sitting around there and i thought holy
smokes i think i did the right thing
and
[Music]
it went from there through a very brief
training program into the airplane
through the years
you know a lot of things happened and
now he's getting into a lot of that
but i might mention one operational
mission out of okinawa down over
north vietnam
i went they had
three days of
absolutely clear weather in october 1966
which is probably a record for those
guys it was always cloudy down there
but i flew the first day
and got a lot of indications in the
cockpit that the sam sites were tracking
me
and you make two passes one end then you
go down around
bangkok gas up turn around come back
pretty heavy on fuel
but you get up to speed but not quite as
much altitude as you like
so two days later i'm down there again
and going in
but all the sam site tracking signals
were blanking all over the place and i
thought oh this folks they're gonna do
something here
well they didn't shoot at me going in
but i gassed up again down in thailand
flying back up made the turn going
overhead away
and all the signals start coming up
again
uh
along with one that said
this has been launched
so
i'm going along uh you know paying
attention to flying the airplane but
looking around a little bit too
and of all things
while i'm doing that you never see
anything you know flying by up at that
altitude
here comes a big old telephone pole
you know sailing right by the cockpit
going straight up
that's interesting
uh so i continued down the route uh
[Music]
as i went along there were more signals
and more things and all that and i
didn't see anything looking around until
i got
down the road a bit and then you can see
behind me and you have a rear view
kind of a little periscope like a rear
view mirror
there were about uh
you know i don't know how many i think
there's at least four missiles
contrails and they're all kind of just
spread out from the vertical a little
bit
which
our ecm system did turn them off
and then all of these four contrails
went up around
90 95 000 feet
they all turned over
and were
bunched up in in the line headed for me
right up my
tln
and
it was kind of interesting you know i
said holy smokes those things fly pretty
good up there for something that doesn't
have much in the way of wings
you know they're up uh you know
eighty-five thousand feet ninety
thousand feet
so i watched them come they could see
all the contrails and they get up right
behind me
very close and all of a sudden there'd
be a big red fireball
a big black cloud of smoke
and you immediately pulled away from it
you're going a half a mile
uh
you know a minute or so you're you're
i think i said that wrong we're going 30
miles a minute
but
every one of those
sams
guided absolutely perfectly and did the
same darn thing
and
when i debriefed the folks
in okinawa when i got back
a good thing happened
i got a piece of the nose views
off one of the sams actually got
embedded in the airplane
and during the debriefing somebody came
running in with that and so all of a
sudden they went from ho-hum to
well maybe that really did happen
and
yeah right
so
i i guess i'm the only one that
has had of the blackbirds that i know of
i don't know about all the srs of course
but uh
that was a
a serious attempt to shoot one of us
down and it could have been successful
except for the performance of the
airplane primarily you know the speed
was so fast that the missiles got up to
their normal detonation range and boom
they go off and you're just fast enough
to outrun all the fly
uh kind of a
little uh afterthought to all of that in
a way
was uh i was talking to somebody that
had access to
the folks that listened to what's going
on on the ground in vietnam
and the air defense commander you know
after all their planning and training
and everything the shoot went down
it was matter and the son of a gun and
he said the guy's down in the sights he
says
why the hell did you get him
and the answer came back
he goes too fast
so
with that i probably leave it at that
there are other missions that well i
might mention one other very quick thing
uh
the last flight i had in okinawa
the weatherman braved me that it was
very marginal they wouldn't have a
satellite picture until it was about
halfway down there
so i took off and it was down around the
philippines heading
vietnam
and
i had the shortwave radio volume up and
along comes the signal
and
uh they boarded the mission
i turned around and i've got nothing to
do and i got a pretty good fuel load so
i thought
my last flight in okinawa and then the
program's gonna end
so no hurry to get back
so so i came out of afterburner and i
said i'll just take my time going back
and let this thing slow down get
subsonic
guess what
i
the airplane descended down
to about
1.8 or mach 2
and i flew all the way back to okinawa
at that speed
without the afterburner i uh i mentioned
that to the folks that debrief and the
injured guy said and the other white
people
said well you know
we never checked that in the fly in the
test program but we probably should have
but the darn airplane would maintain
well over 1.5 mark without the
afterburner and that's an amazing
performance with that
hey dennis did you keep that little
piece of stuff yeah did you keep it oh
well yeah i don't have it with me i
uh
when i was hit by the
it's a piece of the nose fuse on this on
the sand
because about your little fingernail
but
the folks that looked at it carefully
said the
russian threads are
you know very visible and
identifiable and i have it i took that
and they cut a little piece out of the
airplane now about you know two or three
inches
where they put a patch on the airplane
i have both of those stuck together i
had an okinawan guy put it in a
kind of uh
he molded it into a piece of plastic so
i wouldn't loosen it so darn small so i
have it in kind of a plastic brick
and still having
it'd be like your lucky charm
[Applause]
td i know you were recruited you you had
an idea
when you were at the time you were
recruited you already had an idea there
was something going on in groomed lake
you'd been sort of watching the area
from afar right
yes i did before before we go into that
uh dennis tell them about uh
landing it
are you you want to tell that story over
again you tell this
okay
last last meeting story over again so
those of you who were listening uh you
know you'll find this very familiar
melva favorite is a very good friend of
mine one of our pilots uh now deceased
unfortunately but uh
mel and i were very close friends and
i was flying about at the same admission
the test mission at the same time he did
and i as i landed i met him
and uh
he says uh hey dennis
uh you'll never believe what i did today
and i'm thinking to myself now what
and then he said i said wow okay now
what the hell did you do
he says well he says
when we fly these test missions out of
the area unrefueled you go up most of
the way to canada and you come back and
you and you're at speeding about 85 88
89 000 feet and you're going along
and then you have to come out of
afterburner and you have to throttle
back some
and you you make a big circle you go
about two-thirds of the way to mexico
and
wander around and then he finally gets
sub-sonic and he probably got a hundred
and some miles left to get back to the
area
and he says he was tired of doing that
he says there got to be a better way to
do that the airplane has no speed brakes
or anything
so he's coming back on one of those
missions
and the gear down speed is 300 knots
indicated
it's going back 3-2 also knows that it's
the indicated air speed below 300 knots
plow
throws down the landing gear going mach
3.
and i said holy smokes it says what
happened
he says got noisy as hell
the shockwave's going everywhere
and
so he continued down
and he landed and everything seemed to
be okay
and uh i talked to him uh you know after
the debriefing i said how did you
debriefing go he said well it was going
along very smoothly and the
locking engineer was going along writing
all these notes until i got to the part
where i dropped the gear going mach 3.
at which point his pencil just went snap
and
after about three minutes a very quiet
voice said
you what
but anyway uh that's the only
that is a world record that will
probably never be broken
not even the you know the astronauts
they don't even put the gear down super
sunny
[Applause]
td your recruitment
well i was about like a rave in a bucket
among a bunch of ducks for these these
people first of all i was army
my job was to shoot their tails down i
was on surface air missiles it was a
good thing uh dennis that i wasn't
sitting there shooting those missiles he
would have made it home
oh
they uh
my background was that
i started korea the intelligence
specialist and um
oh i did a little deed over there that
drew the attention of a i was still
about to e4
through the attention of a two-star
general and uh
he kind of adopted me and when uh
rotation was up he said son you need to
get into the electronics then
he urged me to get into the missile
field which i did and i got to fort
bliss texas and
once my first school lasted for a year
and i was going to texas western at
night or so i was a full-time student
i got out of school and they just
started another one and the one i just
finished was already out of sleep it was
a nike ajax so i signed up for another
year
went through every time i got out of
that i had enough rank you couldn't they
just put me doing anything they didn't
have assignment for me so i signed up
for the for another one
and i started advancing into uh i got
interested in electronic countermeasures
and electronic counter counter majors
which is um the jamming and anti-jamming
and the the planes do the uh
ecm it's electronic countermeasures and
our job is to
figure out what they're going to do and
get through it and that's your count of
countermeasures
anyway i had gotten to become sort of an
expert in this field and
the cia has started project palladium
trying to evaluate the capabilities of
the
soviet radars around the world because
we at that time we still didn't know
what their capability was
and we knew they moved some
soviet aircraft into cuba we didn't know
about the missiles at that time and
raytheon had just built the hawk missile
and we were still
fine-tuning it it wasn't ready to go
operational so they uh
grabbed me to work for the team of them
and we'd like to
load this missile up into the belly of a
plane take the nose phone off of it
and head towards cuban we get close in
we would start radiating the uh their
planes with the cw signal magnet thanks
to the incoming missile coming at them
and they turn on their jammers and uh
and i'd watch that old the nose thrown
on my missile and as soon as i could see
the jamming was getting through to it
and start drifting off i'd start
tweaking here tweaking there and we were
recording all of this
and learning how to get through their
systems and uh they uh after a couple of
three times of this they got wise to it
and they uh took a couple shots at it so
we had to knock it off and uh
but that called that's the first time i
worked for dr bud wheelon with the cia
and who incidentally was the head of the
arch card program later there in fifth
one
but my long short short i got out of
service i got disabled then
got injured and it wrote my military
career so i had all this electronic
experience so
nasa grabbed me to for the nasa high
range tracking the x15 the xb70 with
developing these lunar landing vehicles
we had what we call the lifting bodies
that was the
prototypes for the space shuttle all of
this was going on and especially plus we
started
tracking the y of 12. we uh i
participated in the speed run that um
bob talked about
and
tracking the
uh x15 we had the capability of
recording velocity where most radars
stations don't necessarily have that
they don't care they just want to know
where you're at and so they hit you
track you
so i started getting calls from the
agency they didn't say where they called
it from they didn't say what they were
going to be tracking but they said we
got a plane we want you to track and
record the velocity and
don't let anyone know what you're doing
you lock the room the doors of the room
go in and track it bundle it up and
we'll come pick it up and that was in
store they didn't tell me what was
tracking
but the baby i was at baby is where it's
located radar sat there
we're not that far from groomed lake and
i i'd get out of curiosity how to get in
on the radar that really wasn't my job i
was a morbid at that time of
well they called me a
a hypersonic flight support specialist
which meant i knew telemetry radar
communications data transmission
everything it took to run a tracking
station but i love radar that was my
background so i go in there and i found
out that something really really fast
flying out out of groomed lake
i
picked it up one time that we couldn't
pick up the beacon but we could get a
skin track on it just very briefly
but i noticed always before this fast
dude took off there's some
slower planes to take off and then what
this was the weather flights they'd take
off the f-101s and pretty soon here come
that fast burger that was my challenge
for me to see if i could pick him up for
you know 10 or 15 seconds at least
but uh so we knew he was there in it but
uh
it was no big secret but with some of us
most people stationed did not know this
so they just they weren't cleared for
but i did have special clearance
and
and also we knew when they moved the
yf-12 to edwards they shared our control
room so we definitely knew that we had a
mark iii plane but what was interesting
at that period of time you know this was
during the um the space race uh the
nuclear race we had a lot of races going
on with russia they were the bad boys
we had three mark three planes in prop
in the works we had the a12
the yf-12 and the one that i was working
on primarily was the xb70 the bomber
and it was many many times the planes
that these guys were flying and we got
it over mark three
and that's one we had a mid-air
collision a few years later and also
we're finally aborted the program was
too expensive and
we knew it should be shot down it came
out of sleep but it was a great study
for uh high-speed transport which later
on the yf-12
took its place and when they decided not
to
maintain it as a interceptor they took
one of our tracking stations and
converted it to long-range radar and
would track it as a continuation of
their speed sydney pro
project so
but
it wasn't until the very towards the
very end of oxcart
that
these uh
cia contacted me and they said we want
you back in do some another job for us
so during the six day war israel had
captured a bunch of soviet migs and
soviet radar
and it's a great concern because you
know we were in the early stages of
vietnam and
our pilots were having a horrible time
the losses were too severe in vietnam we
were losing way way too many people to
planes that we knew had to be inferior
to our hours we were even losing f4s for
getting shot down bales
of mixed 17s which was korean war
vintage
so
i went to the area uh it was real simple
the um took them a while to get my top
secret clearance back and meanwhile they
sent me to the nuclear rocket track um
uh
development station for the nerva
project developing neutral rocket engine
that's where i got to work on it for
three months and uh incidentally i got
my q clearance before i got my top
secret so i ended up with two clearances
and uh
anyway i got out the area and um this is
a little bit off the subject because the
uh
of the road runners it gives you an
insight of how some of us were selected
in in the the process but the uh
we uh we tore the mitch down to see what
ma how they were made how what kind of
paint they had everything about them and
then we started flying well this was
primarily a navy pro a project even
though all
all the
uh agencies had a hand in it everybody
had a common interest in finding out why
they were defeating us
and it was kind of ironic the first
pilots we brought into dogfight as we
got ready to go into the tactical um
evaluation of the migs was the navy
pilots and they came in their f4s and
their little scarves around their necks
thinking they're you know top gun
and we're proud to say on the first try
we got 100 percent kill against the navy
with the mig-17
and uh but what came out of this is
we realized the mix were not superior
but they had certain situational
environments which they were and they
knew what they were and if they could
trap us into entering that environment
and if we didn't get them on the first
try you better not come back because
they're gonna get you i don't care what
you got that your turn a little faster
or whatever it was that turned the trick
so we very quickly
realized too at the same time that if a
pilot could survive 10 missions
in a war
he'd probably survive the war it took
him that long to learn all the ropes
so out of this we the navy was first
they went with top gun
and then the air force came up with red
flag
and now and it continues today we give
all our pilots that 10 missions in the
in the desert of nevada instead of on
the battlefield but that was my
connection to the programs
there's a question for the pilots and in
no particular order it regards your
respective airplanes uh spy planes and
it's uh there had to be some sort of a
heady moment uh when you realized holy
cow what you were flying when you you
put the pedal to the metal you kicked it
into gear and you and it came over you
that this is unlike anything else you'd
ever flown i wonder if you could share
some of those impressions in no
particular order just jump on it
go ahead
i flew uh 43 different kinds of air
force airplanes okay
and and i was both in
fighters armors and reconnaissance
i think the farthest
uh
advanced by far were the three iraqi
airplanes we're talking about tonight
unfortunately they all have
disadvantages in terms of cost and
utility and that's what really killed
them
but the
excitement of flying them was certainly
something worthwhile
i i would offend all my fighter pilot
friends
[Music]
are there any fighter pilots in here
besides denny and me
anyhow
if i said it was not the best aircraft i
ever flew but i'll tell you the airplane
that was the most most important
airplane perhaps other than the u2
and because the u2 is still going today
was probably the
b-52h uh you know it was the heavy
weapon that we used during the end of
vietnam war
it was a big weapon that we used to
settle the
cuban missile crisis
and it's still around today and it's
pretty tough to uh
to say that it isn't a great airplane
but we had these three lockwood lockheed
aircraft were great airplanes no
question
dennis you remember uh kicking it into
gear first time
sr-71 first time
you let it go 71.
um i went to
i was at bl and flying the sr-71 i was
vice commander it's going to take over
the wing and i got grounded with a bad
ear and i was grounded for a number of
years but
the differences between the two
airplanes
the a was 5 000 pounds lighter
would go 5 000 feet higher
it had just one crew member instead of
two
which caused
some problems in putting in the can you
know camera and stuff we had a great big
one
they had to go to
other routes to
get the photography and that sort of
thing now nothing wrong with the sr-71
is a great airplane but it took them a
number of years
to get the photography and stuff up to
the same quality as
i recall
as as the a12 they're both both
really good airplanes
uh
kind of funny i went up to beale and uh
was assigned to the wing there and
nobody knew me and that's and all that
but anyway a few people did
but uh right off the bat the very first
flight in the two-seater b model
and going up there with an instructor
pilot and they fly up and says well
we're gonna refuel today sir
uh
i said i'll show you how it goes and i
said well
let me give it a shot you know
well i'd refuel for you
five years and it drove up plugged it in
and he says uh after a few minutes he
says um
sorry about that last remark
but uh
you know the the sr was uh a great
airplane in
most respects but in my opinion i like
the a12 better it was fly higher as i
said
better camera
how about this as a question i didn't
want to overstate the importance of the
war the work you did out there but uh
you know saying that it helped win the
cold war this what did you bring back uh
i know the cameras were incredibly
sophisticated what kinds of information
did you bring back and what difference
did it make to our country's security
any of you
i think there's a misunderstanding about
photography
that's just part of the game
uh
electronic intelligence is is equally
important from a war planning point of
view we'd like to know where the radars
are what kind of radars they have
and we like to listen to their
conversations
just like today we like to listen to
people's conversations
so uh the the you too that been so
successful all through the years had all
of those capabilities
and we collected most of the
stuff during the iraq war
i've read figures like 92 percent of the
good intelligence came from the modern
youtube
i don't think it's that much today
because they're using
uh drones to collect as well but the u2
has really been a wonderful airplane
through the years the u2 that i'm
talking about today is not the u2 that
the grandfather flew
uh years before it's it's a much bigger
and better aircraft
yeah it's much better
any other stories about the kinds of
material you brought back i mean was
there a day when you you learned that
these photos what what it showed and uh
and how important it was something we
didn't know before about a week before
our powers got shot down we had a
picture
flying out of alaska over the
over the northern part of the soviet
union we had a picture that looked like
a telephone pole underneath the aircraft
uh
we didn't know what to make of it it
seemed like it might be a missile and
then a few days later gary got shot down
and that's probably what it was
you know we we know now that a lot of
pilots were shot down during those
periods that in various kinds of
aircraft our guys and the the public has
never told about it so we call it a cold
war but it wasn't always a cold war
certainly not for you guys who were
flying over there wasn't
anyone
the coldest i ever was was in alaska
i had an interesting experience i can
digress
we had to go through survival training
in alaska i think that was my sixth form
of survival training that i did but the
u2 cockpit was pretty small so we had to
make a decision about whether we would
carry
a life raft or whether we would carry a
a park
and we'd listen to a guy who was an
authority on survival in alaska and he
spent most of his time talking about
polar bears
and he convinced me that for the rest of
us that basically the only way you could
kill a polar bear was to shoot him
underneath here with your gun and if you
had anything less than the cannon i got
the impression it wouldn't do much to
cold polar bear so i was thinking as i
was listening to this lecture about did
i want to carry a life raft or did i
want to carry the
park and i thought
jesus what is a polar bear going to
think
i chose i chose the parking
frank you had a a landing in thailand
that uh that was a bit
interesting or harrowing can you tell us
about
it wasn't all that harrowing
on a mission over north vietnam as i
about the end of the first camera run
something alerted me to uh there was
something wrong
and i started looking around inside the
cockpit i was looking outside for the
time being looking to see who might be
after me nobody there
but then i noticed the oil pressure
gauge on the right engine started
fluctuating
i said oh
stuff
and then i thought well maybe this will
hold together for a while but it wasn't
long after it started wiggling it
started wiggling more towards zero
so i said well
yucks
so
i kept going a little bit to get out of
north vietnam
as was and then pretty soon shut that
engine down and went to thailand
and
the creation of the problem down there
was partly uh stupidity
and uh you know just ignorance of things
going on and luck
and i everywhere i've ever been in my
life i i was issued this bag of lux when
i went through cadets
and yeah you know when you need it you
reach in the bag and get a luck and i i
was pulling locks out routinely and i
was really lucky because
sometimes you reach in there and you
pull out something else
but anyway got down in thailand okay
single engine landing there no big deal
showed the a12 airplane to everybody in
the world down there
and then it took a while it took about a
week to get that thing out of there so i
i made the one and only
away from home uh landing with an a12
during black shield
and uh i'm not proud of that that's just
happened and i i wasn't gonna fly home
on one i wasn't gonna try it
that was an air base i could land on so
i did it
and we fixed it and flew it home low and
slow but anyway that's a one of a kind
uh only me could manage that
uh from frank
tell them about your officer club
adventure
yeah well while i was down there this is
funny while i was down there uh
i sat in the i was uh a captive of the
u2 uh detachment that i didn't even know
there was one at talk late but the
agency had a u2 hangar and some people
down there but no you too at the moment
so that's where they put me
i was there three or four days and being
a heavy drinker i said uh
okay how about uh how about letting me
go give me some civvies and i'll go over
the club there and get a beer and said
no way
and i said come on guys crap they said
okay we'll send you over with one of our
one of our
guys you know one of the agency guys
escort or something so we went over
there and i was sitting at the bar
something on my bear
and some guy i felt somebody tapping on
my shoulder and i turned around and it's
an old guy i'd been stationed with in
the states in a fighter squadron he said
frank what the hell are you doing here
i said oh i work for hughes
[Laughter]
what do you do for hughes i said i got
out you know and i'm working on a radar
on a hill near here he said oh so he
went on his way
and that was the end of that
well i went back in the air force a
couple of years later and i was going
through sea survival down at tyndall
field in florida
and again i'm sitting in there and this
time i'm in there i'm a lieutenant
colonel just sitting there looking
around and this tap tap tap on the
shoulder again
the same guy
frank what the hell are you doing here
i'm going to see survival school
he said something about [ __ ] and i
don't believe you
and he walked off
[Laughter]
you know the real question is what was
that guy working on
he was a 105 pilot at duckley
we're going to take save some time for
questions from the audience if you want
to come on up and stand up here we'll
take them in just a second i want to ask
one more question to the panel it's
about secrecy you know people in my line
of work they get
cocky about the whole thing i like to
say that no secrets can be kept you hear
it that washington leaks like a sieve
that the secrets in fact can't be kept
at least in the modern generation i'd
like you to address that
the concept of secrecy and whether
secrets can be kept td why don't we
start with you
actually i guess it's
probably generational thing or the the
people that they select for these jobs
but
secrecy never seemed to be a concern
with me or my family
even in the military the
the wife just automatically um did not
ask what what did you do today or how'd
your day go
and we didn't didn't tell about it it
came with the turf and uh
so we went through all through our
career this really never was an issue i
know a lot of people we talked to today
said how in the world could you stand
not knowing
the thought didn't end enter your mind
and even what your fellow men were doing
we just had no no no curiosity it just
we just assumed you you don't ask you
don't tell them that's just as simple as
that
anyone else
well let me say one word you're
i think the one of the key things to be
in a program like this
where you
are not
allowed really to tell anything to your
family and another folks
is to have a good spouse that really
understands
and puts up with that and takes care of
you and
i have that and i think the other
folks in the program did too
and
that really is probably one of the most
helpful things you can have
in a program like this is a spouse that
can handle
uh the like the normal military thing or
well
the other the other half is said well i
just got to set orders i got to go to
you know wherever i'll be back and see
you in about four months
that sort of thing
and they thought you had girlfriends or
something right
didn't they general yeah i'd like to
make a comment on secrecy i i think
secrecy buys you time not much else
uh the point of secrecy and particularly
military secrets is
uh does it leave enough time for
consultation and application of the
things that you're trying to keep secret
the best example of that is the stuff
today that they're finally releasing
uh you know the time has long passed
when anybody really gives a damn about
the sr-71 or whatever because they're no
longer current it's not an issue when it
first came out we were concerned about
the technology being captured by
somebody but once once the world knows
how to do things like that then it's a
question of do they have enough
initiative enough desire and enough
money that they can do those things so
secrecy is a way to
let the clock tick a few more times
before the whole world knows what you're
doing
i think that's what the government's
running through today with the most
interesting thing perhaps is what's
happening in
in the middle east with
the pakistan afghanistan thing and and
general mccree crystal uh
letting the cat out of the bag if in
fact that's what he did about what the
next strategy should be
he's being criticized and perhaps
rightly so if he actually divulged
things that
i have about you in the future but
frankly i don't think he divulges
anything that
that has any particular value to the
enemy if we're going to do it it's a
good thing to do it we're not going to
do it it doesn't make any difference
so that that's what i think about i say
that after some years intelligence too i
was uh
director of operations and intelligence
with far east with european air forces
for a couple years
and handled all kinds of secret things
that are coming in across the border
from
soviet union and whatnot largely through
agents or people who were forced out of
the soviet union like a lot of israelis
present-day israelis a lot of jews were
some of them would tell us things and
some of them weren't wouldn't tell we
didn't pressure them but they didn't
want to talk we didn't put any pressure
on them
but i think it's biggest value is time
td uh the part about the wives that was
a prerequisite wasn't it for the guys
that were recruited
yes it was and i'm not
a comment on that it shows the
quality of the selection that the agency
did or whoever did the selection
but there's very few if any divorces in
our entire group even though we for
years on the end we're going five days a
week and
i commented on the widows that are that
are still with us 50 years later today
that's still part of the family the same
goes to the wise we just do not have a
divorce rate at all prepared but with
the most civilian the only uh subject of
the secrecy i commented earlier that
we're still sensitive what we talk about
even though we know what's been
declassified we know there's lines you
don't cross we don't feel comfortable
and uh now give you an example i'm the
webmaster for uh our website and i work
a lot with the cia but we've been
working uh as helping them with the as
they rewrite that or write the history
when they started uh declassifying all
this material a few years ago they
realized
that the younger generation had no don't
have a clue
of what went on back then they know the
project happened but when we go into
meeting we were not allowed pencil or
paper you did not take notes and you
didn't talk therefore there's no records
in cia
of the details so they started coming
onto our website which grew very very
slowly because first we were very
reluctant and i talked to the deputy
director of
intelligence up there for
numerous times
nervous about what we were doing with
the website and his feeling was that
the good coming out of it telling the
good things that they did outweighed any
possible given way of anything
of concern
but along this line i i monitor who's
watching the websites because i'm still
sensed even about a month ago i was
looking and noting a bit a real heavy
traffic from china
they're just living on those websites
even though the information
most of it is 50 years old and we have a
little bit of stuff that's been released
lately and that's probably what they're
gathering so i went uh contacted
security at um cia and and
they looked into it too because we can
tell who's who's been on site and
the bottom line was is they don't feel
there's anything useful that they're
getting now they're trying to harvest
something
but there's nothing there from the
harvest at this point
and we're going to keep monitoring it
but i i wanted to but they wouldn't let
me i wanted to put a little missing
information on there
and they said no just don't play with
them but uh that's one thing uh
let's talk about that just for a second
uh
i was not a convenient but i know the
story we had three three planes over
there and they flying these missions uh
into north vietnam whatever and the
russians had a trawler right off the
coast and every time when the planes
take off but then on the radio to uh
to the north vietnamese here they come
so they would change the tail number on
the plant
every plane would take i'll have a
different tail number maybe a little
different color scheme
and out the area
when we talk about satellites earlier
particularly when we got the mix the
soviets knew we had the majors out there
and they bombarded us with satellites to
be one coming over the horizon every 45
minutes
we knew what type of satellite was our
intelligence is just as good as theirs
and um
but then she was pinned down for days on
end and and so we when you get bored
after a bunch of engineers and we would
know that there's a infrared satellite
getting ready to come over the horizon
we'll go out and paint on the tarmac
because the shape of some exotic plane
put a couple heaters on the ass end of
it like it had just landed and it'll
take a picture of it
i'm just wondering why they uh they
stopped the tooling of it i mean so
abruptly was that any reason kelly
johnson was mad at something which which
one are you talking about well just the
tooling of of all the you know the sr-71
all that stuff because it can't be
done they talk about the rumors there
was never anything that came out in
terms of a true press release or
anything like that but i think i spoke
about it that
when
they decided not to go ahead with the
yf-12 production program
we'd heard that that the tooling for the
program had been cut up and it for one
thing it's a large asset when a company
is having to keep a building full of
tools that have cost maybe a hundred
million dollars to build they're paying
taxes on it so
i don't know what the truth is all i do
know is that if they'd wanted to build
some more srs or more yf's it would have
cost a lot more money because they would
have to build up that tooling all over
again
they don't want to carry it on the books
i can elaborate on this mcnamara is the
one that ordered the tooling um
destroyed on the uh for the srs he did
not want any more built
so before they destroyed it they built
20-year supply
of everything that they would need for
the fleet
and they had this stuff stored down at
barstow california frank murray and i
went through the
warehouse three years ago they had as in
the marine
warehouses down there i mean huge
warehouses we're talking well just for
example titanium sheets they had 60
million dollars worth of titanium laying
there just in case they ever needed it
they had tires by the if not hundreds by
the thousands they had any nut and vote
that they may conceivably need for that
but when the air force when nasa took
over the the sr-71 for their project
thatcher their force uh quit flying them
but they uh they took over the
warehouses and
then when they got ready to get rid of
them they got a big
healthy monthly charge from the marines
plus they're needing them out of there
because they're needing to move some
tanks and stuff in there and get ready
you know for for the war for fighting it
no this is all just real current stuff
so they was fighting over it and the and
then the epa went in there and found a
bunch of asbestos we had asbestos
inserted some of the components the fire
marshal made them scattered all these
tires throughout these warehouses where
there's a fire hazard
so the headaches to nasa was horrible
and they couldn't get rid of the stuff
they weren't flying the planes
so they uh
uh
told the air force take your stuff back
we've gone out from under and therefore
so it's not ours it's yours we gave it
to you when we gave you the planes
so they actually went to court a little
over a year ago
and the
judge found in in their contract when
the air force assigned all this over to
nasa
they reserved in one paragraph to write
to reclaim the sr said them once and the
judge says that means you own the
warehouse
there's a technical reason
to go to your question
i talked to kelly johnson later on when
i accepted the first of the tr ones
and i said how much
did it cost you to make a titanium
a part for the sr and he said for every
100 pounds they got of titanium and they
got 10 pounds worth of of a useful part
years later i went into manufacturing
myself and made machine parts for for
the aircraft
by that time the cnc machines had
progressed so much
that we could make a part
95 of
titanium without wasting any
and the cost of keeping absolute to
obsolete tooling is just something that
a business doesn't want to do
the modern tools are so much better
and so much more capable and it just
doesn't make sense
question yeah my question is like how
fast could those airplanes fly and how
high could they go or how high can you
tell us they could go and is there
anything else out there that you can
tell us about that go as fast and high
as those planes
we'll pause on the last part of the
question and let's start with the first
part satellites
satellites yeah how high and fast a12
hey 12
very light on view you could get it to
90 000.
um
fast
3.2 mark is the limit but uh there are
other limits and one of them really the
the
one of the critical limits was a
compressor inlet temperature and that
was one thing you watched pretty
carefully if you're getting near the
limit there because that
that would
you know you could have a disaster
but
you know
i i think people have been up close to
3.3 but i haven't actually been there
myself but i've been close
i'll give you one example
uh very early in the test program i'm
playing uh
just a routine mission uh
hadn't been flying the airplane too long
but we were out to
3.2 mark
and
this particular one i
took off and went kind of northwest from
the area and then i'm coming down over
the sierras in california just down the
mountain range
and
you know
nice scenery there just kind of looking
around and everything's nice and
then they're going along very neatly and
along about just under 3.2 mark
well
all of a sudden the shadows in the
cockpit started
moving and i thought you know what in
the world's going on here
and
i looked at the instruments showing
straight levels light everything's
normal
looked out the window
i'm coming up on a 90 degree bank
there was a failure that was had no
indication in the cockpit that cut the
power to the flight instruments
and they were just unwinding
so the recovery from that i'm not going
to do anything very uh exciting
in yankee airplane around because the
low g airplane started it's not a fire
plane
then
get the wings back level and then get
the nose back up and get it slowed down
or at the same time come back into
throttle
well that's my personal speed record
it got up to about what did they say
somewhere around 3.25 or the liar
i guess there's a there's a story we've
all heard about after they retired the
sr-71 that there was one last flight
uh that they just kicked the tires out
and let it go
to set a record that may or may not be
public does anybody talk about that
i think we have our answer on that one
uh let's let's approach the
let's yes i just wanted to comment on
the speed issue uh
techy and out of arrow the the thing
that um that really caused that
temperature limit was that the the
compressor blades and turbine blades on
the engines were made out of titanium
and
as a part of breaking the engines in
you'd take them out and run them up and
there was a stainless steel honeycomb on
the inside of the inlet duct and the
compressor
blades would wear into that honeycomb
and at night you could look in there and
see kind of a ring of glowing
compressor blades it created the kind of
efficiency that you needed in the engine
to get the full amount of thrust and so
what would happen is if you went beyond
this 800 degree compressor inlet
temperature it would cause the blades to
do what we call creep
and they would they would not expand and
then come back they would expand and
stay out there and wear into the
honeycomb
and it would create a gap and that gap
between the ends of the compressor
blades and the inlet of the inside of
the inlet duct
derated the engine to where you couldn't
get full thrust and they basically would
ruin the engines and when that was
allowed to happen you'd go over 800
degrees cit or whatever the actual
number was you basically wrecked the
engine it had to come out and go back to
pratt whitney in florida it would cost a
couple of million dollars to rebuild it
just because of going a little bit too
hot and too fast
on a cold day
you could go faster than a hot day
because you had a cooler compressor
inlet temperature and that's where the
records were being set i think
anyhow a little techie talk here um sort
of following up the gentleman's last
question i i know you can't tell us what
you know about any kind of other secret
planes that might be out there but
maybe approach it this way
is there a need for a successor to uh
something like sr-71 an airplane or do
we have other kinds of technical
capabilities that make it uh obsolete
and i asked that in the context of all
the stories we hear of things flying
around black mantas and aurora and
things like that that no one has ever
actually confirmed what do you think do
we need a plane like that
something faster than the sr-71
never my decision no
if you want to do something that is
going to go around the world in a hurry
and bomb yes
but just to get uh intelligence now
that's my opinion any other opinions
satellites are pretty good at taking all
the really good photography we need i
think
we have about 10 minutes i'll go ahead
td i think we got the uavs that we're
using today scattered around the world
in sufficient numbers that um
they could cover any particular area in
the world in a
quick period of time whereas years ago
we would have had to
send a plane up and
done the same thing so i think we've
covered our bases with uh i'd like to
disagree with that a little bit okay the
the uh as you'll see tomorrow those are
going to create
the ua the uavs that we have are
basically for a low threat environment
exactly and uh there are other
environments that we're more concerned
about perhaps in the long term let's say
china russia for example or iran where
they have more sophisticated defenses at
that point
the uav that you're talking about is
going to last about two minutes yeah
they wouldn't work there so i i would
say with that comment you make should be
balanced with what the real world might
be five or ten years from now or maybe
two years from now depending on what
happens
well we have just about 10 minutes left
i want to know if we could uh talk about
uh some of the other more exotic the
deepest darkest secrets in area 51 and
that was what went on at sam's place and
uh and house six
frank you talk about exotic technologies
and exotic beverages and things like
that the best uh best game of liars dice
in town i i'm i'm asking that sort of
seriously in the sense of what the
camaraderie and conditions were at groom
lake because i know you hear these
stories in the early days it was pretty
grim i guess but you made the most of it
frankly
well i uh
number one house six was the best bar in
town
and there were there were several i only
knew about how six closed yeah never
closed then he said
house six was originally designed to be
the guest quarters somebody came
visiting 51 you know from the agency or
something he had to have a bed somewhere
so we had a place with nobody sleeping
in there
and they decided to put a bar in the
other side of the thing well that ruined
it as guest quarters because nobody went
to sleep in there
but the house six was a fixture
and i spent my time in there too
everybody did it was the only place in
town but other
other areas of the camp up there where i
didn't go house six was used by the
flyers mostly
the officers and the flyers and the and
the lockheed guys and that kind of thing
we each had different camps um yeah
but they're the the we had no army guys
there
but uh
several of the contractor bunch you know
in various places had their own sort of
bar setups and i didn't go to them nor
were they
nor were they so well known as six
but uh it got so good that we had a we
had a weatherman up there named willie
west
who uh he was a damn good poet he really
was and he's written a bunch of stuff
and someday we ought to put all his
poetry on the website so everybody can
see it and enjoy it but he wrote one
about house six that was absolutely
perfect where's sam piezo yeah is he
here
well i meant sam probably had to go to
bed
but he was up because he was up until
noon today
but but anyway
without without going any further house
six was a fixture that was uh enjoyed by
many yeah the bar chief bartender was a
guy named ferguson
he also stalked the thing so when he
came to work up there
on monday morning his trunk was full of
uh goodies for house six
but without house six we'd have gone and
made another one it'd have been a house
seven or somewhere else i think
i got it clean i agree with frank dear
house six was a great place but let me
throw a little bit in about some of the
athletic facilities that were available
up there for people to use
they had a squash court and
there's some of us played squash i can
always remember big old charlie trapp
one of our
uh
good athlete big guy
and we'd have knocked down drag out
squash games in a squash court tennis
courts we get up there
you know i remember somebody
one day walt ray bless the soul
and his other side of the net and
somebody had an easy lob coming over and
he's up in the front and then he jumps
up in the air and throws his hands up in
the racket
and the other guy on the other side
whomped the hell out of the ball and hit
him right in the belly button
but
the athletic facilities uh
were a good addition
to you know
going over house sex and drinking and
we older guys who were there when it was
first opened didn't have any of that
stuff
we
ron you were going to jump into this as
well back in the 55 we had a swimming
pool which had a swimming pool
now these guys tell the story swimming
pool basketball courts it's like their
wives are all here or something oh yeah
the only thing that i really enjoyed is
i think we had the best food in the in
the area
and if our hourly folks ever felt that
the food was getting a little bit below
average they threatened to strike they'd
call kelly next thing you know we'd have
a fresh plain load of cooks coming out
from vegas so between prime rib night
and steak night
and
we had fresh pastry every morning at 10
o'clock on a push cart and uh you could
go back for food anytime you wanted so
they took the care of us
a frank tell about the lake made
paracel
oh yes somebody got a hair
that they ought to train the project
pilots in the use of uh
parasailing you know as a parachute
landing training with a full pressure
suit on
and i mean this is nuts
this is crazy
so anyway they we we decided that lake
mead would be the the ocean we'd jump
into
and they tried to drown jack leighton
who's over there in the corner and me
and other guys got by unscathed they
came out of it with their hair on and
everything else but it was really hairy
i thought
parasailing into the lake and we tried
all our private boats to pull the guys
up and we can't do that so they they
conned the coast guard into using one of
their fast boats and that got people up
but they also drug me through the rocks
for about a hundred yards and then tried
to drown leighton
so there's a little to gain on a thing
where you kill all the people at home
but
i figured they were trying to do that to
kill us off so they wouldn't have to pay
us
let me add one thing to that very
quickly here
alvarodic uh
good friend now deceased but uh
and the parasitic thing he's going up
and everything's going along really good
and they dump them off and now these are
parachutes that can't be used anymore
they're condemned and all that so they
weren't in the best of shape
uh one of these
side of the
canopy down by the
pilot the stitching came apart
and essentially
the whole thing's slipped one way
so
he's in the parachute but he's actually
in a tailspin going into the lake
at about twice the velocity normally
would be so they drop them off and all
of a sudden he goes
[Music]
like a rocket in the lake and i said
well now now where i am out there
swimming around try to find mail well he
went about two-thirds of the way the
bottom of the lake and he
he finally came up and we just about
drowned and
tried to slip in one train i'm sorry
dennis we're going to try and slip in
one more question this lady here i think
has a unique perspective literally and
figuratively about area 51.
um
my name is barbara sheehan i'm from the
groom rhine
we thought that we owned all the desert
out there because we've been there since
1889
and were we surprised when
the aec came in with the bombs the
airports had been there before and they
used to fly over us with their bombers
and their fighter pilots and they shoot
the targets over camp and we put up with
that we thought the war was all over
with and then lo and behold one morning
the family got knocked out of bed just
about had no idea what was going on
and so my brother got up one morning
early with his camera and he took a
picture of the fireball
we were within nine miles of the bombs
going off and so that he sent the the
pictures into kodak
and they sent out the fbi
[Laughter]
they did not know that we were there the
air force knew but the aec did not know
that we were there so they came out in
in mass needless to say to our mining
camp
and my dad had a mining operation there
for a long time so like i said we
thought the groom lake was ours we used
to go down and chase jackrabbits and
coyotes all over the lake you could
roller skate on it it was wonderful i
haven't been on that lake since 1952.
i'd love to go on that lakeville but we
can't go on the lake anymore well your
family still has property out we can see
it we still have the property we have
like a little island in the middle of
the test site and we can go out there
we have to get permission to go
and we don't know a thing that's going
on down at area 51 nor do we want to
surely they would allow channel 8 to
come with a camera
[Laughter]
i just wanted you to know what area 51
is like from the civilian side
we come and you know they let us in god
bless them uh we have to go through a
guard and they have the great big
machine guns all ready to shoot us
there's old ladies going out there and
they're going to shoot us but anyway we
get through
and then we go up to our mind they have
all kinds of cabins and everything we've
got our old dump trucks still ready to
run if we could 1939 dump truck in 1940
dump trucks still run
and
anyway we have
our old mine that we love very very much
the family still goes out there whenever
they can
but we can't stay out there we can't
live out there but it's it's ours
why don't you join the air force
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm sorry i'll get everywhere and see
you
uh recently i did a little thing in one
of our newsletters about the uh the
groom minds we used to walk up there out
aboard them on the weekends or something
and the great granddaughter
wrote me a letter just recently and you
sent me some of the diary
writings of dan that her great-grandpa
was buried there
and we've been so we've been
corresponding back and forth and uh i
put her with mary polosky with the unlv
that's doing the
co-war or history program
and now they're corresponding
because she sent me a lot of material
about how the when the their fallout
would come down metal would actually be
hitting on the 10 roofs buildings and
stuff from the from the shop towers
so they're closer to nation we're
talking to you they would they would set
off the bombs when the wind was blowing
towards us
not towards las vegas but towards us
because if las vegas got it they'd we'd
be in or they'd be in trouble and so
it's
right over us it was rain it's hot hot
stuff i don't know and my dad
would he would let the the boys that
would that would go out after the bomb
was set off the boys would go out from
our camp they were living in our cabins
and they would go out and check to see
what was done
you know the boys have got to see what's
got what happens when you blow something
up you know well that's what they would
do they want to see what happened and
then they would come back take off the
coveralls and leave them and then they
would go back to town so my dad would
pick up all the coveralls and throw them
in the trash barrel and burn them so i
don't know how we're all still
we aren't all of us alive but two of us
are still are
anyway it was a wonderful wonderful life
out there thanks for sharing those
stories thank you i'm going to take one
more question from the other room
uh
question if you can hear us
hi i wanted to thank you all on the
panel very much for your participation
and i treasure your stories i'm very
honored to hear all your stories and i
guess i'd like to ask
in parting
50 years from now
people will be sitting here listening to
the stories of those people out there
now
do you have any words of wisdom for
those who will be taking your place on
this panel 50 years from now god willing
i'll still be here to hear them
can you guarantee the invitation
i hope they're very good and i hope that
only
god's speed
i want to thank our panelists it was a
fascinating conversation and we really
appreciate all of you being here and
sharing these insights and experiences
and uh want to remind you all that
there's another panel tomorrow afternoon
and uh i want to thank the atomic
testing museum for hosting this event it
was fabulous i hope we can do it again
real soon thank you all for coming
[Applause]
you're watching american history
television on c-span 3.
you can watch american history
television every weekend starting
saturday which podcast you'd like to
download and listen to afterwards while
you travel
next on book tv investigative reporter
annie jacobson presents a history of the
military base area 51 located in the
nevada desert
the author uses recently declassified
documents on-site reporting and
interviews with numerous people who
worked and lived at the base it's about
an hour
everyone and i wanted to thank the
commonwealth club for having me
and everyone for being here it's a real
author's dream to have a full house for
a book speaking event and thank you gill
for having me on your show and also for
moderating tonight and we'll get to some
questions because i i know people love
to ask questions i certainly do and i
wouldn't be here if i didn't have that
sense of curiosity so
um what i'm going to start with i'm
going to actually read you two
paragraphs from my book
but i'm going to set the
the stage so to speak a little bit first
and let you know where area 51 is other
than in people's imaginations because it
really does exist
and it's located in southern nevada
about 75 miles north of las vegas
it's in a much bigger
parcel of land that is the largest
federally restricted
piece of real estate in the united
states it's about the size of
connecticut
and it's called the nevada test and
training range
inside of the nevada test and training
range there's a
1
350 square mile parcel
called the nevada test site and the
nevada test site is divided up into
quadrants the quadrant numbers have
changed and shifted and gone underground
over the years but
in essence they are one through 30 with
some mysteriously missing
area 51
sits just outside of the nevada test
site but inside the greater land parcel
that is the nevada test and training
range and it is there that
many it is there that my book the basis
of my book centers and that is where
many of the
most secret and perhaps most alarming
uh national security projects took place
but also many of the most fantastic ones
that kept us all safe
arguably kept us out of world war iii
with the russians
certainly helped our pilots in vietnam
some really great things go went on
there and probably continued to go on
there today
but um
with that said i'm going to read you two
paragraphs in my book about
that really speak to what the book is
and and
when i was researching the book i was
able to interview a total of
74 men who had uh rare unprecedented
access to area 51.
32 of whom lived and worked at the base
for extended periods of time
and about 20 of them i kind of tell
their stories their characters in my
book and one of them that i'm going to
be reading about is a pilot a cia pilot
named ken collins
and ken collins in this scene
is flying the
a12 ox cart
which is the
was the cia's original mach 3
spy plane that flew at 90 000 feet so
mach 3 is three times the speed of sound
and 90 000 feet is about 17 miles up
and this was in the 1960s so it was
radical science and technology at the
time and the spy plane was built
to take over after
the u2
spy plane program was outed when gary
powers was shot down over the soviet
union
so i write
collins pushed the aircraft through mach
2.8 in another 45 seconds he would be
out of the danger zone
nearing 85 000 feet the inevitable tiny
black dots appear
began to appear on the aircraft
windshield sporadic at first like the
first drops of summer rain
only a few months earlier scientists at
area 51 had been baffled by those black
dots
they worried it was some kind of high
atmosphere corrosion until the mystery
was solved in the lab
it turned out the black spots were dead
bugs that were cycling around in the
upper atmosphere blasted into the jet
stream by the world's two superpowers
rally of thermonuclear bombs
the bugs were killed in the bomb's blast
and sent aloft to 90 000 feet in the
ensuing mushroom clouds as they gained
orbit
when i first came across that detail i
found it incredible i thought to myself
what on earth or
that high up
uh are bugs doing dead bugs circling
around and i didn't really understand
being 43 years old um
not having lived through the cold war to
the extent that many of my sources did
i i wondered well i was 40 when i
started the book but um i wondered
it didn't make much sense to me how why
these bugs were there and in essence
it's a bit of an analogy about what area
51 is
it was set up
to conduct espionage on the soviet union
the cia began building its base there in
1955
with the u2 spy plane because the cia
wanted to spy on russia and see what
they were doing
and
one of the other men that i interviewed
in my book was
hervey stockman and he just passed two
months ago which is
also a really interesting side note that
the men that i interviewed are really in
the last
chapter of their lives
but hervey stockman explained to me what
it was like to be the first man to fly
over the soviet union in a u2
and yes he agitated nikita khrushchev
greatly and yes there was a lot of
fallout between the eisenhower
administration and the soviets over this
spying that was going on but at the same
time
what hervy stockman brought back
in the film canisters of his u2
was over 400 000 square feet of film of
spy footage
about what was going on in the soviet
union and as hervey said to me
that the cia was able to learn and
understand that in fact the soviets were
not
lining up for world war iii as many
members of the air force wanted to
believe
certainly general lemay who's a
character in my book as well you might
call him an antagonist
and so when you consider that the cia's
job
is to present intelligence to the
president based on fact not fiction or
not speculation
that is what the u2 spy plane certainly
did for us
and i think that was an important
important notion
but at the same time there were other
elements of the government that were
really
pushing science as i write in the book
and i think here's where i get into
some of the more dangerous areas and
some of the questions that i
that i
would like readers to be able to ask of
themselves
about whether or not pushing science is
necessarily a good thing
um
right around that same time or actually
if you back up a bit
you know for a while after world war ii
we had an atomic bomb
and then
when we found out the russians were had
also had an atomic bomb this was in 1949
there was a big movement toward creating
a bigger bomb called the thermonuclear
bomb which is how these bugs got so high
up
and
robert oppenheimer the father of the
atomic bomb at the time really opposed
that on moral grounds he said it was not
a good idea to create a weapon that was
larger than its target
in other words the thermonuclear bomb is
so big that it would not wipe out a
military installation it would wipe out
a whole city
the thermonuclear bomb that
sent the bugs aloft that ken collins
flew through
was actually a thermonuclear bomb that
was 10 megatons
and that thermonuclear bomb is big
enough if it's dropped on manhattan it
would wipe out all five boroughs and it
would kill 75 percent of the population
down to washington dc over time so
obviously that's a bomb that's bigger
than its target
and in my book i think
one of the more interesting analogies
that i came across was that
at area 51 here we were trying to
prevent
war so to speak that's what the cia was
doing with their espionage platforms and
on the other side of the fence over at
the atomic bombing range at the nevada
test site
the atomic energy commission and the
department of defense were practicing
how to have a nuclear war
um this spy plane that ken collins was
flying was called the a12 ox cart and
although most people have probably never
heard of it because
it was only declassified by the cia
in
2007 50 years after
its drawings and one of the characters
in my book is the physicist who did
those original drawings and helped build
stealth for the cia
um but this idea that you could have
these two
uh notions working at once is a little
bit complicated preventing a war but
practicing to have one
but what i the point i was making about
the ox cart was that
you probably have never seen it or or
heard of it maybe but
its cousin is very famous and that is
the
i don't know if this is a military crowd
but it's the uh
sr-71 the air force's famous black bird
um
that went mach 3 and the sr-71 is
interesting because
it actually stood for originally
reconnaissance strike but president
johnson when he announced it bungled it
and they didn't want to correct the
president so they corrected the plane
but um
reconnaissance strike meaning
so that when the air force decided to
take over the cia's espionage program
their idea was to have it be
a spy plane that could go in and
photograph
a post-nuclear
site to figure out what to follow up the
bombing with
and i think that's one of the
more interesting parts or perhaps more
evocative parts of my book
that i hope people will read and think
about which is how these different
federal organizations that we have
work together
fight with one another on these secret
programs
that
on balance perhaps keep us safer and
more more nationally secure but
sometimes enter into the area of
uh
recklessness and i write about that in
the book also some of the weapons tests
that we did out there um
were in my opinion reckless one of which
there was a program that we had called
project 57 and i tell the story through
the eyes of the security guard who
worked on that program he was also the
first security guard at area 51 during
the u2 program his name was richard
mingus but to work overtime so he could
buy a new car he agreed to moonlight on
this project 57 which was
the idea that the defense department had
well what would happen in america if
this was in
1957 by the way what would happen if one
of our planes carrying a nuclear weapon
were to crash on american soil
would it have an actual explosion would
it
create a kind of dirty bomb environment
they didn't know and they wanted to find
out
so at the very edges of area 51 in a
land parcel called area 13 they decided
to do what they called a safety test and
in essence they they set off a dirty
bomb out there and they contaminated 895
acres
with plutonium that is still
contaminated out there um
so the idea of
what is keeping us safe what is pushing
science what is reckless
what is important um all kinds kind of
comes together in what i think is the
enigma of area 51.
um
i could go on for a very long time i
wrote a 500 page book and it's filled
with stories but maybe to keep me on
track i'll uh take some questions from
the audience and uh we can start a
dialogue
we've got questions that are coming up
yeah no that's okay
this is actually interesting because it
goes to a heart of your book a lot of
which is about secrecy and how
off-budget this
operation was
a person asked what percentage of the
cia budget was area 51 and how is area
51 justified but you write in your book
that though the cia is certainly
running area 51
a large part of this and large part of
the most controversial things in your
book comes from the atomic energy
commission
that's right and the atomic energy
commission is now known as the
department of energy they've changed
their name four times over the years i
think to kind of
if you change the name of something
enough times maybe people will forget
about it um
but the original part of your question i
wanted to speak on that because it's
very interesting there's a one of the
people in my book that i write about at
length although he's passed so
everything that i've written about him
is from archives but he was the sort of
the first man to run area 51 for the cia
and his name was richard bissell and
he's famous in cia legend and lore for a
number of things but he
ultimately had to step down for
taking all the blame for the bay of pigs
and in my book i i explain a little bit
that i think he got the bad rap on the
bay of pigs but so it goes when you work
in that kind of a business but uh asking
about where the budgets came from
i found out in my research
richard bissell was you know he was a
brilliant economist he was a yale
graduate and he became the executor of
finance for the marshall plan after
world war ii so there was something like
13 billion dollars
that was
at the disposal of richard bissell to
help rebuild uh europe
and a friend came knocking at his door
one night
in washington dc a man by the name of
frank wisner and the two sat in front of
bissell's fire place and wisner said you
know we need some money for this group
we have over at the cia
and because they had a mutual friend in
aval harriman
bissell knew better than to ask many
more questions and just kind of agreed
that that would be all right and that
those funds were diverted over from the
marshall plan
to the cia
about two and a half years later bissell
became the
uh subordinate to alan dulles the
director at the time of the cia and area
51 was up and running
okay several people want you to cut to
the little men
i told annie before we started that the
last time i saw the reverend ralph
abernathy he complained to me that he
wrote and it is if you ever get a chance
to read it a brilliant book in the
history of the civil rights movement and
all anyone wanted to ask him about was
one sentence about martin luther king's
personal life
so there's seven pages in this book and
and here come a bunch of questions okay
uh who what were the little men that
were seen at roswell
per the first chapter can you
comment on the ufo connection to area 51
what about the ufos and aliens what
about ufos
go for it annie
curious crowd no one wants to hear about
war and weapons
when there's little green men to talk
about um okay but first i want to say
something about my sources because this
is important to me and it's important to
me as a journalist um
i interviewed a lot of men for this book
as gil said you know really the the
largest number of men that have ever
gone on record about area 51 and they
all go on record
using their names
and there's one exception and that is
the source that i write about in the
last seven pages of my book that many
people want to know about
um
and this source remains anonymous for
reasons of safety and security and also
because
that program the program that he
discussed with me has not been
declassified per se
um
and
it's an interesting
distinction as a journalist to make
between
being able to source
your source's information up against
declassified documents
as i did with the first 367 pages of my
book
uh
national archives
library of congress declassified
documents with cia with the atomic
energy commission department of defense
department of intelligence agency nro
nsa i can go on and on and on a lot of
late nights looking at documents
um and then there is
a point in the book where i
make a shift in the way i wrote the book
everything in the beginning is written
in a traditional journalist form where
you
annotate everything and you make clear
where your sources came from and in the
very end of the book i lean into the
reader who i trust has read my whole
book
and i say
okay but that's not why area 51 is still
classified
and area 51
has never been admitted to by any
organization in the government and
that's a fact they
any of the declassified documents always
have the word area 51 blacked out or
redacted sometimes they refer to it as
the test facility or the site
but it's only ever located in print
twice by me and i believe those were
obviously errors
so why keep this base secret and i lean
into my reader and i say here's why i
think the base is secret and this came
to me from
a source
and in the last seven pages i tell you
what that source said to me and i'm very
clear to make clear that
there is no documents to fact check this
up against
while i did get some very
what i consider to be corroborating
suggestive evidence in archives
um the actual story is from one man's
oral history
the source was a engineer for eg g which
means that he had a top secret clearance
and also acute clearance for handling
nuclear secrets
and i examined the sources
medical records his war records
i looked at the
documents that he was the certificates
and awards that he was given by the
atomic energy commission he worked for
the commission across three decades as a
contractor
he was a member of the manhattan project
and the source told me that in 1951
he was one of five engineers that was
asked to solve what is called a wicked
engineering problem and a wicked
engineering problem means that it's
something that no one has figured out
and needs to be solved but solving that
problem will create its own new set of
problems
and the source told me that he was
one of five people who received the
equipment
from
wright-patterson air force base and that
was originally what crashed in roswell
and that it was a flying circular-shaped
aircraft it was not
from mars it was from russia
and it was actually a
originally a third reich design
much of what i write about in the book
discusses how
a program called operation paperclip was
put into effect
after the war where
america
pillaged third reich scientists to head
up our aerospace programs and much of
our military programs werner von braun
is the best example he designed the v2
rocket for hitler he came over and
designed the apollo rockets for kennedy
but russia also did the same thing
they pillaged the scientists that they
could get their hands on
and so this flying disc according to the
engineer from eg g
was something that had crashed in
new mexico and the intent was
for it to be a hoax
that stalin
and again were in 1947 here when we're
talking about the roswell crash
1947 stalin did not yet have an atomic
weapon truman did they were bitter
rivals
and so stalin
made a move
fired a warning shot over truman's bow
so to speak to say you may have the
atomic bomb but i have psychological
warfare and allah the war of the worlds
he wanted to send this flying disc to
land in new mexico
and have
people come out that looked like aliens
and the eg g engineer told me
that the
child sized pilots inside were
the results of ghastly human experiments
in the soviet union
and that is what he told me and i repeat
it in my book because i wrote the
uncensored history of area 51 not the
censored history and many people
take umbrage with that certainly a
couple of the guys in my book aren't
happy about it and i understand why
as they've said to me you know we were
john wayne out there saving the free
world and no one likes to hear
about this kind of possibly this kind of
ghastly goings-on in the desert but this
is what my source told me i absolutely
stand by his veracity and it's what i
wrote in the book and it's obviously
what a lot of people
um are very skeptical of and at the same
time want to know more about
if the
let me ask one one follow-up before we
get to the next one
so the reason then if it was not aliens
that would panic the population for
keeping this such a deep dark secret
would have been what
the reason for keeping the program
for keeping this particular program
essentially reverse engineering this
disc the idea that russians were doing
the psychopaths if they were caught
red-handed
why keep it a secret wouldn't that be a
victory look how awful stalin is look at
what they've done
there was evidence that he took some of
the papers that were captured from
joseph mengele
and
this would have been a great propaganda
victory for the united states
absolutely and that was
a question that i asked my source
repeatedly um
i interviewed him for over a hundred
hours across what i write in the book
was 18 months now it's been
more than two years
um we would discuss nuclear weapons we
would discuss lots of things which i
would then go fact check
and at the end of our
several hour interview i would say can i
ask you another question about the
subject that we're not allowed to talk
about and he would
say yes and that was one question i
asked often and
now remember keep in mind that this
individual
also participated in the program so he
was according to him a first-hand
witness
reverse engineered this craft
he received the people
that were the child size aviators so i
asked him that question and he finally
gave me an answer which i write in the
book and he said because we were doing
the same thing
the idea that
the american scientists wanted to also
push science that they didn't want the
soviets ahead of us
in any program
whatever it may be
and i do want to say a note on that
because another journalist said to me
you know how dare you accuse the united
states government of such
horrible things and my answer to it was
and i spent quite a bit of time writing
about this in my book um while i don't
claim to
be able to speak for the technology in
the flying craft or
certainly the tech the the kind of
medical experiments that would create
that kind of a of an alien looking
person
what i do speak to and what i do write
about and what i do fact check and
source is what the atomic energy
commission did
during its tenure
and the reckless human experimentation
that they did there's you know president
clinton put together a commission in the
1990s after a reporter named eileen
wilson revealed that the atomic energy
commission had been experimenting
injecting [ __ ] children with
plutonium at a state school in
massachusetts and you know i see all the
faces everyone's like oh god how
horrible and people really don't want to
hear about that and they they turn the
other way and they say
that's just horrible and kind of go on
and you know i felt as a journalist that
by
i believe what my source told me and i
believe that what he told me the reason
that he told me what he told me was
because it was a matter of conscience
the other four engineers are dead and so
it's just him he was very clear about
that and so if
a debate or a discussion
ensues
as to whether or not
this kind of a program could go on
how long it went on for i feel that's an
important discussion and it's why i
chose to write about it in my book
you're listening to the commonwealth
club of california radio program our
guest today is annie jacobson los
angeles magazine columnist author of a
new book detailing her investigation of
the legendary military base known as
area 51. this question from the audience
if the contents and activities of area
51 are much less shocking than the
speculation all these years why do you
think the government maintains so much
secrecy about it
and i think we touched upon that as well
but i will also say that um
you know i take the reader all the way
up through the 80s one of the last
programs that i write about
uh was the f-117 bomber
the
that sort of diamond-shaped stealth
bomber that became famous in gulf war
one that was developed out at area 51
after the air force took over and sort
of replaced a lot of the camera bays
with weapons bays
um
but what has been going on since the war
on terror began
is a
is certainly out of my need to know and
um
and none of that i didn't have any
sources tell me what was really going on
there now
um because that really is obviously of
national security concern because we're
fighting the war on terror but it is
certainly a place where the drones are
test flow flown
and i also write another interesting
story
from right about 1998
when
drones everyone's familiar with them now
because they're used in pakistan but
they began
as espionage platforms that only carried
cameras
um
they were actually used in the serbian
bosnian conflict
and they were just kind of not
interesting to many people other than
the cia
but right around the late 90s this
unknown terrorist name osama bin laden
appeared on the scene
and the cia wanted to they were
considering assassinating him with a
with a drone and the way they would do
it was they would attach missiles to the
drone and this was kind of a radical
idea so they got together the cia and
the air force
and they decided to
engineer these hellfire missiles the
missiles are so accurate the hellfire
comes from fire and forget you just push
a button and it goes but first they had
to test it out there and the president's
concern at the time was well this osama
bin laden character is known to
do a lot of falcon hunting with members
of various middle eastern royal families
and
what if some somebody important is at
his compound when we attack him with
these
with this predator drone carrying a
hellfire missile that we don't know much
about we haven't used yet so they said
they built a mock-up of bin laden's
afghanistan farm which was called tarnac
farms and that's where they practiced um
how to possibly assassinate him without
collateral damage
uh this was before 9 11 but at the end
of the
at the end of the experiment the state
department got involved and there was
lots of legalities about assassinating
someone so they decided not to do it
so question how could area 51 secrets be
kept from american presidents
that's a very tricky and
uncomfortable question certainly for
this journalist um
but
in the very beginning of the book i
explained to you that something that i
found really pretty shocking when i
learned it
in researching this book that the atomic
energy commission actually has
a system of secret keeping that runs
parallel to the president's system of
secret keeping which is the national
security system
that is not the way the constitution was
written
but it is what the atomic energy act of
1946 allowed so when the charter was
written
right after world war ii for the atomic
energy commission they created the
system of secret keeping which the slang
for it is called born classified
scholars who have looked into this
secret keeping system
say that it's
it allows the aec to have
unanswerable authority
and that is certainly the case and that
is why the atomic energy commission was
able to
do so many things the bomb test i told
you about that sent the bugs up to 90
000 feet
that thermonuclear bomb test
it involved 12 000 people in the middle
of the pacific ocean
no one knew it was going on when it went
on
so
secret keeping is an important part of
area 51 for some reasons but it's also
not a good
situation for other reasons and it is
the source who tells me the story in the
end who told me that
um i asked him
you know
president clinton looked into the crimes
of the atomic energy commission
how come he didn't find out about this
rogue program at area 51 that involved
roswell and what he said to me was he
almost found out about it but he didn't
have a need to know
a question that goes back to
the ufo story
why would stalin send the craft to
roswell new mexico instead of a more
populated area
that's not an answer i have um
i'll ask the source i was kidding um no
i don't you know the thing that i write
in the end of the book is i'm very clear
about saying he said this and according
to the engineer um there are some places
in the epilogue where i speculate about
some things and i
i go to some of my other sources and ask
them i asked the physicist okay
you know could we really have had a a
stealthy flying disc the physicist ed
lovick who invented stealth for the cia
had an interesting answer which was that
he recalled sometime in the 1950s kelly
johnson who was the head of skunk works
who invented the um who built those
planes for the cia kelly johnson had ed
luvik radar tests some round-shaped
aircraft and at the end of the day they
decided that it just wasn't it just
wasn't you know
appropriate for a pilot to fly it was a
dangerous thing for a pilot to fly so
i you know i have as many questions as i
have answers actually i have more
questions than i have answers but i
don't have the answer to that one
although you write in the book the
roswell base
uh air base was actually an important
base and of course white sands los
alamos i mean that was not an
unimportant area in terms of national
security oh it was the most important
area in the united states you had los
alamos you had sandia los alamos was
where the nuclear scientists were
working
sandia was where the weapons were being
assembled and roswell was the five of
the base of the 509th which was the
bomber group
um you know one of the guys i interview
in the book is this amazing legend uh
colonel richard leghorn he's 92 now and
he's actually at home writing according
to his secretary he's at home writing a
paper on my book
and he just did an interview with the
cape cod times talking all about his
role in my book and um he is
accredited in general with inventing
the concept of overhead
uh our first post-nuclear
post-war nuclear test
was a in 1946 it was in the pacific it
was called operation crossroads and
colonel leghorn was in charge of
photographing those bombs from the air
and in my interview with him it was
amazing because he explained to me all
about how
the base from which they left with all
the camera equipment was the roswell
army air base because at the time that
was the only
military base in the country that had
bombers that could actually carry
nuclear weapons so
that area of new mexico couldn't have
been more important to national security
in 1947
if somebody wants to know if it's
possible and you answer this in the book
that many ufos were
actually were and are they right u.s
military aircraft that the united states
has been lying about
absolutely i mean one of the things that
i absolutely was able to source was the
cia's obsession with ufos starting in
the 1950s they actually even created
their own ufo
department and this is all based on
declassified documents it's funny to
read them read through them because the
see the guys at the cia in the 1950s
were really still
gentlemen spies they kind of fancied
themselves um
you know on the ground spies and this
idea of science and technology was a
little bit plebeian to them so you see
in all of these memos where they have to
deal with ufos
they're saying you know why can't the
air force handle this but in fact out at
area 51 the u2 spy plane
accounted for over 50 percent of all ufo
sightings on the west coast
it flew at 70 000 feet which is about 13
miles up and when it was flying up in
the sky it looked like a
giant silver cross
and
you can imagine people on the ground
seeing something up that high would
wonder
and then of course the same thing
happened in the 1960s when this
incredible cia spy plane called the ox
cart was flying at mach 3
even higher up
and there's a couple great accounts from
some of the guys in my book colonel
slater is one real cold war hero who i
write about he was the commander of the
base
for a number of years in the 60s and he
explained to me how often
commercial airline pilots would be
flying
on the west coast let's say at dusk
at thirty thousand feet
and they would see the ox cart fly over
overhead
at ninety thousand feet at mach three
and people in the plane would see it as
well and they would the pilots would
radio in you know ufo ufo and colonel
slater would have to send the fbi
to
wherever it was the plane was landing
and make the pilots and the people sign
inadvertent disclosure forms
letting them know they'd be in real
serious trouble if they told anyone
about that and these kind of things
certainly only added to the ufo lore and
mythology yeah plus i mean you have five
ox carts that crashed and of course the
as they went out to get the titanium
covers and all of that
obviously these kind of secret people
went out in in the desert and people saw
them and it all looked like they were
getting something very secret which was
but just not
flying saucer
which brings us to somebody asking why
in your opinion has area 51 become such
a popular element in u.s and global
popular culture
most assuredly because of the
conspiracies that are attached to it um
we've talked about the ufos um and the
aliens but there's two other big
conspiracy theories that are
sort of embedded themselves in area 51
they are that the
lunar landing was faked and filmed at
area 51. that's a big one
i interviewed a lot of conspiracy
theorists for my book i also interviewed
buzz aldrin
the second man on the moon and i found
his testimony to be a little bit more
believable than the
some of the other people but that's just
the journalist in me um
but there the thread the link there is
that
the
over at the nevada test site the
neighbor to area 51 there are these
giant craters
from the atomic bombs i was lucky enough
to go there
with a couple of the guys who were in my
book
and these atomic bomb craters are these
giant cavernous
you know things
that look very much like the surface of
the moon
and i interview a man named ernie
williams who actually was the tour guide
for the apollo astronauts
uh in the late 60s and early 70s they
would go out to the nevada test site and
put mock-ups on their back that they
would then you know that they would wear
on the moon when they finally went there
but they the point was to kind of roam
around the geology of the
lunar landscape
and i have some great photographs in the
book of that
but i think that this gave way to some
of the conspiracies about
the lunar landing and another one i'll
touch upon was the
a lot of conspiracy theorists told me
that area 51 is
filled with underground tunnels and that
these
tunnels connect to other military bases
across the country
what i found out was there are a lot of
underground tunnels
certainly at the nevada test site under
area 12 and 11.
one of the tunnels is 4500
feet deep that's
very deep
and starting in the late 1950s
the department of defense and the atomic
energy commission would use these
underground tunnels to explode nuclear
weapons
to see what would happen to different
pieces of military equipment to see what
could survive and what not so that's
where a lot of that mythology i believe
comes from
there's something right in the book that
nobody's going to ask about unless
they've read the book but i think is
important before i take the next
question
which is when we're talking about some
of the scientific recklessness something
that i had never heard of before reading
area 51 was we did a
a high altitude thermonuclear test that
they knew in advance might endanger the
ozone layer they kind of just wanted to
see what would happen
true
when i first heard about this it really
made me wonder whether um when you know
when i was growing up in the 70s we were
told that we couldn't use aerosol
deodorant anymore because it was ruining
the ozone and when i heard this i
thought i don't think it's the deodorant
um
and what's what's really interesting is
i heard this story from the nuclear
weapons engineer who actually wired this
bomb
um
but there were two nuclear tests code
named teak and orange
and they actually took place down in
johnston island in the pacific
um not at area 51 but the crew that
worked regularly at area 51
wiring nuclear bombs went down there
and the idea uh the president's science
advisor at the time his name was james
killian
um
he had such
power and persuasion with the president
that
anything he did he did not have to
report to congress
later in his memoirs he admits that
maybe that wasn't a good idea
but at the time
james killian authorized this
two-headed nuclear weapons test these
are megaton thermonuclear bombs
one was set off 28 miles up
the other was set off 50 miles up but 28
miles up is right around where the ozone
layer is
and
at the time there was i found in the
declassified documents there was
discussion among the scientists
what might happen
and could we make a hole in the ozone
layer this was an actual discussion
and the answer was
yes we could but
we believe the bomb turbulence would
then close back up that hole if it were
made and so they went ahead with the
test
there's a couple of questions from the
audience about sources
first one is if everyone's interviewed
is sworn to secrecy how is anything they
say valuable or believable and then a
variation on that do you have a top
secret clearance and if not what makes
you think these people you interviewed
told you the truth
um
what's interesting is some of the things
that i've been talking about like the
project 57 the dirty bomb test that um
spread plutonium over 895 acres up there
uh people have said to me that i've
asked me that exact question you know
well that's actually not classified
those documents i located
in the atomic energy commission archives
i even located photographs but
it didn't look to me like anyone else
had looked at them
and i actually had a really difficult
time trying to find them
but once i
was able to
find someone who had
knowledge of that and knew it had been
declassified
i was able to talk freely with him about
that program and he was able to give me
some keywords that allowed me
to look up the program and access it
the program is called project 57 but
everything was classified under 57
project i mean
organized um so
all of the programs that i talk about
except for the program in the end
have actually been declassified it's
just that a lot of them are kind of
hidden or perhaps people weren't
interested in them in and of themselves
i think part of what makes
my book interesting is that i
try to give you the whole landscape
of
area 51 and its nearest neighbors and
what was going on there
another one about uh
about the
aliens who
were according to your source not aliens
at all
were there autopsies done on the roswell
victims
according to his story two actually
lived but were in a coma
and why would their remains still remain
classified
the first part of the question was tell
me again the first part of the question
was were there autopsies
that i don't know
um
they arrived as as bodies um when they
arrived according to my source out at
area 51 and they were comatose but still
breathing one of them died shortly
thereafter according to my source
um
and the reason why the program is still
classified according to my source is
what we touched upon earlier that
the government decided to
embark upon its own program what i'm
also going to say at this point which is
interesting is that one of the most
interesting and disturbing pieces of
information that my source shared with
me was the individual who was the head
of the program his name was vannevar
bush
and vannevar bush was in charge of the
manhattan project
he was the president science advisor and
he is the one who or you know was in in
charge of this program that really is
the mother of all black operations that
is the manhattan project and all other
black operations kind of trickle down
from that original idea in both analogy
and also secrecy
you also point out for people who wonder
whether something
could be kept secret
the manhattan project the size and the
budget amount and even the vice
president had no idea that the manhattan
project was underway i mean how many
people were working what was the budget
of that thing
it's in the book
[Laughter]
um it was huge there was you know what
the where the
plutonium or the uranium at the time was
being processed
um in tennessee
that outfit pulled more power
off of the united states electrical grid
on any given night than the entire city
of new york city
and yet no one knew it was there
that's how powerful a black operation
can be
the vice president that you're referring
to when the manhattan project was
originally going on was harry truman he
had no idea
about the nuclear weapon until he became
president
and the person who told him was vannevar
bush
basic question why name it area 51 are
there 1 through 50 if so explain
well that's the subject of great debate
a lot of people even a lot of my my
named sources in the book will say oh
that's just a quadrant that they came up
with
but according to my source in the end of
the book
the reason that it is named area 51 is
because in 1951
the original equipment and the remains
of the roswell crash came there
have you been called a conspiracy
theorist this audience member asked the
net of conspiracy theory has been cast
so wide it often includes investigative
reporters such as yourself in other
words you kind of get thrown in with the
3 a.m
i i'll let you guys decide on that one
but what i do know is that a lot you
know i've been accused of it i've
definitely been accused of being um
you know part of the government
conspiracy to hide aliens because my
theory does not
push the idea that aliens have visited
earth and i did get a letter from a
group or an email rather from a group in
the uk
furious with me last week when my book
first published they said even we don't
believe you
[Laughter]
the truth is still out there not here
why did area 51 show up in the wikileaks
document this person wants to know was
it only due to weapons testing or about
alien life or what that's news to me i
don't know about that so see me
afterwards
there was a and a lot of the book is
about we're talking about reverse
engineering because it
comes up and talking about roswell and
things one of the most significant parts
of the book and reverse engineering that
went on at area 51 one of the greatest
secrets was reverse engineering
the mig that was kind of hand delivered
for a million dollars by an iraqi pilot
to the israelis
it's a great story it's one of my
favorites in there and i tell it through
the eyes of t.d barnes who was a an
engineer who worked out at area 51 on a
number of projects
in 1966 your the story that you're
talking about made headlines when an
iraqi air force colonel named munir
redfa
defected from iraq to israel in a soviet
mig and at the time no one had no
western
you know no member of the western world
had ever had their hands on the soviet
mig it's what all the arab uh nations
flew and it's obviously what the soviets
the communist black countries flew
so the mossad got a hold of it it was a
very big deal to them it helped them win
the six day war
but what didn't make the news was that
after they were done with it they made a
deal with the cia
to bring munir redford's mig to area 51.
and td barnes was on the team
that reverse engineered that mig they
took it down to its nuts and bolts
and looked at it to figure out what made
it fly
and at the time we were engaged in the
vietnam war and our pilots over there
were getting shot down in this terrible
ratio of nine to one we were really
losing against the mig
the soviets were supplying the north
vietnamese with the mig and so
there was a halt on the dogfights over
vietnam while the
engineers worked on the mig out there at
area 51
and after they reverse engineered it
that was called the technical phase then
they began what was called the tactical
phase so they put the mig back together
and they began flying it in dog fights
mock dog fights
and the skies over area 51 to figure out
how to beat the mig in air-to-air combat
and what is not known um until now or
kind of known only to the
the men who worked on that program is
that that was actually the birth of the
famous top gun fighter school
there is there's another
thing that comes of that make being
there that almost outs area 51 and some
of the top secret projects there when a
general decides basically to go
joyriding in a mig that's right and it's
a pretty controversial story there was a
general who is in charge of the f-117
bomber program
out that was going on out at area 51 and
he became enamored uh with the mig
according to sources and he wanted to
take it for a flight and he did and um
the mig went out of control and crashed
in area 25 next door to it's about maybe
20 miles from area 51
and he where he crashed was right into
this place where another secret program
was going on
surprise surprise um
and so at the time it was like my god
we've got the mig program we've got the
f-117 program we've got the nerva
program at area 25 we've got area 51
you know and you've got a general who's
dead
so
a newspaper reporter was leaked
information that the general had been
flying the mig and that program was
outed in that way and it allowed the
other secrets to remain hidden
there's a number of questions about the
advanced technology created at area 51
such as mach 3 speed aircrafts and why
this has not been released
commercially
questioner says it's odd that our
current commercial aircrafts can only
travel at a fraction of this speed
compared to
what area 51 technology had half a
century ago
are commercial aircrafts
you know i'm not an expert on jet
engines i did interview robert athernap
robert abernathy who developed the mach
3 engine for pratt and whitney and it
was super interesting talking to him
about that but my understanding
would be and it's limited but that you
know it takes so much jet fuel to fly uh
mach 3 the
the ox cart spy plane was basically a
flying fuel tank it had a delta shaped
wing that was just filled with fuel
um it could get from one coast to the
other coast in a little over 60 minutes
so i don't think that would be cost
effective
on a commercial airline and you would
not really have any place to put your
bags
plus all that mid-air refueling yes
mid-air refueling is tricky too um
yeah and then a couple of planes were
lost yes and stories that you tell in
the book
uh well i'm gonna say one of the things
you know the the
i became a big fan of the cia's science
and technology department i must say
because the things that they did out
there and they did it in total secrecy
without getting any any credit for it
but to refuel the ox car it was such a
incredibly fast flying plane the ox
guard had to fly at it at its absolutely
slowest speed and the fuel tanker had to
fly at its fastest speed
you know at the same time and uh
you know the plane the ox cart would
sometimes almost stall that's how slow
it had to go
um somebody in the audience says why do
you think the government was prompted to
declassify all of this stuff and provide
great stuff for your book
well that's also an interesting question
they didn't declassify all this stuff
they declassified the a12 ox cart in
2007 and i don't know why um i've asked
some
people at langley why and they have
different different answers none of
which really answer the question um
because if you're trying to keep a base
secret it would make sense not to
declassify one of the major programs
there
uh
but that is how i was able to
speak to ed luvik who was the original
source
and that is how i was introduced one to
the next to the next of all the
different sources who
um make up the narrative of my book and
to whom i'm very grateful because you
know it was a real honor and a privilege
to be able to
talk to these men
who
are really a group of cold war heroes
scientists spies engineers physicists
who were known only among themselves
and now i think
in reading the book you're able to see
a really have a really interesting
window into what it's like to be someone
who
does all this work for absolutely no
glory
there is a story you tell in the book
that people have to read the book to
know that is possibly the most
frightening
well there's many frightening parts of
the book
and it is a staged attack
on area 51 to test the perimeters for
security even though it was secret to
many americans the russians had known
about this place since forever
and uh watched it by satellites and so
they decided to test the security
if i understand it from your book
correctly without telling anybody at
area 51
and
during the time of a nuclear test
that's right and the way that i was able
to put that story together was very
interesting because the actual mock
attack on the guard gated area 51 by
whack and hot security guards is still
classified
but what isn't classified
is the fact that these nuclear weapons
test engineers on the other side of the
fence were working to get a nuclear bomb
down into a shaft so that they could
explode it on a weapons test and so the
story came from the guys who were
over on the other side of the fence who
were working on the nuclear bomb not
from the guys at area 51 who can't talk
about it um but what happened was
there was this weapons test going on and
you they measure
they measure the system of measurement
to get a bomb down into its hole is
picked so it's like you know x number of
yards means it's this pick and it has to
get to a certain depth before it's
considered secured otherwise it could
still in essence be hijacked and so
there's different layers of security
that are watching this bomb go down and
the gentleman who is in charge of the
program is my um source in the book
richard mingus he was in charge of it
and there he is waiting for the thing to
get down the thing the nuclear bomb to
get down the hole and he hears suddenly
were under attack and they had to treat
that as if the russians were attacking
or an enemy force was attacking because
it made no sense otherwise but as it
turned out
it was actually a test by the security
people who wanted to see what it would
be like
uh how the guards at the area 51 gate
would respond to an attack and so they
flew a helicopter over the guard gate
and were you know mock shooting at it
the alert went all the way to the white
house and according to the source um the
the nuclear subs on the west coast were
also put on alert
i sleep better hearing that um
and with a live
nuclear weapon in the hole yes at that
time and the test went on by the way
number of questions from people
saying many of uh here's one of the many
of the united states military projects
born or developed near a51 including the
f-117 stealth fighter
was the blackhawk helicopter used in the
osama bin laden raid
developed at area 51
i would certainly like to know that but
i don't have a need to know about that
yet
sounds like it would be a great place to
uh fly those helicopters or practice
that
weather technology developed there going
going it's kind of a variation in the
previous question about the aircraft
whether the technology there so you know
the famous questions about teflon and
in the space whether the technology
there so you know the famous questions
about teflon and in the space program
and all of that has
gotten out into the commercial world at
all or whether what's developed there is
just so secret
what what's developed at area 51 stays
at area 51. that's a really interesting
question and i don't i haven't heard
about any um commercial applications it
tends to be
military and espionage based
including the stealth paint and
all of that yes the first attempt at
which was apparently according to the
book something of a disaster
yes they tried to originally make the u2
stealthy
um because when the pilots like hervey
stockman and immediately were flying
over the soviet union the soviets were
able to track them right away
they couldn't shoot them down because
they were so high up but the physicist
ed luvik was called on board to try and
make the u2 stealthy it didn't work and
one of the pilots was killed out there
flying one of the planes that had been
uh
doctored up with some
some paint that was supposed to be
camouflage and instead it made the plane
overheat
unfortunately we've reached one of our
program where there's time for only one
last question
and uh somebody kind of open-ended for
you
was there one particular story that you
found the most shocking or surprising of
the things you learned about area 51
you know
everything that was told to me was
very ornate and very interesting and i
think
all circled back to allow
me to create
the puzzle so to speak the all these
individual pieces that in and of
themselves were fascinating
um to understand the broader bigger
picture of area 51
was what i found the most rewarding
certainly at the end to step back and
say this makes sense and this is this
this is why it's secret and this is what
went on there even though i probably
only know a small fraction of it um
winston churchill once said about and he
was speaking about russia he said it's
an enigma wrapped inside of a puzzle
wrapped inside of a riddle
and
he could have been speaking about area
51.
our thanks andy jacobson los angeles
magazine columnist
author of the new book area 51 and
uncensored history of america's top
secret military base
this event was hosted by the
commonwealth club of california in san
francisco for more information visit
commonwealthclub.org
we'd like to hear from you
if everybody could take a seat that'd be
great
and just a couple of things at the
beginning if um
i could ask you all to
silent silence your
cell phones mobile devices etc
and afterwards these authors will be
signing their books
in signing area 7
and
people out there will be guiding
both them and you towards
wherever
signing area seven
is i think we should rename it area 51.
it's probably a little bit easier to
find than area 51. we have
maybe not so dangerous
anyway the title of the panel is
surveillance and secrets and i'm just
going to briefly
introduce
each of these terrific writers
and then ask them to
speak about their own books
for
a few minutes and then we'll have a
discussion and then
i'll throw it open to you guys fairly
early on because i think there are going
to be a ton of questions
about
these subjects which
touch all of us very sort of um
immediately
so
down the end there
we have laurie andrews
and
she is a professor of law
at
illinois at the illinois institute of
technology
she's been a visiting professor at
princeton
and she's an expert on
biotechnologies the author of the clone
age
and
much of what she's written has been
about the
legal implications of
genetic
science and research
but her new book
i know who you are
and saw what you did
is
it's a great title a very
scary
read about
the information that we
give away about ourselves
without even thinking about it
every time
we go on the internet or
log on to facebook or even just go
to a website
and um
not even buy something but research
something
and
it really does feel like
my wife said to me when she saw me
reading it the other night you know
is it as bad as i think in terms of
what they found out about us i said
it seems to be way way worse
than you can imagine
and sitting next to laurie is michael
schumer
whose new book is called the believing
brain
um
which is
is basically a study of um
how we come to believe some of the
things we do believe
and
how those beliefs mutate
and michael's a
specialist in
crazy thinking um
he took a degree in psychology um
a detail i
didn't know until i just read about this
this morning he was a competitive
cyclist
and even has a medical ailment named
after him
and um
he's the editor and
creator of the skeptic magazine
and um the author of many books and i
know because i've
been on a panel with him before
is one of the most
brilliant and entertaining panelists
i've ever encountered in all the time
i've been doing this so
michael that's something for you to live
up to
thanks
and
here we have annie jacobson
whose
first book
is it
an epic piece of research about area 51
that huge
piece of
edwards air force base
up in the nevada desert that the
government
still i think sometimes tries to say
doesn't even exist
where
the above ground
nuclear testings were going on
through the 40s and 50s
and where
their various um
high-tech surveillance
jets that the stealth bomber before that
the black bird was developed there right
and uh of course it's the sort of
the locus
in popular mythology of um
the place where the aliens were taken by
the government
when
they landed in the late 1940s so
if we all remember the
the film uh independence day
the nasty creatures that come from the
spaceship uh
they're being probed and investigated in
what presumably is area 51 right
um so anyway i'll just ask each in turn
to talk about their book a little bit
and
starting with you laurie
so what did you reveal about yourself in
the past 24 hours online did you post
drunken pictures from last night did you
like a certain author you saw yesterday
did you apply for a job that your
current employer doesn't know about
uh well amazingly everything that we're
doing on the web is being tracked by
data aggregators in one form or another
and you know and sometimes it's to give
us ads tell us where our favorite band
is playing or money off at a store in
other times it may be used to
disadvantage you
so um google routinely searches gmail to
craft ads and so if i email a friend
through gmail and say i'm thinking of
getting a divorce they have that
information about me or if i
google search
a medical condition they have that
information or if i
search for
old guitars to buy
well it turns out if i've done that and
then i go to a credit card website
they will use that information and if
i'm if they think i'm about to get
divorced or i'm in a band
and we know that divorcees and members
of you know garage rock bands more
likely to renege on their credit cards
they actually offer me a lower limit
without giving me the chance to
correct that
and so in my book i look at how that's
occurring
and what we can do about it and it's the
225th anniversary of the us constitution
and so i bring up issues about why is it
that our offline rights are more
protected than our online rights and
what would we need online to protect
privacy and freedom of association in a
right to fair trial because some jurors
are now actually posting the facts of
the case on facebook in one case a
criminal case and asking their friends
to vote up or down about whether they
should fry the guy
so those are some of the things i talk
about in my book
michael
so um
well my book's based on what i do for a
living which is published skeptic
magazine it's a science-based magazine
here in southern california we
investigate pla
claims of the paranormal pseudoscience
fringe groups and cults and claims of
all kinds between good science junk
science bad science voodoo science
pathological science
non-science and plain old nonsense
and unless you've been abducted by
aliens and been in area 51 for the past
few decades you know there's a lot of it
out there nonsense that is and some
people call us debunkers but let's face
it there's a lot of bunk
and it's our job to debunk it and uh
and more importantly though i think
trying to understand why people believe
those things uh weird things so the the
the short answer why people believe
weird things
uh is because we have to believe things
and weird things are a subset of things
and we're not really good at
discriminating between correct things
and weird things or incorrect things so
as a matter of course then the whole uh
cluster of cognitive biases that help
reinforce our beliefs as truths
uh turn out to be very powerful and that
we're not very objective
uh rational reasoners we are not the
embodiment of the enlightenment idea of
a rationally calculating human being
we're not like that at all so
the reason we need science is because uh
as flawed as it may be it is still the
best system we have for
getting at what we think is real
in terms of not just what i think but
what you can go out and check also and
you can run the experiment in the same
way
and you can check the data as well as i
can check the data and i might be biased
and you might be biased but there's some
other lab that will gain a value in
debunking our silly ideas so the
competitive nature of science i think is
what gives us confidence that there's
there's some hope for figuring out the
way the world actually is now in the
surveillance secrets and surveillance
topic i guess the closest in my book
would be my chapter on conspiracy
theories um the reason in part that
exists is because there are secrets
and governments do conspire to do all
sorts of things not just governments
everybody whenever two or more people
get together to talk about what they're
going to do to you
without you knowing about it that's you
know technically by definition a
conspiracy
and that happens all the time so it's
not unusual or unreasonable to be
suspicious
and
and cautious skeptical uh in thinking
that might be people conspiring
against you the problem is is how do we
know which conspiracies are true and
which aren't because most aren't
conspiracy theories are not true
but some are lincoln was assassinated by
a conspiracy uh there was a whole
conspiracy to assassinate to decapitate
the entire lincoln cabinet and all of
them failed except the one
and watergate was a conspiracy but but
here's a clue that
the most powerful administration in
on the planet couldn't even break into a
hotel room
so
so the idea that they could they could
like run a world economy like the
illuminati these 12 guys in london
running the economy and doing a crappy
job of it uh you know is so so i sort of
go through a little uh sort of bologna
detection kit version of conspiracy
detection kit that is the more people
that are involved the less likely the
theory is to be true because for two
reasons one most people are incompetent
and two most people can't keep their
mouth shut
so the more people you have involved the
more leakage is going to be and and
bumbling and fumbling your way through
and and so on the more elements that
have to be involved they have to come
together just the right time at just the
right place perfectly the less likely
anyone is going to be able to do that
the bigger and grander the conspiracy is
the less likely it is to be true
most conspiracies do involve very
specific targeted things you know we
want to conspire to collude about the
price of a product or we want to control
some little market or we want to spy on
some particular government agency that
we're not sure
those are more likely to be true than
global dominance of the new world order
to build a highway that goes through the
entire north american and south american
continent and they're building
concentration camps to put americans in
in places that are invisible because no
one's found one and the more it's so
grandiose it becomes the less likely the
conspiracy is to be true
so
so i'll just end by saying when
the fundamental principle of science is
what's called the null hypothesis the
null hypothesis is that
uh your hypothesis is not true
this is our assumption whatever your
idea is it's not true until you prove to
us otherwise
and we have to do that because most
ideas that people have are not true
you know i got the cure for cancer aids
or whatever there's a there's 10 000 of
these on the internet you know 99.9
percent are not true so the fda just has
to start off with the null hypothesis
your cure for the cancer is not true
until you show us your data your
epidemiological studies your controlled
experiments and so on and then we'll
consider so that's the way i think we
should apply the principle which apply
to everything
your crazy idea might be true but
probably not but go ahead and give us
your best shot
thanks michael
annie
what a great panel to be on um secrets
and surveillance and there is certainly
in my opinion no greater place where
secrets and surveillance meet
and that's at area 51 which is
located out in the nevada desert about
75 miles north of las vegas
and yes you are right the government has
never officially admitted that area 51
exists although it certainly does and i
assure you it does i interviewed 74 men
for my book their stories are in my book
and they all worked and lived there for
extended periods of time they worked for
the cia for the air force for the atomic
energy commission for the department of
defense
and they're living breathing humans i
did not come across any aliens when i
was researching my book
but i did come across some very very
strange dark ideas about conspiracies
and why they might exist i have a couple
chapters which i write about black
propaganda
area 51 is tied to ufos for a very good
reason
the surveillance that was developed
there in the uh starting in the 50s
starting in 1951
is you know surrounds us today when you
read
as you may have last month when
president obama on valentine's day gave
the faa 63 billion dollars
to uh revamp the rules of the sky and
made kind of in a very secret way room
for what's going to be 30 000 drones uh
flying overhead by 2014.
that traces back to area 51 that's where
we first began developing drones we
being the cia
many people think i'm part of the cia
i'm not um that was the royal we
um
but uh that is where we developed drones
and very interesting drones drones in
1960 they could go mach 3. this is
astounding this still holds the record
for speed if you believe that it still
holds the record for speed
the government tells you it holds the
record for speed
2 300 miles an hour
drones in 1962 out in the nevada desert
that's some very serious advanced
technology people often ask me what i
think is going on there now what kind of
drones they're coming up with i can only
imagine um i know that you know it's
great to be on the panel with these two
interesting authors and uh you know
all of our ideas kind of meet and merge
in this idea of secrets of surveillance
and for me who writes about you know
really looks at the military and
espionage elements of surveillance um
it's fascinating to me that the that the
private sector and the military sector
people begin people see now how they
merge when they look at drones today but
of course this goes back um
you know to the 1950s when it all began
out there at area 51 and i i love
answering questions on that so
take it
uh laura yeah i wanted to ask you um i
just want to play devil's advocate for a
moment here with with your book and say
well
hey you know if i go on amazon and
amazon you know remembered that i was
was um
looking for a novel by i don't know vs
nypal say you know it suggests well you
might want to try ben ocry too
then
you know isn't that just a kind of
furtherance of the excellence of
capitalism and isn't that something that
we should all be applauding and
what
was it that kind of first really kind of
spooked you
about
the net and what prompted you to write a
different
kind of book than the ones you've
written before
well you're totally right that these
tracking technologies started with
amazon you know remembering my credit
card number remembering what i liked
which is a real
um which is a real benefit to me but
then it got a little
wild in terms of the type of targeting
they did so
imagine you're a 13 year old girl and
you're feeling fat and so you put in
you know i'm interested in weight loss
or something on google to find something
out now every place you go you go to
look up
a movie time it's like feeling fat you
should take this you know it sort of is
psychologically harmful but it also can
be
um financially harmful socially harmful
um google admitted in 2010 that when
young people were saying on a google
chat room
you know i'm thinking of committing
suicide using x chemical an ad appeared
that said dial 1 800 now 2 for 1x
chemical and so there's something about
it you know that gets to be
you know creepy uh at some level and you
might have all followed the the girls
like me app that was pulled off the
apple store there was nothing legally
wrong with it but what it did is if you
were in a bar
you could see pictures from the facebook
pages of women
and since
you know 13 year olds can go on facebook
you know young people too where they
were you can click on it and find their
whole facebook page if they had a public
page and
you know it just is like you know
stalker heaven one woman's rapist found
her through
um spokeo and so my um my thought is you
should at least be asked you know
amazon should say do you want to be you
want us to remember it which it does
but you know i've written 14 books i
love dictionary.com it keeps me alive
but it puts 233 tracking mechanisms on
my computer without asking so ask me
michael i mean in one way the the sort
of um
there's this
there's a common ground between um the
three of you in this idea of the sort of
the interior world that the individual
inhabits
supposed
reality
whatever we mean by that which is kind
of out there and then this
nebulous area where
the virtual world
belief systems um
act on them both and liaise between the
two between what we mean by the real and
what we mean by our own personal
consciousness
in ways that kind of come to see seem
manipulative
right so that's why i mentioned science
at least helps us get out of our own
skin
in terms of the competitive nature of it
if i don't identify my own cognitive
biases
and slant on the data that i put
somebody else will be motivated to do so
because they can actually gain career
advantages or whatever by debunking my
ideas by identifying the flaws and
that's the idea of peer review it's not
perfect
because there is the problem of kind of
collective ignorance where people
collectively think that everybody else
thinks x
and even though i personally don't think
so i think you think so and therefore i
don't want to stand out too much so i
pretend like i do and you you you think
the same thing as me but so you pretend
pretty soon the whole room here
is actually thinking one thing but
saying something different so we know
how that works psychologically you know
solomon ash's famous experiments of the
three lines and the matching line and if
you have four out of five people the one
four shills and one
subject
they all identify the other line the
obviously incorrect one 65 percent of
the time that the subject will go along
with that and there's a whole series of
these
you know reading a literary criticism uh
tasting wine if if the subject thinks
everybody else in the room likes the
vinegar tagged wine
they'll say oh yeah it's bouquet is so
rich
even though they don't really think that
right so um you know and this goes a
long way to explaining uh you know how
totalitarian regimes can last as long as
they do even though most people in the
country don't really believe the line
they think everybody else does and they
have to send the signal socially that
you know that they believe too
there's a famous case alexander social
nation writes about of a part of a a
party meeting in moscow under stalin
where he got some award it was his
birthday or something so they gave him a
standing ovation that went for three
minutes four minutes five minutes six
minutes no one dared sit down
and finally after 13 minutes some guy
stopped clapping and sat down and he was
promptly arrested and sent to the gulag
so this is how that collect so this is
the problem
that we face that there's no good
solution i call it belief dependent
realism that our realities really depend
on our beliefs and the only hope we have
is to have some kinds of checks and
balances
on that which is what science provides
not perfectly but at least better than
nothing
and in a way i mean what laurie's book
is saying is that sort of um you know
that you
you couldn't kind of elect a totalian
totalitarian regime in in
america just
the whole ideology of
american democracy is so powerful that
it could just never happen but in a way
this de facto
capitalist form of
totalitarianism has happened through
the internet which is sort of
extraordinary it's been we've given away
this stuff without even having
my favorite quotes is from a security
analyst richard power and he said think
about if the government tried to get
this information that we post on
facebook or google
um you know it's the most intimate
information our political beliefs our
sexual preferences where we are at
various points in time where we're
checking in what we like or don't like
about our life our family our boss he
said if the government tried to get it
it would take
money it would take lawyers it might
even take guns
and yet we
post it you know freely and 93 of the
time when the government asks google
for that information they cough it up so
some people have been tried entirely
based on their google searches and
heaven forbid you know like my sister
should disappear because i've written
three mysteries i google search you know
date rape drugs different sorts of you
know the depth of lakes nearby you know
you know odorless poisons i blow up the
white house in one so if i'm taken away
in cops you know
no i didn't do it
i think it's also important to remember
that it was the department of defense
that created the internet during the
vietnam era and it was arpa the advanced
research projects agency now it's known
as darpa and when you look at where a
lot of the finance is coming from
certainly not with necessarily with
google but with you know general atomics
for example the people that are creating
and learning about these
information systems and providing them
out there in the private sector are
funded over here
by
places like darpa and so there's an
interplay and on the subject of
totalitarian regimes it's also important
to remember at area 51 the reason why
surveillance was born and it was born
there in peace time peacetime overhead
surveillance equals area 51. and that
was to track
essentially the soviet union and the
whole idea of government surveillance
is so that you don't know it's going on
and that is the underlying premise that
i find fascinating when people are
talking about the internet because there
couldn't be
more of a conflict of interest of giving
your information out and also at the
same time trying to remain private
um
all you know i just love looking back
because i think it's interesting to look
forward and one of the very earliest
drones that the cia created and this was
in 1971
and i saw this um i saw a little version
of this it was called the insectothopter
and it was designed to look like a
dragonfly and it really did look like a
dragonfly and it beat its wings and it
was filled with a thumb full of a
thimble full of gasoline and that was
then so and of course now we have
hummingbird drones but they're much more
realistic looking and so i think we go
from the internet to what's at your
window looking at you well also what's
in your pocket because
we you know i mean it's a perfect
situation for surveillance you have an
iphone there are apps that people
download that seem innocuous one's
called into now so if i'm watching the
good wife on tv you know it remotely
activates my phone and it can tell what
i'm watching on tv and it puts me in a
chat room with other people watching
that and then ads come on do you want to
buy alicia's suit all this
well you don't realize that by allowing
remote activation of your mic it also
collects data about things like
does she eat in a restaurant does she
eat at home does she have sex with
someone of the same sex or the opposite
sex so our very technologies can be used
to spy on us a high school in
philadelphia gave laptops to all their
students didn't tell the students or
parents that the webcam
could be turned on from the school
and
the school tech people took tens of
thousands of photos
of both the teachers and students it was
only supposed to be used if your laptop
was stolen but i mean think about high
school students they've got them open in
their bedroom they're coming out of the
shower they're having friends over doing
who knows what
and um
and yet that um you know
no one was prosecuted for
for that and it was only it only came to
light when one kid was called in and a
principal showed him a picture taken of
him in his bedroom
and he was shocked and she said you're
using illegal drugs and he looked at
what was in his hands and it was mike
and ike's candies
so um you know a warning about the
actual technologies use what you google
collects gps information even when
you've turned off the gps on your droid
phone
and you know looking at
the nine zero supreme court decision
about how
gps tracking can be an invasion of
privacy because
it
it tells things like whether you've gone
to a synagogue or a church or whether
you're at an aids treatment center or an
abortion clinic you can find all that
out through gps so
you know we may be
our own worst enemy in terms of
what we buy in terms of apps and so
forth well in your book the kind of the
detail that uh made it so concrete for
me was that the the school story where
they send out the computers and
the girl who notices that the computer
the light is winking at her
and she thinks well why is it doing that
and
covers it up yeah yeah and so so now
i've got my
a little posted on the laptop camera in
my hotel room here after reading about
that case
well in principle why couldn't you just
do that
across the board if you get ads on
amazon just ignore them
you could do what i do every time a guy
in a pickup truck pulls up next to me
listening to rush i just roll up the
window
but most of this you don't know is
occurring so if in other words
yeah
but you know it's not a matter of
changing the channel though when this is
on the back end so that when my web
searches are used without my knowing it
in terms of whether i get a credit card
or not you know so in under the fair
credit reporting act
uh if a credit rating agency said
something bad about me i'd have a right
to correct it
if however the credit card agency thinks
because i've you know looked up things
on suicide
for a novel
that i'm likely to commit suicide after
running up a big bill they make these
decisions life insurance companies
credit card companies i can't change the
channel because i don't even know i'm on
that channel
what we're talking about here is the
difference between what the cia would
call humit and sigit or elend and that's
human intelligence
or electronic intelligence or signals
intelligence and again using the analogy
of espionage this was the the reason we
created surveillance platforms in the
first place was to spy on the russians
because the iron curtain was so
difficult to penetrate
that the human the human intelligence
the spies on the ground were unable to
deliver that information to the cia that
they so desperately needed so that they
could advise the president to make you
know decisions on national security and
so along came the idea of sigint and i
write in my book the the precursors to
all of that took place at area 51 the
first kind of nsa agents are in my book
interviewed and they say that it used to
be a dirty word elent you know that
people um at that upper echelons of
government didn't want to be looking at
signals intelligence and electronic
intelligence it was sort of foreign and
too scientific and they liked that idea
of you know men on the ground with the
cloak and dagger aspects and you can see
how far we've come and you can certainly
see
how much easier and how much less
expensive it is to have eyes in the sky
and certainly the stakes are a lot lower
for the united states i mean look at the
predator you we're fighting an entire
war with a drone with a few missiles on
it
yeah i mean you get into that in a in a
very concrete way that the
the issue of what they were actually
trying to produce in area 51
it all looked like well why wouldn't we
want to have that in one way
but then
there is the other side that well
once you open that door which certainly
did get opened and which
i wonder whether we can actually kind of
close pandora's box now and i know that
you laurie you're appealing for
the constitution about the way
the net should operate but do you do you
really think that that can
isn't that pie in the sky that hope
i'm constantly working on hopeless
causes and some of the you know i mean
i spent 17 years trying to get a genetic
anti-discrimination bill passed in
congress and that ultimately
happened i think that the fact that in
in europe um we do have there are more
protections
um so you can find out what companies
know about you and an austrian law
student wrote to facebook and said what
info do you have and
got a cd-rom back with a pdf of 600
files everything he'd ever deleted
everybody who'd ever had any contact
with
and you have certain rights to correct
the big issue is um
you know whether some this being a
capitalist country as you point out a
market economy whether someone's just
going to come along and
create some more privacy enhancing
technology so for example
some people are working on
digital tags in photos so they
self-destruct after
two years so the
all my law students in chicago who i
don't know why they think this is such a
great idea sent me their you know
drunken st patrick's day green river
photos in chicago
that wouldn't exist when they then went
out on the
job market it would certainly have
behooved the department of defense to
have that um
on the market technology because when
they when our
drone recently went down over iran the
rq sentinel our top secret stealth drone
developed at area 51 and the iranians
got a hold of it it didn't self-destruct
and of course the first people that they
invited to come look at it were the
chinese
and someone asked me well reverse
engineering is very difficult well
that's not true i mean my kids do it
with legos all the time your kids
probably too too and grandchildren but
reverse engineering is the way to find
out how
something works and that's a big part of
area 51 and it's also a big part of why
they call all of this a race and not a
standstill you know
as things move forward and people are in
a race
the technology is accumulative
um
i'm sure that lots of you are going to
have questions so
if we just get ready for that part of
this
panel where if people will step forward
to the mics
i do have an example of a of a of a
camera spy
uh run by the government that uh is very
invasive there's a
red light camera at wilshire
and the beverly hills hotel such that if
you are going uh east on wilshire and
you turn right
on the red light there there's no street
there it's just the driveway in the
beverly hills hotel it's a 479 dollar
ticket
and why do you suppose they put it there
because anybody going to beverly hills
hotel a has money and b they don't live
around here so they're not going to
fight the ticket
or else they live around here and
they're with someone they shouldn't be
with you you can see in the car
the high def video i mean
yeah you could definitely see somebody
sitting in your car
okay so that would be an example in
support of what you're saying i guess
let's get some questions going starting
with this gentleman yeah i have uh i
have two different email addresses with
two different uh domain names and i'm
wondering if i send myself an email
talking about islamic jihad in
thermonuclear warfare and how long will
it be before i get an answer from
some government agent
well the department of homeland security
does have a a group of 350 words that
they searched and i talked about some of
them in my book because some of them are
pretty innocuous pork vaccine even the
term social media itself so if the la
times you know promoted this in any way
talking about social media it would it
would be um
be picked up and so maybe that's why
conspiracies fail so much i mean they
you know they've created a lot of
information which
also they did with the early
surveillance in the cold war i mean i
have a friend's father who worked in
that program and told me all about the
um the naked russian women on the tops
of their apartment building sunbathing
that he actually has pictures of so you
do get a lot of stuff and it may not
actually be the stuff you can most use
those did not dissolve after five
minutes
uh from my understanding from the
different um folks in the cia that i use
as sources is that
most of the words that they're looking
for are coded because the codes are you
know
somebody isn't going to say
thermonuclear weapon it's more like you
know popeye or something and um that
runs into a whole other host no it's
like
sure because um there actually were
there's an interesting legal opinion
because drug dealers um you know
smartened up and they're not carrying
drugs in a jaguar maserati they're using
like a gray honda
and so the cops on the route from
florida up to pennsylvania stop started
stopping every gray honda and you know
because they're like drug you know drug
lords now use normal cards and the
judges finally said you cannot have a
rule that some you know that something
is suspiciously normal you know and so
people using the word pork for some you
know incredible reason like you know
could you pick this up on the store on
the way home get swept in as potential
offenders along with you know with that
with people who are actual offenders
yeah this is a fascinating panel and i
have a dozen questions i'm thinking the
one to actually spit out and it's this
i agree that you could term the data
collection that goes on every day
as insidious but
if we were to actually care about it
would that not be paranoia i mean do we
actually think that the government
really cares
about all these little things
that that populate our lives
you know my concern is actually less the
government
than social institutions so
fascinating to me that now 75 percent of
employers require their human resource
people to look at your online profile
one-third of employers say they don't
hire someone if they have a drink in
their hand on facebook even an innocent
wine glass
you know at a wedding and so those are
big deal things to me because it's not
like something i can knowingly
you know avoid if i if i if i don't
realize that's going on so i'm more
concerned about
people being disadvantaged one you know
i mean do we really want right now
if you play college sports now they're
starting to require that athletes friend
the coach
i mean if you think social networks are
valuable at all should they be
you know constantly monitored for signs
of
a bad behavior right now if
women in a custody case post anything
sexy on their facebook page
they lose custody of the child now that
shouldn't be that doesn't relate to
their ability to mother
um and so those are the concerns the
private institutions and courts use
right now i would change that
that's a good argument so michael though
is there a point at which kind of caring
becomes you know bothering
yeah
very conflicted about this because i
have sort of strong libertarian leanings
of liking privacy i don't like the idea
of governments especially spying on us
but on the other hand evil happens in in
secrecy
uh and so you know tweet the revolution
facebook uh the revolution i mean this
is a good thing when everybody's got a
camera it's harder for governments
autocratic and uh theocratic governments
to pull off violence against their
citizens which in the long history of
civilization is the norm where we're the
exception in in america but uh uh the
governments normally suppress their
people using all these different tools
in secret so i like that aspect of it
yeah and it's you know on
it's an interesting question and i think
from the standpoint of looking at the
military and the government
most of the surveillance projects that
they're working on are for warfighting
be they defensive or offensive and so
the average person is absolutely not
important to them as the
as the gentleman um pointed out however
it does create technology that then as
you're writing about
can be used for those purposes
gentlemen
yes
i i just finished glenn greenwald's book
where he paints a very detailed and
exquisite picture about how
certain groups in this country are
immune from the law
and i listen to progressives with
intelligent and exquisite analysis
of what is being done to us and then i
listen to the news where in tennessee
they are going to balance out religion
with science on an equal basis
and it seems to me that while as a
middle class jew from los angeles i'm
not about to go out and commit domestic
terrorism it seems to me that the only
model that stands against this is what
we are seeing in afghanistan
with the taliban where they are not
electronically dependent and where
they're saying we ain't going for this i
put out a website called per daily.com
where i talk about the purposeful
failing of public education in the
united states
and i look at the ghettos where 44 years
after the walkout in east los angeles
latino education is worse than ever and
no one pays any attention and i go to
seminars like this i'll finish i'll
finish my question is
will you address yourself
to the possibility of domestic terrorism
in the not too distant future as the
only response to what is going on
michael the first part was
coherent
and then the plug for the web page well
so um i'm not sure about the school
stuff
but in general i i guess i would just
repeat what i said that uh
you know evil happens in secrecy and so
there's a trade-off there and there are
some benefits to
there being
uh surveillance i guess in that sense i
i don't know i'm i wouldn't take the
conspiracies too far because for the
most part governments are incompetent at
using that
but i mean not 100 of the time i don't
know
you probably have a better oh i mean but
you you brought up the
you know
twitter and facebook's contribution to
the arab spring um but you might recall
that you know a few days into that uh
egypt
you know shut off the web so they called
the can do that the internet service
providers and you may think oh that
couldn't possibly happen here
but um there's legislation pending to
have a
a director of cyber security for the
united states who could slow down the
internet and homeland security has a
proposal to put digital tags where they
could then keep out you know whole other
countries from communicating with us or
if they didn't like what i was saying so
i think we have to be
vigilant that would be an argument
against no no i'm allowing that yeah no
so one of my my first right is the right
to connect because i agree that that's a
way to get things
you know uh done in a way and i and i do
i do agree that
we need
uh
you know a better educational system if
science is so key to everything here and
my heart breaks to see that there are
schools
in east l.a where the books are actually
stamped outdated
you know because you know things do
change uh and
and so i mean i think that's one of the
great things about supporting libraries
and books and so forth well yeah the
solution is better technology free free
internet access to all students
everywhere
instantly
i'm just going to disagree with the idea
that the taliban doesn't rely on
you know contemporary electronics
because they do
and muhammad atef was the first
taliban commander killed by the the u.s
military and the way they tracked him
was by his cell phone and it was also
interesting just to bring it around to
surveillance is he was actually the
first kill
in afghanistan by a drone although it
was reported for several years that it
was an air strike because back in 2002
no one in this room including me uh knew
that we had drones that were equipped
with missiles and we believed that the
general population believed at that
point that they were still just eyes in
the sky
yeah michael thanks for having such a
cool interesting and important magazine
first of all
and looking at subjects or issues in the
magazine has there ever been anything
that you looked at
paranormal or just interesting that
you couldn't really debunk and you
thought that was an intriguing that we
might not have heard about
lady gaga
no
no explanation for that
sorry i said this gentleman's question
uh yeah well there's a good question
that uh i mean there's an actual serious
answer that that is um
probably most of the stuff related to
altered states of consciousness or even
explaining consciousness there's so
little we know about that we know a lot
about the brain but so little compared
to what we still need to know i think
most of the great mysteries involving
that are still out there
uh what what you know the origins of the
universe
why should there be something instead of
nothing you know there's new books about
this now and so but we don't have
answers to that those kinds of questions
and there are a few of these conspiracy
theories that uh
they're not going to let uh
they're not going to let us into area 51
to you know with their cameras and stuff
to find out what's going on now but
maybe someday we'll know but there's so
certain things that are just kind of
remain
uh open so there's actually a skeptical
principle there the fact that i can't
explain it or we can't explain it
doesn't mean it's
in support of your pet theory i mean ufo
just means unidentified that's all it
means it just means i don't know what it
was at three in the morning in farmer
bob's field in pucker brush kansas i
don't know
and but the fact that i don't know
doesn't mean it's extraterrestrial it
just means we don't know and that's a
hard principle for people for any of us
to grasp because uh our brains are poor
a vacuum just like nature we got to fill
it with some answer and that's that's
where we get into trouble or i'll jump
in and say we do know what it was it was
a u2 spy plane but
no one can know that because that's a
secret platform so we'll just go along
with the theory
we being the cia that it's actually a
ufo in farmer bob's uh field because the
propaganda of that idea of black
propaganda works for itself you know let
the people think it's x because then
they won't know about why
yeah this gentleman yes uh i recently
saw
mr seymour hirsch
on television
speak about
area 51 where supposedly according to
him
the cia is training
an iranian
terrorist a terrorist group
i think
they called the rem
and and he said he has definitely
reliable sources about it
so
could you comment on it also
if you want to find out more about it he
wrote on a new yorker blog about it an
extensive article
and he says this obviously is against
united states law
i couldn't quite hear the question it
was that uh seymour hearst says seymour
says
and i saw him on television speak about
it extensively
that the cia
is training
a iranian
group
terrorist group
in terrorist
activities
in areas area 51.
i i'm going to definitely go home and
read the new yorker blog but i know blog
has it yes
i mean we have you know in the past
we've trained um
i mean i do know for a fact that we
trained uh vietnamese soldiers at area
51
um during the vietnam war uh soldiers
from south vietnam who would then go
take some of our equipment and put it on
the ho chi minh trail in north vietnam
so there's a precedent for having
foreign
folks come and train this is illegal
according to u.s law
terrorist group terrorist activity yeah
that that i don't i don't know about
it's definitely seymour hurst i think he
he must be right
well
he said he has pretty reliable sources
right let's go with this guy now this
one's for annie i loved your book i read
it cover to cover on my ipad now i'm
going to buy it and get to have you sign
it it's coming out in paperback next
week oh no i want the hardback
uh i'm a lockheed brat my dad worked at
groom lake on the a11 and the u2 in the
early 60s and uh
one question i had about from your book
though was from the roswell
craft i was michael's going to answer
that one for you okay
i was stunned when
i don't want to give away the best part
of the book but the language
the
acrylic alphabet found inside that craft
and then it was put away because of the
concern that
the american population would go nuts if
they learned the soviets could get that
far into the united states
with this type of technology can you
describe more this must have been a
rotor or something i mean this is a
still the disc type object i mean how
were they able to get that craft over
here to new mexico
well and you might just preface that
question by the answer to that question
by just
telling
about roswell and what it was area 51
has always been linked to the conspiracy
theory about roswell and in the last
seven pages of my book i write about
what a source
um told me that that actually is and how
the things link up
and uh as for the cyrillic writing you
know my source who who handled this
round-shaped disc um that was used as a
means of black propaganda the so that
the soviets had sent um that's how he
described it and that it was you know
the russian writing so
um but i always love hearing michael
talk about this topic because um this is
his area of expertise about you know
black propaganda and how it works
um we we differ a little bit on the idea
of
of how it actually has an effect on
american pop culture but michael what do
you have to say well so in the in the
late 1960s a ufo group uh sort of
summarized all the great cases of the
last half century the most important ufo
sightings
it was like the top 500 and roswell
wasn't even on the list roswell did not
become the roswell incident until 1980
uh when nbc made a you know made for
television movie about the roswell
incident and and so it's really
myth-making at its at its classic best
and then the eyewitnesses started coming
out going hey you know what i remembered
or i saw well we know how fallible human
memory is and all that's conflated with
the fact that project mogul which was
a military
top secret project to loft into the
upper atmosphere surveillance with using
balloons
made out of this you know tin foil and
balsa wood which is exactly what was
described you can see the photographs
right there in the living room of the
colonel that said he found it and so on
it was on the front page of the
newspaper exactly what it looks like
this project multiple these high
altitude balloons launched to monitor
soviet upper atmosphere nuclear
explosions with an acoustic signature
that this device would be able to record
and uh and it created in a crash that
that's all in farmer bob's field in this
case in roswell so uh so when the when
when the government said when it's okay
so what are we going to call it well
we'll say it was a weather balloon and
then later came out that this was not
true so do governments lie yes of course
they lie to their citizens we know this
but that doesn't mean extraterrestrial
or super-secret soviet whatever it just
means we don't know and it's more
plausible i think that in the middle of
the cold war we're not about to tell
everybody so that the russians can know
what we're doing by monitoring the upper
atmosphere because then they won't do it
so there's good reasons for national
security secrets
that's one of them and so that leads to
the lie the weather balloon and that
becomes the extraterrestrial and then
five decades later the eyewitnesses come
out uh to remember what they think they
saw
that's the short story according to the
skeptics
history um i'm gonna admit i'm a
journalism student from usc and i
started a ufo magazine so
i i apologize i actually put all my
career into it because i was one of the
naive and i
i'm gonna take whatever i deserve i'm no
longer i'm no longer part of it it still
exists so i can't speak to the
intelligence that it has but i wrote a
lot of stories that you're making fun of
and the people the people that i talked
to were really sincere something strange
happened to them they don't know what
but i interviewed tony lilly who talked
to dolphins and i interviewed quantum
physics people you mean john c lilly the
dolphin guy john his wife yeah he was
dead oh i'll get you um and the thing
that was
weird about
i did most of the business part not a
lot of interviews because i was trying
to start a publishing company but the
thing that was weird
about the things that i did
was that most of the people wanted to
keep quiet because they didn't want to
get made fun of so they were like well
only if you don't tell my research
friends only if you don't make it public
because i don't want to get
made fun of by my colleagues so
i'm a researcher but you can't tell
anybody
what i'm telling you you can quote me
but don't tell my name or else i will be
made fun of in my other field
and i thought that's not fair if there's
something that you're researching
the national enquirer should have the
jokes but i want to start a real serious
thing so let's nail down the questions
the question is do you think that there
should be able to have journalism happen
if you
are are there any stories that you think
deserve to be treated seriously even
though you're making absolutely what are
they i completely agree people have
genuine experiences that are anomalous
they can't explain it they're very
sincere in the reporting of it they're
trying their best to explain what it is
they saw or what happened in their
experience absolutely there's no
question about it experiences that
people have are very real the question
is are the experiences out there or in
here and so like the only difference
between me and the ufologist the serious
ones that really get down and study
every each and every claim they'll
they'll admit that 95 of every sighting
ever made is fully explicable it was a
planet venus it was a weather balloon it
was the stealth bomber whatever they
know this the only difference between me
and them is that other five percent the
anomalies the residue of anomalies in
science this is called the residue
problem no theory explains everything
there's always anomalies we can't
explain what do you do with them nothing
well you sign them to grad students
that's what they're for
where in society are they looked at i
mean everybody just laughs at it so it's
well not everybody laughs at it there's
quite a few actually i mean about about
a third of americans believe that ufos
represent extra cocktail party i go to
they they laugh lisa sherry what are you
doing with your career that is trash
well uh i can send you some other
parties you could go to where they
where where they really believe this
stuff
let's jump to this guy's question please
i'm just wondering if any of you have
heard of any
internet service provider
or operator finding a national security
letter
fighting it one
so one of the issues is that um
you know there is a a a way through a
national security letter to without a
warrant ask internet service providers
for information
about people and they can't even tell
the user you know if they were looking
at you
and
i'm not familiar with
any that have fought it i know
google does turn this over um
and so it's very different for me
because i come out of a sort of genetics
medical background and there are plenty
of times where you know hospitals or
doctors will fight for their patients
privacy rights when there's some other
thing going on government requests or a
lawsuit or whatever
but i haven't i'm not familiar with any
internet service providers who have
taken on
the national security letters
okay i've only heard of one um
which one
nick merrill
he's starting something called the calyx
institute he's got a campaign on right
now on uh
indiegogo for a non-profit
isp concentrated on
user privacy
and almost nothing else
yeah and i think chris sagoyan is also
working in this area and keeping track
because
he's there is an effort by the aclu to
at least get them to file it in courts
great thank you that's good to know
for many years there's been a
controversy for people
being very concerned about the
possibility that we're going to have a
national id
something much broader than your
driver's license but for all those years
people seem to forget the fact that we
all have
social security numbers which are
being asked for every day in many
different forms for example your health
insurance companies they have their own
private system that is totally dedicated
to tracking you and your medical history
through your social security number so
though we've focused in great part on
the high technology issues of the last x
amount of years
nobody i've heard has addressed anything
as some of the more low-tech things
especially your social security number
and how that's being abused and what we
can do to make sure that that is
something that doesn't impact us
personally
so has this stuff always been going on
through that
channel then lori well
so there's a recent lawsuit where
aeon consulting
one of their employees mistakenly put up
the social security numbers
gender and age
of all massachusetts retired state
employees 28 000 of them on a website
and uh
merely through that use of the social
security number then um
you could do identity theft
and so some known identity theft
websites from china actually
access those
and you know surprisingly the
the state
you know the people who sued
did not get relief because their
identities hadn't yet been stolen so i
think we you know we're seeing even low
tech things like social security numbers
be making us vulnerable and
no recourse until something really
horrible happens and i think some of
these things where
something private like that is
is made public
erroneously or negligently or
maliciously you know we should have a
privacy right in our social security
numbers so just one last question from
this gentleman here so what are your
thoughts on
supposed government or military hacking
like stuxnet and to what extent do we
see that or what's its prevalence in our
daily lives or yeah and so you know
there is a big concern about um
about cyber security and so
stocks nest was a a virus
in a nuclear plant in another country
not in the united states
but
it looks like it was actually
put there on a flash drive it didn't
come through the internet
uh but it it you know so
but because of that um
senator joseph lieberman is you know
introducing all these cyber security
provisions that actually could lead to
some problems with people being
erroneously cut off of the internet so
there's a real question about would the
government be better able to protect us
or would the internet service providers
and the googles of the world and many
people think that the internet service
providers comcast verizon whoever have
more of an incentive
and more of the people who actually have
the technological wherewithal to do so
and so some of the claims of the need
for a government
monitoring
to prevent you know malicious viruses as
a form of warfare
is is less than one would think annie do
you have a final thought about that i do
and it's a great question because i
often look at the relationship that the
cia has today with iran as being very
much a parallel is the relationship that
the cia used to have with the soviet
union
and it took a long time for any of us in
the civil sector to learn about the
stuxxmax virus which was fascinating to
me that you know it had happened and
then there was a delay in knowing about
it and there were rumors that it was you
know america mossad and russia and you
know all kinds of things and no one in
the government said anything about it
until recently and uh the former cia
director michael hayden went on i think
it was 60 minutes and gave an interview
about it so if anyone's interested in in
my opinion
in knowing what didn't happen just go
ahead and look at that interview and
look at it because there's no way that
the former director of the cia and he
was current when that happened would
tell you anything about what did happen
in fact i believe he would tell you the
exact opposite because really who he was
speaking to was not you and me but iran
um i think we have to wrap it up now and
thank you um laurie michael thank you
thank you thanks so much thank you
two hours left to go of our live
coverage of the afterwards airs on book
tv every saturday at 10 pm and sunday at
9 pm eastern you can watch all previous
afterwards programs on our website
booktv.org
and now on book tv
we're live with author and investigative
journalist annie jacobson
ms jacobson is the author of four books
including area 51 the pentagon's brain
and the newly released phenomena the
secret history of the u.s government's
investigations into extra sensory
perception and psychokinesis
annie jacobson live on in depth for the
next three hours starts now
jacobson let's start with some
definitions what is area 51
area 51 is that secret base out in
nevada where all kinds of mysterious
things happen
that you and i can talk about and maybe
we know what's going on out there maybe
we don't
why is it called area 51
big debate i believe it's called area 51
because of the original project that
went on out there in 1951.
information given to me by some of the
sources that i
interviewed at length for that
that book but of course everything about
area 51 is kind of a puzzle inside of a
puzzle so
that's even debated
the actual origins the original date the
origin story of area 51. so 1951 what
was going on
the atomic energy commission was doing
lots of nuclear testing out there in the
middle of the
desert and
they wanted to
you know keep what they were doing
secret and the cia was kind of coming
into existence with its programs and the
two merged in this idea of if you have a
secret base inside of a secret place you
can do secret programs so this was not a
military operation necessarily
well area 51 has every
organization you can imagine there over
the decades military intelligence
community atomic energy commission
so everybody has their foot in area 51 i
think
what is operation paperclip what was
operation paperclip
well
so i get the ideas of my books from the
books i've written before
and when i was finishing up area 51
i learned quite a bit about some nazi
scientists who were here working on
programs and i found this fascinating in
particular a fellow by the name of
siegfried nehemiah okay
now nehemiah was a very important
air force
technical intelligence person
and when he retired in the 70s he was
given the defense department's
distinguished civilian service award so
that's kind of this incredibly high
honor to get from the pentagon and when
i looked into his past i learned that
he had been her during the war during
world war ii he had been
one of the most important
uh technical intelligence officers for
hermann goring of the luftwaffe
and he was given the highest award that
you could be given there and i thought
how does this happen how do you work for
one side
and then work for the other side and
that is why i wrote operation paper kit
that was the springboard of that
of that journey into that you know
narrative story but what was operation
paperclip
it was to bring nazi scientists to the
u.s correct yes after the war we brought
as many as 1 600 nazi scientists
to create our weapons programs and
you know this is something that really
is brings up a lot of moral questions
and what i what i found most intriguing
about writing that book as a journalist
perhaps with all my books is
trying to maintain this neutral position
and
looking at both sides of the argument
because
you know many people will tell you paper
clip was imperative
we had to bring those nazi scientists to
the united states in order to beat back
the russians others will tell you
how could we have possibly brought these
you know nazis here some of them were
war criminals
there's you know dod weapons policy for
you in a nutshell i.e
extremely complicated and always
you know two sides of the argument
what is the pentagon's brain
the pentagon's brain uh book number
three for me um
okay so that idea came from paperclip
when my editor
i was finishing up with paperclip and
warner von braun is probably the most
famous
operation paper clip scientist um
created our rocket program and then you
know really responsible for the apollo
program in many regards
and he was a nazi scientist he had been
hitler's rocket builder um v2s yes yes
and my editor at little brown asked me
when i was finishing up paper clip
what it what what went on with von braun
in such and such a year and i looked
into it and found out that
this was in 1957 um
that this new agency was emerging at the
pentagon and it was called arpa the
advanced research projects agency we now
know it as darpa with a d for defense
but when they were beginning this
organization
uh you know the query was which who's
the best scientist in america to lead
this program to lead all of american you
know military technology in in blue
what's called blue sky research and they
chose von braun and they you know he he
was interviewed for the job but his
caveat to take the job was yes i'll take
it but
i i need to bring 12 of my colleagues
from the rocket program and they were
all former nazis so kind of that was the
dividing line for the pentagon they said
no
and they passed on von braun being
darpa's first director and
you know but the but the way that uh it
came about of calling it the pentagon's
brain was really realizing that the
defense department is looking at the
great minds
that's what they're concerned with they
want to know
who will lead us in technology of the
future what are some of the things that
have come out of darpa
i mean
you name it i mean the most famous is of
course the internet which was originally
called the arpanet
but technologies like gps
laser weapons um
you know
there's no end to what the pentagon
produces
uh you there there's reason to say that
artificial intelligence is a
darpa product um
biotechnology
so
there is the the idea that the pen
this is important to think about
darpa is the most powerful and most
productive
military science agency in the world
and so few people know about it that's
pretty much why i wrote the book in a
nutshell because it was like
how can this agency be so significant
kind of changing and shaping our world
if you will and yet
it's
it's you know
its public perception is close to zero
psychokinesis what is it annie jacobson
um
book number four for me that i have
uh that just published
last week is
the idea of well the book is called
phenomena and it's about the
government's investigations into extra
sensory perception
and psychokinesis
extra sensory perception
gaining knowledge through means other
than the five known senses
psychokinesis
the alleged ability to move matter with
the mind
these are very controversial subjects
and subjects that many scientists will
tell you is pseudoscience
why i was super interested in writing
about this was having come off of this
very hard science book the pentagon's
brain
on the other side of the spectrum was
what's sometimes called squishy science
but the
pentagon the defense department the
intelligence community they are
interested in both of these subjects and
so so am i
so
taxpayer dollars are spent studying
psychokinesis and esp
yes yes i mean this goes back by the way
look all roads leads back to the nazis i
find certainly when i'm investigating
and reporting on defense department
weapons programs and intelligence
community
intelligence collection programs
and esp psychokinesis this whole idea of
the phenomena
leads back to the nazis as well so the
we're talking decades of research in
this area still going on today but the
original programs came from the idea
that um after the war we had a
intelligence collection unit called
operation also it actually began you
know in the end when the war was still
going on
and we sent our sort of finest
scientists to try and capture
nazi technology and we did and this is
the link between all of my books
so
one of the cache of documents that we
found this links up to the book
phenomena is
was part of heinrich himmler's science
organization organization which was
called das ananerbe
and within that organization himmler was
investigating extrasensory perception
psychokinesis map dowsing
and when we got these documents they
became very
interesting to a lot of individuals in
the military intelligence community
particularly because guess who got the
other half of the documents the russians
so anything
that we knew they had as well
we were worried about who would win the
race and that is how the psychic arms
race really began same way
the you know over in the hard science
department you had the
the rocket uh arms race that idea of
getting man into space began with
captured nazi documents v2s and
scientists literally von braun
was your career arc to be a historian
talking about national security affairs
not at all i mean fate and circumstance
kind of intervene in one's own life
i think that's why it's such an
interesting
concept for me to write about about how
uh you know
circumstance has a role in
the path that one one is on i
wanted to be a novelist when i was
younger um
and i went away to boarding school with
a
typewriter when i was 15 and i was going
to be the great american novelist and
you know
decades passed and that was not the case
and i um one of my mentors said to me
stop making things up
pursue the truth it's the truth that
matters
um she also pointed out that i had a
little difficulty following direction
and that if i worked with an editor
at a newspaper
or a magazine i would you know
learn how to follow direction and that
was exactly what i did it was
extraordinarily helpful for me and i
tell anyone who's interested in you know
having struggling with writing to do
that because
if you have if you're willing to take
um criticism about your work and and
work with very smart individuals who can
help you
you know streamline your ideas and pull
out what's really important and send you
on other paths and suggest you interview
different people
that becomes
i think an
enormously powerful journey
when you bring other great minds into
the mix to kind of direct you
and then you kind of wind up where
you're headed at least that's my
experience well andy jacobson how did
you get started on area 51
well that was fate and circumstance
intervening i i i also think luck comes
into play you know and what was
interesting writing the book on
um
extrasensory perception and
psychokinesis is a lot of
a lot of the scientists who lean toward
let's say the supernatural
talk about luck and they talk about
coincidence and they say these are these
these fall into that category believe it
or not of extra sensory perception it's
kind of intuition it's a very squishy
science concept to think about but i
like thinking about it particularly
because of this question that you
brought up so
how does one get a lucky break okay
you could say fortune favors the
prepared mind
if you're always you know reading and
writing and thinking and working on
subjects that are of interest to you
then
circumstance intervenes and you are on
your way but specifically
with area 51 i was at a
a dinner party
with seated next to a gentleman named ed
lovick who i had known for
five six seven eight nine years he was
sort of a distant family member
always under the impression that he
was an aircraft designer because i knew
he worked for lockheed
and he leaned over to me one day and
this must have been 2007 or eight and he
said
boy have i got an interesting story for
you at the time i was reporting on
terrorism he said he read was reading
what i wrote and enjoyed reading it
so what was this interesting story you
know and he said the cia just
declassified
my life's work
i invented stealth technology or rather
i was the team that was sort of the
physicist that led the team
and this goes back to when eisenhower
was president and so as you can see this
is a remarkable lead for a reporter to
get i mean i went to the cia and of
course you know lo and behold they had
just declassified this
aircraft program called oxcart
that took place out at area 51.
and so in then i began to work with
luvek
talking to him about his role the
science and technology role in building
this incredible aircraft and i learned
very quickly aha there's a backstory to
this backstory and there's a lot of
tangents that are super interesting and
they're all going to fall on the axis of
area 51 and that's how i got that idea
for that book
when did the
larger public become aware of area 51
well that's a great question i mean and
it's it's very interesting in terms of
u.s national security because when you
think about what a powerful and potent
site area 51 is as i report in the book
the fact that it remained almost unknown
to the general population
until the early 1990s is astonishing i
mean talk about being able to keep a
secret
i mean i make the analogy in the book
about the manhattan project same idea
right even you know vice president harry
truman did not know about congress or
congress you know the ones funding the
program did not know about the program
so i think secret keeping is very
interesting i write about it in all of
my books but to your question
it wasn't until a
an individual named robert lazar you
know squeaked this bit of news out which
landed on the edge of conspiracy
um
and then area 51 became known um and i
think that is the origins of an
extraordinary amount of conspiracy
theory
that
grew out of that base and still exists
about that base and there's still things
going on there now who was robert lazar
well he was a an interesting let's say
engineer and he was out there at uh the
base according to him and he saw things
that he believed were he was working
there yes and um although people will
tell you he never worked there i mean
again you know the the the myths inside
the puzzles inside the conundrums
um
but he stood by his uh position that he
you know he said he saw an alien in
essence
um
and then you get into these as i was
reporting the story all these realms of
black propaganda and you know i mean did
they dress someone up and make them look
like an alien where they try i mean
this idea
of mythology and
you know
misinformation and disinformation is
part and parcel to area 51 and really to
all of the books that i have written the
subjects are conducive to that annie
jacobson you talk about you have to sign
an oath if you are working
at area 51 and by the way is it called
area 51 by people who
work there as well or is that just our
yes i mean yes and no i mean originally
when i was interviewing the scientists
who worked there and the spies and the
pilots and they would call it groom lake
they would call it the ranch there were
all kinds of code names for it
but and of course what's fascinating or
was to me while i was writing the book
is that the actual word area 51 the name
area 51 was classified when i was
writing the book it's since been
declassified because president obama
referred to it publicly
that's a quick way to declassify
something
but when i was looking at those
documents we were talking about earlier
the ox cart documents you would see read
be reading along and then there would be
a small word redacted like blacked over
and if you looked at it you know up to
the light or whether you could that's
area 51 and out of something like 7 000
pages of documents that i reviewed
i found two places where someone forgot
to black out area 51. so you would see
it there and it was an aha moment
robert lazar
las vegas television
what happened
well he went on tv and you know made
this claim on a local channel yes in las
vegas yes and said that there were you
know there was that there was alien
technology and that there was an alien
out there
and you know people have been fascinated
with ufos
and uh for millennium i mean that is
so this was like you know setting off a
match in dry grass i mean that people
went
um
you know the story built and it became
kind of a firestorm and i think that
that has since
become a great point of contention and
why area 51 is on such a lockdown issue
because people will not move off of that
idea that there are aliens out there
many people believe that and still do
what kind of cooperation did you get
from the various government agencies
that you worked with on this or tried to
work with
every book is different i mean every
book is different um
there's kind of a dance i think that's
done with journalists because
remember the just basic job of the
journalists is to inform the public
i mean
in spirit you're really not even
supposed to have an opinion
so one would think you would want to
work with
transparent elements of the government
to
also make things known but i find in my
experience that
current let's say like the pr office of
any of these agencies
they only want to present a certain
message
and that's not that's a message not a
fact let's say so
where i do most of my reporting is in
interviewing
scientists who are retired who worked on
very significant programs for these
individual agencies
and are acutely aware of what they can
speak of
and what they cannot because it's still
classified and because i also write
about a lot of cold war programs
um
things that were incredibly interesting
and and and you know involved
extraordinary classification measures
decades ago
everyone wanted to know about them then
but could not when they become
declassified sort of the public has
moved on and i find in my experience
that by tracking down these scientists
the superman of scientists if you will
um they are willing and and and
you know happy to share their stories
about these incredible programs because
people have lost interest and it's this
idea that you know it's important to
know
the past
to safeguard the future and that's the
greatest joy i think with working with
defense scientists
who are dedicated patriots who believe
in what they did but are also especially
as they get older willing to
share
uh
the pitfalls the the failures
and
the press office of any given
military or intelligence agency does not
want to talk about failure period they
only want to talk about success and i
think there's a danger in that i mean
that's a theme going through all of my
books it's not to you know ridicule a
success a failure but rather to
demonstrate
that failure is part of success but we
must be very careful
and you know about trying to cover up
failures how much of what goes on or did
go on at area 51 is still classified
i mean if i
or don't you know is it hard this is the
analogy i mean
you know it sometimes said i wrote the
book on area 51 but
if you imagine an iceberg
and you think of how much of the iceberg
you see and then how much is below the
surface
i mean i probably might i'm guessing but
i probably if you planted a flag at the
top of the iceberg that's probably
what i reported in a 450 page book
what has been what has gone on there and
what continues to gone on boggles the
mind i mean we could talk about you know
tunnel technology for three more hours
just when you think you have what's
going on
at area 51 there are a lot of tunnel
systems at that base
things that are going on there when will
those be declassified these are the
great mysteries you know i can't wait to
write area 52.
have you become a freedom of information
request expert
most definitely i mean my kids
i file so many foia requests that
sometimes you know
well they often come in the mail and
they're usually those eight by ten
envelopes and they say in the corner you
know nsa or dod or you know
cia and they're the thin envelopes
because that means you open up one sheet
of paper and it says request
non-responsive
meaning
sorry we couldn't find any information
every now and then you get a bigger
envelope and that's sort of a great
moment of joy i mean that's what
happened with phenomena i um
i came home one day and there was a
thick
manila packet
from the central intelligence agency
a foia request had been granted and
there were
you know almost a thousand pages of
documents
on these esp and psychokinesis programs
that became the basis of phenomena and
that was super interesting that's where
i learned about you know that the apollo
astronaut ed mitchell was doing esp
tests going to the moon i mean the
little details inside these documents
are just priceless it
well let's go to phenomena then annie
jacobson you visited
edgar mitchell and first of all tell us
who he was but you visited him in his
last months of life yes
the way i got the idea to write
phenomena sort of the spark was
researching pentagon's brain i was
looking at the apollo image library
because so much of darpa has to do with
space okay it's why it's it was the
launching point of the
of the organization and i found this
image
and it shows
an astronaut standing on the moon
reading
a document
and i thought
oh my god this this is an incredible
image you have
advanced science i mean space travel and
you know
proto-technology
writing
reading
in this one image and i had to know what
that astronaut was reading on the moon
first i found out that it was edgar
mitchell apollo 14.
sixth man to step on the moon yes so i
went to interview him at his home in
florida and i asked him
what were you reading on the moon and he
said
that he was reading a map
so i mean this is this gets even better
man on the moon reading a map of the
moon
why was he reading the map because he
was lost
and that to me is just a brilliant
beautiful concept you know it's so human
and it speaks to what we were just
talking about with failures right how do
you define failure
you have a program failure but then you
also have individual
failure and that often leads to people
being lost or feeling like they're lost
and because i write narrative nonfiction
and because it's character based i care
about the people i write about i want to
hear their story
and how it becomes a metaphor for the
bigger story and so with mitchell when
he told me the story of being lost on
the moon i was just you know it's
remarkable i mean the the brief version
i write it at length and phenomena but
what he said was
so part of the apollo 14 mission and of
course keep in mind apollo 14 comes
after apollo 13
right the failed moon mission there was
so much pressure on them to perform
and the geologists wanted them to go to
cone crater
and pull out samples rock samples and
believed that these rock samples could
perhaps reveal earth's origins
and the moon right how i mean what a
concept you can't have much more
pressure on you and so he and alan
shepard that was their mission so they
fly 240 000 miles to get to the moon
mitchell was the pilot on the antares
lander he lands within 87 feet of the
target
and then they get lost locally
trying to find cone crater
i mean it doesn't get more human um and
they had to you know when they when they
found out they were lost and of course
this speaks to many issues of
perspective you know where do you think
you are versus where are you really
in that airless environment they
they became confused and they told nasa
you can read all these transcripts um
we're lost we think we're here we're
there nasa's trying to help them the
heart rates are going up
they gave them nasa gave them 30 more
minutes
and they couldn't find their way to the
crater and they were told to go home
you know
and so
hearing from mitchell about this
disappointment of going all the way
there
and
missing what turned out
to be the target by about a thousand
feet
you know it's just amazing and he shared
with me how disappointed he felt
on the trip home from the moon
but looking out one of the five windows
on that spacecraft he had what he said
was an epiphany
he looked out
and to him
he realized that
man
was more than he previously thought so
he became fascinated in that moment with
the idea of consciousness with the idea
of man what is man capable of and that's
why i think my new book phenomena is
really about the reaches of what can be
known mitchell came home quit nassau
divorced his wife made all new friends
and began this trajectory into the world
of esp and psychokinesis he suffered
dearly because of it some say he got
lost
that's not what mitchell thinks why did
he suffer
he was ridiculed i mean he was ridiculed
you cannot pull up any article
on ed mitchell without
kind of a snickering journalist pointing
out that he conducted these esp
experiments on the way to and from the
moon and
you know he suffered because of it he
was his all of his colleagues were these
hard scientists he himself was he has a
phd from mit
um
but
he he
had what is called a conversion moment
again another important theme in the
book phenomena you have scientists
physicists individuals who have these
conversion moments when dealing with
extrasensory perception psychokinesis
and they become absolutely convinced of
the reality of the phenomena and they
pursue it you know some pursue it to the
gates of hell as i write in the book
and others maintain a very scientific
attitude toward it but because the
scientific skeptic community
insists that this is pseudoscience
because rightly so
psychokinesis extrasensory perception it
does not pass scientific method muster
the five
steps that every scientist agrees must
you know you must adhere to to move from
hypothesis to general theory the most
important being that it's repeatable
well esp experiments aren't repeatable
the the those you know pro this work say
it's fickle by nature and those against
it say that's hogwash
but i love this battle
there's a real
battle between
you know
science versus supernatural if you will
and again it speaks to this idea of
what are the far reaches of what man can
know
in phenomena uh annie jacobson you quote
some government documents though saying
we cannot not prove
that this is not real i mean in a sense
there's some doubt there
i i mean there's doubt absolutely
there's doubt everywhere but you know
the cia
concluded that the phenomena was real
but they couldn't repeat it but they
said it doesn't take away from the fact
that these real laboratory experiments
happened
but now what i found
most interesting in reporting phenomena
the book
was that
when i began researching and reporting i
was under the impression that the
programs were buttoned up in the mid
1990s with the kind of downfall this one
big defense department program
but i was astonished to learn that
they're actually
back today
under the rubric of advanced
cognition okay so the defense department
is now
merging this idea of the biological the
sixth sense the office of naval research
calls it the spidey sense
but instead of the parapsychologists of
the 70s and 80s now the defense
department is employing neurobiologists
computer technologists computer
engineers they are taking individuals
who have the spidey sense
it's just a dressed up word for esp
um and they're looking at their brains
and they're trying to model what's going
on their brains
and then of course to accelerate
accelerate it
and ultimately weaponize it because
that's the role of the defense
department
because of your research have you had a
conversion moment when it comes to those
topics no i mean but i will you know the
harvard experimental psychologist
gertrude schmeidler
back in the 50s created this system to
talk about
how individuals approach this
controversial subject matter and she
said on the one side there were goats
okay
goats were the scientific skeptics who
said this is nonsense this is hogwash
you know forget about all of it
sheep on the other hand were those who
were open to the idea of esp of
psychokinesis
and i would say i began as the neutral
journalist
but looking at
many of these experiences reporting
you know looking at documents
declassified documents and seeing what
the defense department thinks what the
cia thinks talking to the scientists
talking to the physicist talking to the
psychics i kind of
shifted a little bit toward
sheep like
i am open to the idea that it is unknown
that the you know the conclusions are
not yet in i really think that is
um
the idea of the far reaches of what can
be known
for me it's wiser to lean sheep to not
discount
not throw out the baby with the
bathwater if you will
are there aliens at area 51
let's go to it oh my goodness i mean
that's right that is that's what
everyone i mean
that's the first question you're always
asked doesn't it certainly when talking
about area 51 i mean
so
i interviewed you know 75 people for
area 51 all of whom had direct
access to that base
all of whom went on record
one source
remained anonymous with me
because he gave me
what was then what still is according to
him classified information
uh he was an atomic energy commission
scientist
and he told me this shocking story in
the end of the area 51 book
you know it takes up 12 pages at the end
of the book and it's what
you know garners
the most curiosity and what he told me
was that
there was a program out there that he
worked on which was a black propaganda
program
to
create creatures
that
looked like aliens
and it involved human experimentation
and he was very parsimonious with the
details
but he was very succinct
with going on the record about this and
you know i interviewed him for over a
hundred hours and by the way
stayed in contact with him after the
book published
and continued to have discussions with
him
and he sticks by that idea so
the read on area 51 as i tell the story
as he told it to me is they were not
aaron they were not aliens
this doesn't mean that there's not
extraordinary material that continues to
you know swirl around the cauldron about
why his information is incorrect
it's a big puzzle but i i
i really
appreciated his candor with me and i
stand by
everything that he
spoke of and that i reported in the book
and and he stood by it all the way to
his death
and welcome to book tv on cspan2 this is
our in-depth program we have one author
on talk about his or her body of work
and this month it's author annie
jacobson her books area 51 an uncensored
history of america's top secret military
base came out in 2011 operation
paperclip the secret intelligence
program that brought not see scientists
to america came out in 2014 the
pentagon's brain an uncensored history
of darpa america's top secret military
research agency came out in 2015 and her
most recent book is phenomena the secret
history of the us government's
investigation into extra sensory
perception and psychokinesis just out
this year she'll be our guest for the
next two and a half hours and if you
have questions or comments you'd like to
make with annie jacobson here's the way
you can contact us you can dial in on
the telephone 202 is the area code
748-8200 for those of you in the east
and central time zones
748-8201 if you live in the mountain and
pacific time zones now if you can't get
through on the phone lines still want to
make a comment try social media at book
tv is our twitter handle you can also
make a comment on our facebook page
facebook.com
booktv you'll see her picture there you
can make a comment right underneath
there and you can also send us an email
at booktv
cspan.org and we'll begin taking your
calls in just a few minutes
annie jacobson were you able to get any
dollar figures on how much is spent at
area 51 how much is spent on researching
psychokinesis
what did operation paper clip cost and
darpa what's their budget
all of the programs i write about almost
all of them are what are called special
access programs sap programs they exist
in these
very secret classification protocols
that are far above normal classified
proto calls so
it is almost impossible to accurately
say
what the budgets are um the the one of
the budgets i can give you is that the
darpa budget that's public
so darpa spends 3 billion a year
and that is the case
that's basically been the same figure if
you adjust it for inflation going back
to darpa's origin in 1958. it's an
extraordinary amount of money for 120
program managers
but that's only the public figure so
all of the programs are dealing with
black budgets
which means that the money is
essentially unknowable
on that uh subject i'll give you one
fascinating detail that i find that
maybe stands as the best analogy for all
of this so
in area 51 the one of the kind of
creators of area 51 if you will was
richard bissell he was with he was
deputy director of the cia
and the way in which he became involved
in area 51 if you back up a couple years
he got a call from alan dulles at cia
saying hey listen bissell at the time
bissell was in charge of the marshall
fund okay that was the plan to rebuild
europe after world war ii an
extraordinary amount of money bissell
was in charge of it and dulles said
and i'm paraphrasing but this is the
essence can you skim some of that money
off of the marshall fund and give it to
us for a secret program
bissell said are you sure again
paraphrasing you sure i should do this
yes bissell did it
and years later he found out when he was
made sort of the director of the area 51
project
remember that money you gave us
here's what it went to this is how area
51 was set up so these things are and
interestingly bissell talks about that
in his memoir so you can find
information i as a reporter find
information in a whole array of places
from memoirs to you know papers that are
stored at different archives individuals
journals sometimes the family gives me
access to them foyer requests interviews
this is the joy of being a journalist
you have many different sources you're
pulling from to try and piece
together the story for the reader as
best you can
somebody who plays a part in several of
your books edward teller
i mean almost all of them you know i
begin the pentagon's brain with this
talk about a colossal failure i mean and
again others will say this was a
colossal win so the castle bravo bomb um
i mean this was a
thermonuclear weapon edward teller the
father of the hydrogen bomb
and it's you know
the average person thinks oh atomic
weaponry thermonuclear bomb same same
cookie sheet well perhaps except for in
orders of magnitude i mean
thermonuclear weapons can t one
thermonuclear weapon could take out the
eastern seaboard there was one thermo
nuclear weapon exploded in castle bravo
uh the castle bravo bomb out in the
marshall islands i begin the pentagon's
brain with it
you know from the perspective of
witnesses who were there who told me
their story when i say colossal failure
it was supposed to be six and a half
megatons
but it went out of control i mean
teller's calculation and all the
scientists working with him they
couldn't you know predict the future
they couldn't predict their own science
experiment and instead it was a runaway
thermonuclear bomb
15 megatons i mean just an astonishing
amount of power energy and apocalyptic
by its very nature
well he he shows up in area 51 and he
shows up again in pentagon's brain and
operation paperclip the whole the whole
gamut
i i mean he's he's a super interesting
character i mean many people again would
say he had hubris and that he was trying
to outdo his arch rival oppenheimer
right
um other people will say he saved us
from
you know
soviet invasion because
you know
the he pushed the idea of the
development of the thermonuclear bomb
which some of his colleagues by the way
called the evil thing okay they did not
think these are manhattan project
scientists they did not think it should
be
developed because it could end the world
teller pushed for it and ultimately won
and he was also involved with sdi
yes i mean he gets pulled into the
program um during the reagan
administration i mean he and again i've
interviewed people who swear by his
benefit beneficence and when i say that
i mean because the castle bravo bomb um
which was a secret program no one even
knew it went on at the time you know we
we found out later that the russians
were only you know literally months
behind us in the development of their
thermonuclear weapon and in this idea of
the battle of the superpowers a theme
through all of the books you know
the us government
must stay ahead and what's interesting
is it does stay ahead so to give credit
where credit is due and when i was
interviewing darpa scientists who said
when we got into the realm of you know
cloning let's say i mean you've got
thermonuclear weapons as part of the
origin story and today you have you know
autonomous weapons artificial
intelligence biotechnology
biohybrids human cyborgs this is all
darpa science science and the darpa
scientists would say to me when i would
ask questions like is this wise they
would say
well
what if you were to wake up in tomorrow
morning and find out that the chinese or
the russians or even a dark horse like
saudi arabia presented the world with
the first clone human clone you know
would americans say my god we've been
beaten
by
an enemy nation um that's why darpa
exists that's why these weapons program
exists why area 51 exists it's why paper
clip existed
we must stay ahead
of the rest of the world so that we are
not beaten by technological surprise and
so far we have 28 billion dollars is the
figure you cite for the development of
the nuclear bomb
in your book 200 000 employees
kept secret from congress
oak ridge tennessee took more power than
new york city more electrical power
i mean i use that as an example whenever
anyone says oh come on you can't really
believe the government can keep secrets
they're not capable of doing that you
know it's a conspiracy to think
otherwise well i cite exactly that i
mean of course the government can and
does keep secrets
and then the other side of the argument
is it needs to
somebody lost to history but plays a
role in the early development of some of
this is vanivar bush
who was he
well he was the scientific director of
the manhattan project and also of sort
of
so we're going back in time now to the
years
right before america entered world war
ii
and there was an extraordinary sense of
isolationism in america you know we
didn't want to enter the war and didn't
feel that we
that we needed to or should
but at the same time the president
needed to
make sure that we were keeping up
with the science and technological
advances that we knew
the nazis were making thanks to people
like
einstein who had already come here you
know
so you have secret science that's really
where i think secret science began
with vanivar bush and with these
pre-war
technologies
america was hedging her bets rightly so
because you know you can't start your uh
atomic weapons program
um when the nazis are working on their
triggering system
annie jacobson is our guest
let's hear from cj in marietta georgia
hi cj
good afternoon actually
um i have recently uh been interfacing
with a gentleman actually that worked
for oakwood national laboratory for over
40 years
he contacted me because he also knew i
worked for one of the largest defense
contractors what's interesting is the
manhattan project that you actually are
speaking of and he went in great lengths
about
sharing with me that he just thought my
personality was outgoing enough where he
wanted to find some of the
children or grandchildren or some of the
scientists actually african-american
scientists be specific
that actually worked on the manhattan
project and i
over the course of the christmas holiday
for about three weeks
i contacted
various agencies paternity organizations
and was able to find
five
children of some of the individuals that
worked on the manhattan project and it
was very interesting one of the guys who
is a doctor in washington d.c now uh
said that his father kept journals and
we're going to be meeting with him here
in the atlanta metro area in the next
few weeks
about those various things but what was
very interesting
the gentleman said is his father never
talked about his work
and that you know he would be gone for
months years at a time and
as you indicated the secrecy there were
over 200 000 employees that actually
worked on the manhattan project
and was in oak ridge national uh you
know oak ridge tennessee where actually
i was reared and i never even knew about
it
until i met this gentleman um mr mentor
actually who had worked for them for
many years and so the secrecy that
actually exists both with the the area
51 project you know oakwood national
laboratory in others across the united
states
is so mind-boggling to me
uh it just
it you know we're here you know years
later finding out about all these secret
projects and things that happen but it's
a lot of that and we will never know
about it unless there were journalists
like your stephanie that actually bring
these things up that what's going on and
oftentimes we're not aware of why the
united states are going into debt
because of these type of projects thank
you cj thank you
any comment for her i mean it's it you
know you've touched upon a very
important theme for
this not only the individuals who work
on their programs but their families and
it's why i love tracking down and
interviewing the children
um if the if the parents have passed the
scientists because you can kind of get a
sense of that secrecy the children knew
nothing in many cases and also the wives
knew nothing but a lot of times they
have um and will share you know father's
papers that are stored in the attic and
so that becomes this idea of legacy i
think is very interesting and i
particularly found that when i worked on
paperclip and i went to germany and
interviewed the children of some of
these major nazis who worked for hitler
and then later worked for
the department of defense what was your
reception like
in germany you know what it was either
black or white i mean and that really
was astonishing it was either no i don't
want to talk to you father didn't do
anything wrong
um
never mind he was a convicted war
criminal
uh i'm speaking specifically about
a convicted war criminal named otto
ambrose who was
hitler's chemical weapons developer and
he was convicted of as i write in in
paperclip he was convicted of mass
murder
slavery
genocide sent to landsberg prison after
the nuremberg trials and then was
released by our u.s high commissioner
john mccloy
um and what went back into the world and
then consulted for the atomic energy
commission i mean
when i tried to track when i did track
down his son and tried to interview him
he said my father did nothing wrong he
was acquitted
um
on the other hand i interviewed
other children of major nazis who had a
very different
take and were very thoughtful and
remorseful and courageous
in sharing with me the profound
difficulty of you know that legacy that
they must live with i mean on the one
hand the son cannot be judged by the
father
but psychologically it's an
extraordinary burden to bear so
interviewing
people who are that forthcoming with me
about
you know
the complications of that legacy
i mean i feel like that undergirds the
book
with
significance that's deeply emotional
sixteen hundred nazi scientists or so
came over via operation paper clip
how deep did their tentacles go here in
this country
i mean they were in every weapons
program that
we were financing there was a
a top nazi i mean that's a gross
generalization but
i think it is also very accurate
certainly from my reporting i mean in my
book i focus on 21
of the nazis who i found to be extreme
cases extreme meaning
they during the war they worked directly
with hitler
himmler
um you know spear
and so
when you when you think about that then
they were working for us with us
um that's real drama in there so i
looked at 21 but there are 1600 and just
from looking at those big files and and
sort of mapping out where everyone went
yes they were in every one of our
weapons program and i think i read that
one of those nazi scientists was the
first director of the kennedy space
center
kurt debuss
um you know they still give out the kurt
davis award just kind of the most
innovative thinker in this
world and i i was shocked to find out
this because of the the documents that i
was able to get from a freedom of
information act
indicate that
deb debuss was a hard core nazi i mean
he even wore the ss uniform to work in
nazi germany he turned in a colleague
ratted out a colleague
for saying mean things about his hitler
literally and this guy got picked up by
the gestapo and you know we're giving
him an award i mean this kind of thing
is astonishing i called up the head of
the
of the of the organization that gives
that award and you know he's very
defensive and he said
debus was a great innovator and he you
know brought did all these things for
the apollo program and i said
but what do you say to the person who
says to you he was a nazi
and his response was very interesting he
said
no one's ever asked me that question
before
so we have journalism
to present the facts and let people
decide what they think about those facts
was it known contemporarily that he was
a former nazi and now he's running the
kennedy space center or
a lot of these guys was that known very
important question absolutely not and
from the declassified documents
i learned that
not only
did nasa know
about their past but they were complicit
in making sure
that this did not get out this was a
this was a kind of a quote from one of
the von braun documents because von
braun because he was so high-profile
warner von braun yes he was always being
kind of pulled into it by journalists
who would ask him questions about his
nazi pass he was told by nasa to say
if you're asked your answer should be
i've been thoroughly investigated by the
u.s military
and he had been thoroughly investigated
they just didn't reveal what the
investigation had found
so you were able to make some inroads in
germany have you been to darpa's
headquarters here in the washington area
have you actually set foot in area 51
i have not been to darpa's headquarters
they're very secretive about letting
anybody in there
i mean they
like to present
the idea that they are a beneficent
organization
and you know they do do some great
things we have the internet
the results of a lot of their work
have profoundly impacted society and
made it easier for a lot of people but
let's face it darpa's
job
as was indicated in its early mandate
you know in 1958 is to create vast
weapon systems of the future so darpa is
very you know
secretive about um
letting anyone in and and seeing what's
really going on
um area 51
no journalist has ever been there
including me
i was taken by a group of
former manhattan project scientists when
they were still alive
to the nevad what was then called the
nevada test site which is you know all
the other areas areas 1 2 10 15 20 that
align with area 51 area 51 sort of over
the hill and you're on ticaboo peak
yes and well no i was actually in the
test site which is where all the bomb
craters are and you're kind of driving
through the desert and you see where you
know
an old safe was blown up like a big
giant bank safe to try these were parts
of the test to see
what would survive a small nuclear blast
train tracks you know the rubble that's
out there in the desert uh is remarkable
the area is all you know concealed
so i went there and i kind of saw area
51 5 miles away but that's the closest i
got to
travis is calling in from eureka
california hi travis you're on with
author annie jacobson
hello good afternoon
i'm interested in
remote viewing and
what um if any evidence that
you researched did you find to be
the most convincing
uh in favor of it being you know a fact
so thanks for the question remote
viewing for those who might not know um
is another word for extrasensory
perception and it was a term created by
the cia
uh in the 1970s to destigmatize
the concept of esp the concept of
psychics of psychic functioning
it became part and parcel to all of the
programs that went on for the next 25
years
across the cia
across the department of defense over at
dia which is the defense intelligence
agency
um and as i write in the book phenomena
there's there are extraordinary success
stories of remote viewing locating
hostages locating downed aircraft
there are also colossal failures
and again i tell both of those stories
in the book and i let you decide but
when you look at the facts of what some
of these psychics were able to
accomplish were able to see
to know the unknowable
with a cia or defense department handler
sitting with them inside of what was
usually a faraday cage an electronically
shielded room so there's no way they
could be getting information
uh any other way other than this
mysterious
sixth sense which no one has been able
to explain so i would say the remote
viewing success stories
exist
and i write about them in the book
the pentagon's brain was a finalist for
the pulitzer
and this email comes in from chris
in houston texas
and he or she asks how does darpa search
make its way from being purely military
to something a company can sell to the
public at large
great question so let's talk about gps
okay
i mean satellite technology
interestingly finds some of its origins
at area 51. uh richard bissell who we
talked about earlier the the sort of
mayor of area 51 along with uh dr bud
weilon
who i interviewed for the book they were
working early satellite technology as
they were running these airplane
technology programs they were also
experimenting with satellites hoped it
would work i mean think about that as a
concept in terms of innovation our whole
military runs you know with the
satellite system being at the center but
in the 50s and 60s these ideas were just
coming online and there was a mandate
over at the defense department to
you know create what we now know as gps
through satellite technology and it took
decades to really come to fruition
but when darpa finally was able to make
these systems work and this is kind of
at the end of the vietnam war
this was an import it was a military
targeting technology gps that you have
in your smartphone okay and it was kept
secret um it had an offset by a couple
hundred feet so if anyone hacked into
our system they wouldn't be able to
target you know their bombs would be off
in essence
and it was kept secret all the way
through the 90s and during the clinton
administration
word came down that a european civilian
organization was going to
develop gps for the consumer and that is
why the clinton administration
declassified gps technology because we
wanted america to be able to be the
innovators and the primary drivers of
that in the commercial world and that's
exactly what you see
al st petersburg florida good afternoon
al your own book tv
good afternoon folks
miss jacobson
in your book phenomenon do you mention a
person named ingo swan
i sure do they called ingo swan
the original super psychic and he played
a very significant role
in the early years of the cia program
and also
in the years of the defense department
program so there's quite a bit you can
read about um in phenomena about swan he
was a very charismatic person and a
fascinating character al why do you ask
about him
i hung out with him in california in 69
when i was a scientologist
and he
oh doesn't that's one of my questions
was anybody in scientology taken
seriously in the phenomenon program
and ingo swann had contempt for the
people who reached ot3 and other levels
he says hell i can do what cost you thou
hundreds of thousands of dollars you
know with my hands tied behind my back
the other thing um there's two other
things i'd like to mention to you that
might be interested in and maybe some
other time not on this program i could
contact you if you're interested
but there is a study in the university
of virginia
done about 30 years ago
that has
really that scientifically
proves things that
that tie in with what you're doing
it would be an extended conversation i
don't know if you want to have it now
well probably we don't have time now
alba we appreciate your calling in i
think you do have a website we'll put
that up on the on the screen if you wish
to contact annie jacobson go ahead
the scientology question is very
interesting of course the intelligence
community and the defense department
were extremely anti-scientologists
but you're absolutely correct that ingo
swann and others in the program had been
involved in scientology
and it becomes a great point of
contention and it also is there are some
mysteries that remain and i think the
biggest mysteries that remain surround
a psychic that worked at the same time
as ingo swann for the cia and his name
was pat price
and pat price sort of um he outperfo
performed ingo swan in the psychic realm
if you will because whereas swan was it
was incredibly gifted at describing you
know using his esp talents if you will
to describe situations narratively uh
colorfully
pat price could pull actual names
numbers figures off of documents in
classified facilities thousands of miles
away and he was so good at this that a
number of
security investigations high level
investigations came down on him because
people could not possibly fathom how he
could know what he did he died in 1975
under very mysterious circumstances many
conspiracies have arisen about what he
died one of them is that the church of
scientology killed him
annie jacobson do conspiracy theorists
come to your book events
oh yes i mean i i did this great event
with the one of the scientific skeptics
named uh professor michael shermer at
caltech and this was for the area 51
book and he filled this auditorium i
mean it must have sat 400 people
and because it's in pasadena right near
jpl the jet propulsion laboratory um
it was sort of like half of the people
in the room were these big brains from
jpl and the other half were conspiracy
theorists and you know we had this
lively
raucous uh debate
um
not just me asking questions but then
the question started going back and
forth and sometimes they weren't
questioned sometimes they were like
shouting at one another but i think
these are all important readers to have
because
i find that
conspiracy theories often have roots in
truth and i write about this in every
one of my books where you have an
alleged conspiracy theory which is
actually you know part of a black
propaganda campaign or a disinformation
campaign and again i'm able to unearth
these documents uh have them
declassified and demonstrate that things
are not always exactly as they seem
would any of your four books exist were
it not for the cold war in russia
no no no they're all a product of
that
race the arms race between the united
states and the soviet union and often
china comes in
pardon me george email
i believe bob lazar said that element
115 was the power source for the alien
technology that he was trying to reverse
engineer
since then element 115 has been
synthesized and is apparently not
possibly a credible power source
any
comment a little too inside baseball for
me i interviewed lazar for the book area
51 i write about my interview with him
um but what i think the caller or the
the individual is speaking to the fact
that
these ideas these mysteries some would
call them conspiracies these are not
going away people continue to be
interested because they feel that their
questions have not been answered and
that of course speaks to this idea that
we've been talking about uh about you
know transparency government
transparency what can be known what
should be known why do we have to wait
decades to have these documents
declassified you also write about janet
airlines what is that janet airlines is
the the private airlines that flies
from las vegas to area 51 it has its own
conspiracies within conspiracies
i mean i had someone contact me just
recently and say you know give me the
janet airline schedules and they stop
flying during the day apparently and
they only fly at night i mean again
these these mysteries and conspiracies
fold within one another and they don't
want to end why are they called janet
airlines and you describe the interior
and landing what it's like there have
you been on janet airlines no i have not
been on john
you have to be invited like you know
many places uh certainly area 51 you
have to be invited out there
but but what is interesting is in all of
my books it
researching you know the superman of or
interviewing the superman of science
lo and behold almost everybody says oh
by the way i read your area 51 book and
i was out there and then they tell me
the little program that they were on um
dale graf one of the leading scientists
in my new book phenomena he was out at
area 51. i said dale that's incredible
tell me you know what were you doing out
there i can't tell you
let's hear from joel in eagle idaho hi
joel
hi peter hey great program
my father was a b-29 pilot over in
tinian where the enola gay took off
he never talked much about it but
he ended up at bell aircraft in niagara
falls new york
now there was a program there icbm
program
and
i can remember a picture of him and
warner von braun
uh eventually bell got into the x1 and
x2 programs
but
you never heard i never heard much about
whatever happened to von braun
after he was at bell bell was
the bell helicopter plant of course
but
what can you tell me about warner von
braun and where he ended up and what he
ended up doing thank you sir
it's a great question and there's
another uh
former nazi general
operation paper clip scientist who wound
up at bell
and that was walter dornberger and i
write about him in operation paperclip
as well so von braun had an interesting
trajectory i mean he worked all the way
through
uh the apollo program and then
retired and went into
um private enterprise and then he was
stricken with cancer and died um
but you know von braun comes up in every
one of my books there's a fascinating
story uh where he loops in with the
in the in the book that i've just
written phenomena
with uri geller um of all people who you
know was a cia asset
and who got the had the defense
department very concerned with
psychokinesis so
spoon bending what geller does and many
people tell you that he's a magician
the dod did not think so the cia did not
think so
and they were concerned that what geller
could do with psychokinesis
was
think of the delicate electronic system
in an icbm
they were concerned if geller could bend
a spoon with the tip of his finger that
using his mind he could do the same he
could disrupt
the electronic system and so
when he came to the united states he met
with warner von braun
and uh there's a photograph i have of
the two of them in phenomena but von
braun
was fascinated with geller geller got
von braun's watch to stop and he made
this statement like i have no scientific
explanation for how he did this and
geller got an old
desk calculator that von braun had that
was that had stopped working
geller got it to start working just by
touching it and you know this mystified
von braun and because he was such a
powerful figure in the science community
it raised a lot of eyebrows that von
braun
was uh you know taken with geller
uh we had on this program a year or two
back uh jonathan ronson john ronson who
uh
the men who stare at goats
does that tie into some of the things
that you write about in phenomena it it
does i mean that's the remote viewing
program and one of the things that i
demonstrate you know
over time happened with the phenomena
program was that the cia was under the
impression
that this talent okay which was still in
the hypothesis stage this you know let's
call it enhanced intuition or enhanced
perception the cia doctors
believed that it's biological that it's
individualistic that
use the mozart analogy think of how i
know i cannot sing in the shower and
then you listen to mozart's amazing
music
and you know wow that's different that's
biology okay
um
that's the metaphor that the cia used
because they believed that individual
people ingo swan pat price uri geller
had some kind of extraordinary gift
uh that the rest of us didn't
the defense department took a different
approach they believed that
soldiers could be trained to become
psychic
and grave problems arose
because the cia advised against this
the defense department pursued it
and it led to a lot of program a lot of
problems within these programs because
in many cases you had soldiers
you know trying to be psychic
and having very little success and at
the same time you had
individual people who were actually
psychic if you will
working on these programs and having
success and it created a catch-22
because
the defense department didn't want to
believe that people were psychic because
it flew in the face of science
a lot of corporations are involved in a
lot of your books and a lot of this work
the rand corporation raytheon vanver
bush i believe was the founder of the
raytheon corporation um
a lot of money to be made on these
projects
you know this is a very
important subject um defense contracting
um it speaks to what eisenhower said on
his farewell speech about the
military-industrial complex
and the warning area that i saw
was when i was reporting the pentagon's
brain
and i learned that the jason scientists
okay so now if you want to talk
conspiracy i mean the jason scientists
come up in everybody's
in all the world of conspiracy who are
the jasons so they are allegedly this
you know before i interviewed a lot of
the jasons
uh
one idea is that they're kind of the
illuminati of the defense science world
so i interviewed marvin goldberger who
everyone calls murph
right before he died who was the founder
of the jasons and worked on many of
these darpa projects
uh
for decades and the jason scientists
what i found to be most interesting was
they were full-time professors
you know at the great universities
across america
and part-time defense scientists so they
would get together
in the summers
and solve for darpa whatever conundrums
darpa was facing
they were called the supermen of science
and what i learned
in the recent era in the modern era is
there has been a shift and the defense
department darpa in particular has kind
of moved the jason scientists to the
side they still consult but they're not
as important i was told and what is
important now in terms of
setting
you know setting policy and making
decisions about what science projects
will be pursued in the future is an
organization inside the pentagon called
the defense science board the dsb
and
as i write very specifically in the
pentagon's brain if you look
at the individuals who are on the
defense science board they are almost
all
full-time defense contractors
they are not part-time defense
scientists and so what you have is
what eisenhower warned us against which
is the very people who are deciding
which weapon systems which vast weapon
systems of the future the pentagon will
pursue
are the same individuals who stand to
make an extraordinary amount of money on
those weapon systems who runs darpa
today do you know darpa is directorless
at the moment
but darpa is really managed by these
120 program managers
as we said earlier 3 billion dollars
in the hands of 120 program managers
they have extraordinary power to stop
and start programs they look outside of
the military establishment as well and
work with universities in research labs
so profoundly innovative i mean this is
the true definition of blue sky research
darpa leads the question is you know do
we like where they're leading us and the
answer is you don't have a need to know
about that because most of the really
intense programs that darpa is working
on artificial intelligence autonomous
weapons these are classified programs
jake in west hollywood california thanks
for holding you're on with author annie
jacobson
hi thanks for taking my call i was just
wondering
you're talking about money now is there
any mechanism by which
the united states gets money from the
companies that use darpa's
innovations
because i know uh if you read the
biography of steve jobs or uh
bill gates or any of these people they
always have a stop off at darpa
i know uh darkly developed the screen
for the uh smartphone things like that
so are we making deals where we get paid
for that stuff thank you
well the way the money flows from darpa
is it flows out of darpa into the
hands of the
laboratories that are developing um
the weapons programs so yes
you know if if apple has a product
that darpa wants to develop they would
be paid does that answer the question
he is he is gone
so let's hope that that does answer the
question i think he's looking for is
there a return on this investment in a
sense
well i would say the return on the
investment happens in the civilian
sector i mean if you make a product if
you
if you
let me maybe give a better example so i
interviewed for the pentagon's brain
some scientists who are working down at
um
uc irvine on limb regeneration okay
this is the idea think of the salamander
loses its tail it grows back okay
these scientists believe that humans
will one day be capable of regenerating
their own limbs extraordinarily
interesting to darpa in terms of you
know
you know wounded warriors um
but this kind of research is
20
30 years out
what the scientists at irvine told me is
who's going to fund that
no one except for darpa so
darpa is willing to invest in
very early laboratory research
that leads to extraordinary new things
the scientists that i'm that i spoke to
and that i write about in the book
working on this program we're very
grateful for this funding from darpa
because it allows them to continue their
research and to seek grants elsewhere so
there is a give and take in this world
that has to do with money coming in and
new programs going out
one of the characters in the pentagon's
brain michael goldblatt
who is he
well goldblatt was the individual who
really took
biological science uh to a new level
okay so back up for a minute researching
the pentagon's brain i was fascinated by
the idea that
the hard science of those days missile
technology weapon you know
did not involve
uh biological scientists so
that happened ironically when the wall
came down
and you had soviet biological weapons
engineers defecting to the united states
and bringing with them
the big reveal that the soviets were
breaking the
biological weapons treaty and developing
these horrific
weapons um you know mixing things like
ebola and influenza okay to create
apocalyptic results so
when these scientists arrived
and began working for darpa
it led to this idea of we need to look
inside the body we need to look at human
biology
and that's where goldblatt enters the
scene because about that same time
computer were now kind of in the in the
in the 90s okay the early 90s and
computers are now computer technology is
getting small so we're moving toward
nanotechnology and the defense
department now becomes very interested
in the idea of human physiology
what
individual soldiers are capable of how
you can enhance that and how you can
ultimately create a super soldier and um
you know goldblatt led the way all the
way through the late 90s and early 2000s
and there was a lot of kickback from
this from the public one of the programs
i think that that
sums this up with something called the
robo-rat okay so the idea was ultimately
to be able to
put computer technology inside humans
and an early prototype was the rat so
they wired up this rat and they were
able to con with a chip in his brain
darpa scientists were able to steer the
rat through a maze
well people cried foul and said you know
this is right at the edge of ethics and
you cannot be doing this kind of thing
it's only going to lead in a bad
direction
and so the programs were somewhat
curtailed well then 9 11 happened and
there was an extraordinary amount of
funding and now these darpa programs
today that i write about at length in
the pentagon's brain involve you know
pushing
the biology of humans in another
direction and ultimately merging
man and machine to create what used to
be relegated to science fiction and that
is the human cyborg
michael goldblatt began his career at
mcdonald's
he did he did i mean and he was
recruited by darpa it's a it's a pretty
interesting story about how you know um
he he developed a system that dealt with
a sterilization technology
for mcdonald's on the wake of a
one of those bacteria scandals that you
know really put the fast food
restaurants um
in in a lot of trouble and so this
sterilization technology he thought
there has to be a military application
for this and darpa agreed with him and
he ended up becoming a very
powerful player there
kathleen's calling from los angeles hi
kathleen hi hello
uh i just wanted to speak about ions i'm
the co-chair the co-chair of the la ions
group which is the organization that
edgar mitchell started
to marry science and spirituality
physics and metaphysics but i just had
to comment
on growing limbs because as an
acupuncturist i have i have a youtube
video of me fixing a paralyzed dog and
six treatments with my electromagnetic
field stimulator
but i wanted to comment on on edgar
mitchell
in his last two years we skyped him into
the ions convention in chicago as well
as the contact in the desert conference
here in joshua tree
where he spoke about
his career and being on the other side
of the moon seeing how craters had no
lava because it all went towards our
side but i i was able to talk to him on
the phone and asked him about
the evidence that
armstrong and his colleagues had run
into
aliens when they were going coming back
from the moon and when they were on the
moon and they reported this on their
private line to their doctor not to the
public line that we would hear about and
then this was picked up by shortwave
radio people that they were reporting
that they were you know there were there
were people around them they were you
know aliens they were with them on the
moon and i asked him if he'd ever had
that experience or if he had heard that
from armstrong and he declined at that
time so i don't know whether uh he has
things he didn't want to share
but i just thought that
it's such a wonderful organization that
he started and we would love to have you
come and speak at one of our monthly
meetings because right now our main
project is is fukushima the extinction
level event
and why it's being ignored and we have a
former nasa scientist who has a remedy
for it
but it needs billions of dollars after
six years and so
uh you know why are these things ignored
and um
i don't know it's just very
kathleen what is the ion society
uh the institute of noetic sciences
which was started by edgar mitchell
after that epiphany
and uh they do a lot of research as i'm
sure annie can elaborate on uh you know
up they have a campus up in marin and
they do a lot of psychokinetic research
it's very science-based and it's showing
the you know the underlying
you know in other words when i lecture i
call my lecture the electrum the human
electromagnetic laser body and that's
what we really have you know we have so
many more possibilities and potential in
our bodies
and of course this organization is just
looking into that thank you ma'am
are you familiar with this organization
so
edgar mitchell came back from the moon
after that epiphany quit nasa divorced
his wife made all new friends and
started this organization it had a
couple different names in the early
years but it became a front for the cia
and i found that fascinating um
he became very involved in all of this
and he is actually the individual who
brought geller
to the united states and he was the
front for
the cia in doing that because geller was
such a hugely popular figure they needed
to mask the idea that he was actually
being tested by the cia at the stanford
research institute are you familiar with
kathleen and her work no no no no
william is in izlandia new york hi
william
yeah hello um
i had one question a couple of questions
if you knew anything about the
philadelphia experiment and the
time travels at montauk long island and
the secret
arctic spaceships with the nazis and
the hitler time bell
and the alien bases on the far side of
the moon and that was it thank you sir
annie jacobson any response for him
so we've talked a lot about conspiracies
and how they kind of weave their way
through this
this because i write of all write about
these subjects from a
cia or dod filter
for me it's interesting to look at how
these organizations deal with these
subject matters and usually it creates
great problems so
because
you're
for example in the book phenomena
if you're prone to esp if you're prone
to psychokinesis
for a lot of these individuals that
leads to other ideas that are along the
lines of what the the readers the caller
was talking about
and as i report in the book it became a
real problem at dod because they didn't
know how to set ground rules like you
can think and talk about aliens but it
has to occur at home outside of the
military environment and instead you had
a couple of these individuals these
soldiers who
were using
government time government money to
conduct their own experiments using
remote viewing using esp to try to
you know do all these uh
sort of ideas that the caller's talking
about and locate aliens around the world
and you know the declassified documents
on this are fascinating because
dod did not know how to put a lid on
this because they were concerned
i don't know if it was upsetting people
or they just didn't and so it created a
colossal problem and ultimately it kind
of led to the downfall of the program
harry stephensville montana email two
questions
are you aware of magicians both retired
and working that actively debunk
paranormal phenomena for the benefit of
the public at large
yes and i write i write about them in
the book because phenomena in phenomena
because it's important to address both
sides of the aisle on this issue you
know there's no doubt that magicians can
bend spoons using pre-digitation that's
what they call it i mean you can watch a
million youtube videos demonstrating
exactly that the question is whether or
not uri geller or someone like him
can bend a spoon
uh not using a magic trick and i write
at length about that debate that battle
that is science versus supernatural at
its heart
second question from harry in
stevensville montana are you aware of
the james randy educational foundation's
offer to pay one million dollars to
anyone who can exhibit any paranormal
phenomena under controlled conditions if
so have you talked with mr randy yes i
interviewed randy for the book um
you know
i
am fascinated by because i write about
war and weapons i'm fascinated by
battles and feuds both personal
political uh global
and randy and uri geller
had this decades-long battle over this
subject um
and you know they both
all these decades later stand by their
ideas
one says this is hogwash the other says
this is a biological talent so
the reader might be interested to
see that debate play out as it does in
phenomena hopefully from a neutral point
of view
you know showing different declassified
documents on the subject showing what
the dod thought of randy what they
thought of geller what they were saying
how they all played a role because their
their feud elevated all of this to a to
a public dialogue so that is interesting
also because here they are making this
an issue and the defense department and
the cia are trying to keep it all secret
let's hear from bob in overland park
kansas bob you're on with author andy
jacobson on book tv
hi peter great to talk to you again and
i really am interested in the annie's
book i uh got up to
chapter 11. uh
i'm i'm really interested in a couple of
threads that you have in there one is
the early uh research that was done in
psychedelics in relation to psychic
ability
uh the other thing is the degree to
which there was something of an arms
race between the russians and and the
americans in terms of trying to figure
out how you could uh explore the
military uses of remote viewing psychic
research etc the other thing is i i used
to live in california and met russell
targan
and
was fascinated with his work in remote
viewing did you have an opportunity to
interview him for
your book and then i have another thing
i'll just leave you with and and since
you have done a lot of investigative
reporting with darpa initiative you
mentioned earlier that edward teller has
his feet and so many different strands
well there's a new thing that has been
emerging uh in terms of geoengineering
and it was edward teller that came up
with a first concept for geoengineering
in terms of how could we possibly
mitigate the effects of emp with maybe
doing aerosolization of of metallic
substances and aerosols in the
atmosphere which are now
being touted as possible solutions to
mitigating climate change the effects of
global warming let's hear from annie
jacobson thank you bob
so
your first question is super interesting
to me because it speaks to the origins
of
uh
the psychic program and again it pulls
from that original cache of
nazi documents that were discovered by
operational sauce after the after the
war
so one of the early ideas that the cia
was following with
psychokinesis with esp had to do with
psychopharmacology which is a fancy name
for drugs
this pulled from an old aztec legend
of hallucinogenic mushrooms
the idea that the shaman
would take hallucinogenic mushrooms and
their divinatory powers would be
enhanced so they'd be able to tell you
what was happening what was going to
happen in the future
or tell you who stole your donkey okay
so it had like prophecy and intelligence
collection
this got the cia's attention and they
hired a man a medical doctor who was at
the army chemical center named andrea
pujarek
and you know he has a foot in many
conspiracy theories as well because
he was a
someone who worked on the mkultra
programs so again these themes weave
through all of my books with elements of
truth yes there really was a program
that the cia ran
ultra sub project 58
that sought
to
pursue
hallucinogenic mushrooms for
intelligence collections purposes one of
the details i find fast i found
fascinating on this on this subject was
that the cia sent a one of its
scientists to the this is in 1953
to one of the largest mushroom growers
in america made a secret deal with them
and said you know and the plan was
didn't reveal to the mushroom grower but
that we were going to find these
hallucinogenic mushrooms in mexico and
then bring them back to the united
states and farm them and do all these
you know the volume of the experiments
that the cia intended
seemed pretty significant based on these
documents but of course the program the
scientist who led this mission he was a
of all things a banker from j.p morgan
named wassen
and he
he after he came back from mexico with
these hallucinogenic mushrooms he wrote
a
huge magazine article about it with in
time magazine
and
blew the cover on the program so the
cia's mushroom program fell by the
wayside
it seems that when you start pulling a
thread in
in in one of your stories or in one
topic you're researching all of a sudden
there's a hundred threads that you have
to pull out here and you must be careful
of the rabbit hole because
um
you do go down a lot of tunnels and i
think also it's important to realize
that some of these programs um
dead end and they really do dead end or
they end
others have
different incantations or get rebooted
and rebranded like the psychic programs
of today
annie jacobson has four books out area
51 an uncensored history of america's
top military base came out in 2011
operation paperclip the secret
intelligence program that brought nazi
scientists to america 2014 the
pentagon's brain a finalist for the
pulitzer
an uncensored history of darpa america's
top secret military research agency came
out in 2015 and phenomena
is her newest the secret history of the
u.s government's investigations into
extrasensory perception and
psychokinesis
and dr martin jacobson any relation to
you
i'm cure email i'm curious about her
approach to writing how does she get so
much done four books in six years is an
amazing achievement especially given the
difficulty she has mentioned with some
of her sources how does she schedule her
work what advice she might offer to
other writers
thank you for that question
that's one that's near and dear to my
heart which has to do with process
um it also has to do with
uh early failure let's say you know a
theme i'm interested in meaning i've
been writing for a very long time since
i was 15
went to boarding school with a
typewriter and no one was really reading
what i was writing for decades and so
the fact now that i have the great
privilege of having people read me
inspires me to keep at it and to keep
writing
and i and i encourage anyone who is
writing to continue you know to sort of
follow that idea because i think the
only failure is quitting so if you just
keep at it
you know how do i schedule
my writing i mean i write full time
and i'm always
thinking about
the
what i'm writing and why i'm writing it
and
looking at what's happening in the
current climate of the world
and trying to balance out what are
really the concerns that we want to be
thinking about today
and
filtering that back to
where did a lot of these
problems come from and where are the
solutions
i love the eisenhower idea
in his farewell speech he spoke of the
military industrial complex that is
so
famous but what often gets left out of
that is what he said in the second part
of that speech where he talked about an
alert and knowledgeable citizenry
and he said that that is how you balance
security and liberty
what a simple idea just being alert and
knowledgeable and that's how i approach
all of my books i try to be alert i read
a lot to be knowledgeable and then i get
to go out and interview the people who
are
on the ground um doing the hard work and
tell their stories
in my book so that others can read them
all right each of your books is built in
a sense on the last one what's the next
one what's your next topic
i always hate to talk about the next
topic but um
i'm actually not going to talk about it
i'm sorry
for a minute so but you you do have
another one built from what you've
absolutely been writing here i i mean
i'm going to hint at it i'm writing
about the cia
um
and i i'm it's a really interesting news
story
um
do you write at home and do you write
offline
is the computer you use not connected
oh to the rest of the world i most
definitely write at home i have an
office
i live in los angeles and i have an
office kind of you know through the
garden i take a little garden pathway
and that's my office out there
freestanding and
it's small enough not to be distracted
is it connected to the internet well my
computer is most definitely connected to
the internet but grisham we've talked to
john grisham before and he writes on an
offline computer yeah
i mean i'm able to kind of not look at
the internet all the time but
it is a huge resource for me but i also
do a lot of writing long hand
certainly that's how i begin my chapters
because i find the brain
the human brain
no matter how much technology we have
around it it works at its at its own
speed at least mine does and so for me
the
the process of writing
kind of is like
similar to my thought processes so once
i have information and i know how to
begin a chapter i write it out long and
usually the first couple pages are
always written that way
do you still write poetry
sometimes
all your books are dead
are dedicated to kevin who is kevin
kevin's my husband the new book is
dedicated to kevin jett and finley my
children um look the the
the joy of writing is so that i get to
hang out with my family i mean they're a
super source of info inspiration for me
because you know that has to do with
the quality of life right so if you
enjoy your life if you if you love who
you're with
then you are inspired i think to do
interesting and challenging things
what kind of work does your husband do
my husband is a commercial actor has
been forever he's been in every
commercial you can imagine such as
you name it where would we see him milk
cars beer
i think we have some b-roll of him in a
car commercial here it's a first
commercial ever shown on c-span i think
but he's in the in the nissan
pathfinder commercial and he does that
time yes yes yep does he enjoy it he
does i mean we're both entrepreneurs and
you know in this world we live in where
you're creative and entrepreneurial and
thoughtful
um
and i don't think we've seen him yet
this is the noah's ark there he is
sitting
driving a bunch of animals around so and
that's your husband that's my husband
how long have you been together uh we've
been married for coming up on 21 years
well annie jacobson is our guest and we
are going to continue our conversation
in just a minute after we look at some
of the things that have influenced her
and some of her favorite writers
here's a look at some upcoming book
fairs and festivals happening around the
country
on april 8th look for us to be live at
the annapolis book festival with author
discussions on topics including politics
income inequality and criminal injustice
also that day we'll be taping author
talks at the san antonio book festival
two weeks later book tv will be live
from the los angeles times festival of
books on the campus of the university of
southern california
and on may 20th we'll be live from the
gaithersburg book festival in maryland
just north of washington d.c
for more information about the book
fairs and festivals book tv will be
covering and to watch previous festival
coverage click on the book fares tab on
our website booktv.org
[Music]
so
[Music]
you
[Music]
so
[Music]
book tv tapes hundreds of author
programs throughout the country all year
long
here's a look at some of the events
we'll be covering this week
monday we'll be in the nation's capital
at bus boys and poets where former
policy adviser and speech writer for
president bill clinton eric liu
will share his strategies on how
citizens can become empowered
tuesday we're back in washington at the
brookings institution for vanessa
williamson's talk on americans attitudes
towards taxes
also that evening will be in fort myers
florida to hear former florida
congressman trey radel discuss what led
him to resign from the u.s house of
representatives
wednesday we're off to the kansas city
public library where david nichols will
talk about president dwight eisenhower's
underground campaign against senator
joseph mccarthy
that same night will be at the thurber
house in columbus ohio for former c.i.a
officer nicholas reynolds talk on ernest
hemingway's connections to soviet and
u.s intelligence services
and next saturday we'll be live at the
15th annual annapolis book festival in
maryland state capitol with discussions
on criminal justice income inequality
and terrorism and intelligence featuring
former director of the cia and the
national security agency michael hayden
that's a look at some of the programs
book tv will be covering this week many
of these events are open to the public
look for them to air in the near future
on book tv on c-span 2.
here's a look at some upcoming book
fairs and festivals happening around the
country
on april 8th look for us to be live at
the annapolis book festival with author
discussions on topics including politics
income inequality and criminal injustice
also that day we'll be taping author
talks at the san antonio book festival
two weeks later book tv will be live
from the los angeles times festival of
books on the campus of the university of
southern california
and on may 20th we'll be live from the
gaithersburg book festival in maryland
just north of washington dc
for more information about the book
fairs and festivals book tv will be
covering and to watch previous festival
coverage click on the book fairs tab on
our website booktv.org
annie jacobson you say that you are
reading or have read the lost city of
the monkey god by douglas preston what
is that
it's a book about an archaeological
quest i mean i love quest stories i
think that they're
part and parcel to human nature they
always bring in the idea of success and
failure um and then also this idea of
who are we and where did we come from i
mean the more we learn about the past i
think it
gives us ideas about the future about
where we're going which takes me back to
phenomena the reaches of what can be
known i'm always fascinated when we have
this this is the way the world was and
then oh archaeology reveals actually
it's it was a little different
do you think darpa knew
cell phone technology 30 years ago was
going to be or 40 or 50 years ago when
it was first founded
that's a great question i mean i think
maybe it goes all the way back to john
von neumann
who i write about um in the pentagon's
brain i call him the original pentagon's
brain
and he was kind of the inventor of the
first
computer that contained its own
instructions
he we're talking in the 1940s now
in the basement of the princeton
institute for advanced study where
einstein was von neumann created this
computer he called the maniac it was
essentially like a giant
um
calculator
but what was interesting so when you ask
like where are we now i go back to that
because for this reason this is an
amazing anecdote um
von neumann was so smart i mean he was a
polymath
and he built this computer and
originally we're like in 1947 now
he would his assistants he would try to
beat the computer at a numerical
calculation and his assistants
would feed him the calculations and he
would compute them in his brain
and he was able to beat the computer
originally and then one day in the late
1940s the computer
beat von neumann
and really it's this profound moment and
right then and there von neumann said
that he believed that one day computers
would be able to think that idea of
sentience so that's like really looking
far off
um and and what we have today in the in
the smartphone
you know pulls back to that origin story
i mean in the smartphone iphone's first
generation smartphone had more
technology than nassau had more computer
technology than nasa had when it sent ed
mitchell to the moon think about that
who's thinking about the future
certainly someone like john von neumann
certainly almost all of the scientists
that darpa employs
john von neumann
van avere bush van ovar bush uh jcr lick
lighter these are not names that we know
today lick lyder again he's the
he's called the johnny appleseed of the
internet because he did plant the first
seeds he was a darpa scientist called
upon
um to in the jfk era
to do something about what's called c2
in military jingo command and control
okay
so
think of technology we're talking about
the iphone go back to 1962
jfk
uh looking at a red phone right the red
phone that's the phone that if you think
there's a nuclear strike you have to
call khrushchev okay
and that tech think about the the
dialing capacity on a rotary phone
and darpa was brought on board to try
and speed that up using computers i mean
at the time computers were the size of a
room
so lick glider was brought in to speed
up this c2 process and while he was
working on those programs there at the
pentagon he came up with this idea he
sent out this very famous memo among
computer technologists which was this
where he came up with this idea that one
day
people would be able to communicate via
computers i mean he was really talking
about the internet in his mind but he
called it the intergalactic computer
network and it was going to be this
symbiotic relationship between man and
machine
he planted those original seeds for the
arpanet
he left and many capable people took
over and built the internet and then you
have this today linking up to that
technology in our phones so what man is
capable of thinking about
um is astonishing what are the reaches
of what we can know what will we know
next you're also reading neil gaiman's
norse mythology why yes well that has to
do my husband's norwegian so my kids are
norwegian um
and also
uh you know i love myths i mean i love
the idea of storytelling i love
archetypes
carl jung plays a role in my new book
phenomena
for that reason the archetypes of the
unconscious of the unconscious you know
uh these are basic tenets of narrative
storytelling and they're also basic
tenants i think of how people live their
lives how they strive what they strive
for do they want to be the hero you know
um that's an archetype that's part of
mythology 202 is the area code if you
want to talk with our guest annie
jacobson this afternoon 748-8200
for those in the east and central time
zones 748-8201
for those of you in the mountain and
pacific time zones we'll also scroll
through some of our social media sites
and that way you can also make a comment
via social media
july 9th 1947
roswell new mexico
what happened
you love
i i'm thinking that maybe at home you're
googling some of these conspiracy
theories probably a sheep more than a
goat oh
interesting
um look the myth of roswell is
part and parcel to certainly to area 51
certainly to the idea
that the government keeps secrets that
the military keeps secrets
that is when allegedly a
ufo crashed and the military stepped in
and you know took the
evidence away
it links up to area 51 as i said because
this source of mine
told me that he was part of the team
that years later received
the
what crashed at roswell
at area 51 and this is where this is the
origin story of the alien method of area
51. well when you read your accounting
of july 9 1947 in area 51
it's very believable
tell me what you tell me what you've i
mean everyone has a different
interpretation of it so this is
perspective pov tell me yours well
you talk about
the fact that there were
there was a bulletin sent out
that the air force sent out a bulletin
or put it on the news that this was
found and then they
an hour later they came back and had
another bulletin and that there were 47
witnesses to this whole thing 98
witnesses to this whole thing trucks
being loaded child coffins etc etc
these are documented facts and you know
i mean like the jfk conspiracy um
there are
numerous people we can't even put a
number on it that
spend so much time going over
the precise details i go over them
broadly but you mentioned the most
important ones that are and i think
they're when i say the most important
because they are actually what we would
call fact checkable you know and when
you have big mysteries and
considerable discrepancies within the
fact checkable information
i think it's fair
to
raise questions about
what actually went on and why are you
covering this up
because there is a cover-up if you're
going to change your story
lose in conroe texas go ahead lou
yes good afternoon miss jacobson
fascinating two questions uh one did you
do
any reviews of the violet muslims books
born
identity series for any of your writings
and two do you think the current
election of the president with all this
military in the cabinet and the increase
in the defense spending do you think
that's a dark
cia project thank you
i'm not familiar with any of the callers
books that he talked about robert ludlub
oh oh okay i miss that sorry i could
right um
yes but i tend to read more non-fiction
than fiction um
but as for the current administration
i
attempt to stay out of politics and this
is why is because
i think it's more valuable
to maintain neutrality
in terms of political
systems agendas et cetera because
i'm reporting on the intelligence
community and the defense department and
that doesn't change i mean
the leader the commander-in-chief
changes but many of those individuals
are entrenched
and i
know and work with
many people on both sides of the aisle
and i see their point
i see both sides of the aisle's points
so i'm more interested in the battle i'm
more interested in the individual quest
and i'm most interested in the outcome
well given let's go to operation
paperclip for this but in all of your
books i think you can find this
have we morally compromised ourselves as
a nation at times
for
goals do
as you ask do the ends justify the means
well that's a perfect question segued
into the previous question and here's
why
um
when i was working on
a paperclip
my editor and i would have conversations
about
making sure that i was showing
both sides of
the argument okay
and if there was any book
that i was prone to
having an opinion about
it was operation paper clip okay
um
and i'm not jewish by the way right
because of my last name many people's oh
she's jewish she's gonna side with the
you know
um but what was
what was interesting to me is that
i did try to maintain that neutrality
and i think i may have succeeded and
here's why
um
because i tried to show also why there
was an argument that it was important to
bring
the nazi scientists here to beat back
the russians
so was it a moral compromise
i'm telling you here on book tv that in
my opinion yes it felt that way when i
was writing it my job as a journalist
was to say show both sides of the i was
on
one
television program
um
that leans
right let's say and they said
annie i'm so glad you wrote this book
you showed
part and parcel why we had to have this
program we had to have it yes the nazis
were terrible but we needed to bring
them here because we had to win the cold
war
i could be on another show that would
lean left
and they would say
annie thank you for writing this book
you show that this was morally
reprehensible we absolutely never ever
should have brought these nazis here no
matter what you show it person parcel
thank you they read the same book
which speaks to my
curiosity about perspective about
what how people interpret the same facts
and that is part of human nature
the the
the ability that we have to see things
our way i think where things get really
interesting is when you have some would
call it a change of heart others would
call it a change of mind
that's what interested me in phenomena
in particular because almost everyone
who
works in that world has what's called a
conversion moment where they have a
change of heart where they have a change
of mind their life changes and the
results are dramatic
i think i remember reading an operation
paper clip uh werner von braun
he had a conversion but it was uh he was
born again as a christian
yes yes and agai and because i i mean i
didn't interview him and i didn't
interview any of his family members it's
hard to really know
um
the re the reality behind that and i
mean the
uh
the motivations let's say because
there's no way of knowing if it was
um
personally motivated like from the heart
or whether it was a motivation from his
handlers at nasa who said listen if you
pull some good old you know religion
into the mix here you're going to be
more
appealing to the average
american than the former
you know nazi scientist with a strong
german accent
does this
tie in at all to the the uh
project over in switzerland and france
the big uh
you know big bang yeah yeah does it tie
in at all some of the research that
darpa is doing
not that i know of but you know i
wouldn't doubt it because all of this
science is interconnected in an
interesting way and we at in america the
the defense scientists are always
looking at what's happening around the
world going back to that theme that we
cannot be beaten
um
we cannot be overtaken by technological
surprise
that's what happened with sputnik in
1958
they made it into space before we did
and that has never happened since so
there is good reason to say wow darpa is
doing its job
email
and this is from jim do you have any
knowledge of soldiers being experimented
on during the vietnam war era with drugs
like lsd
also using testing them with esp or ufos
etc
human testing is an infinitely
interesting and problematic area in
operation paperclip i write about the
origins of the nuremberg code
and then in area 51 i write about how
the nuremberg code was defied by
our scientists working for the atomic
energy commission
conducting human experiments related to
radiation
really nefarious experiments that were
made transparent
by the clinton administration these are
worthy documents very important to look
at because it shows you what is possible
right
what is possible flying in the face of
something like the nuremberg code i'm
always on the lookout for
that kind of
work for those kind of operations
programs i did not find any
that the reader is specifically
referring to
dave cleveland ohio good afternoon annie
jacobson is our guest
thank you for taking my call and thank
you for book tv
uh my question is concerning 1957 that
was the year of sputnik and also wasan's
life article with the multi-color
photographs appeared in 57 and in april
of 57 they had project 57 it occurred
right before the nuclear test series
operation plumb bob and in project 57
this was near area 51
plutonium was scattered across the
desert and i wonder if your research
into area 51
if you can give us any more details
about project 57
that might be of interest dave um do you
have a why the interest in these topics
well back in 1989 i was delivering mail
and met a man who had been in hiroshima
a us army guy i saw a tv show about
cloud samplers
and i also started getting a lot of
newspaper photographs relating to the
nuclear test series i was able to tour
the test site in 1995.
and i i have quite a lot of
documents i've got from the government
at one time i was at the reynolds
electrical and engineering uh public
reading room down there in las vegas and
i actually had in my hands uncensored
documents i saw the names and the rates
of dose that cloud samplers were getting
that was quite a thrilling day so i'm
wondering in particular about project 57
thank you sir
i write about project 57 at length in
area 51 um
and it was a fascinating test because we
did do that plutonium dispersal
and i tell it through the perspective of
the security guard out there at the time
a man by the name of richard mingus
and
it's extraordinary what went on the kind
of fast and loose
operations that the aec
was conducting
i also write about cloud sampling
because that is part and parcel to this
because many of the
test pilots who i interviewed for area
51
including the great hervey stockman who
was the first man to fly over the soviet
union in a u-2
this is in 1956 bringing home
photographs of
400 000 square feet of the soviet union
that had been unseen by the intelligence
community before
stockman then went on and was a
was a nuclear test pilot and flew
directly through some of those clouds
that are being discussed here
um so again they this all
kind of loops around together the
different threads come out in different
ways and the u2 was developed at area 51
right tested that was the cia's first
spy plane program they called it eyes in
the spy eyes in the sky um
and
it was
the u2 and then when the you you know so
much of this is about we do this and
then the soviets would beat us or
soviets would beat us back right so we
built the u-2 to fly high enough that
would be out of range of soviet
surface-to-air missiles well then they
built up their surface-to-air missile
suddenly you have the geary powers
incident gets shot down so the cia
starts building this new
um
airplane that we talked about called the
ox cart and that was this incredibly
secret secret project at area 51. many
of the same scientists edward lovick who
gave me my original scoop worked on the
u2 then worked on ox cart
would it surprise you today if
congress or the vice president weren't
aware of some of the things that are
going on or even the president
i wrote that in i found that out
much to my astonishment um
when i was writing area 51 and i was
talking to a source about this
incredibly secret program that allegedly
evolved human you know experiments out
there
uh the crossover with the aliens
and i said how come
this was not uncovered during the
clinton administration when so much of
this that these nefarious human
experiments
out at the test site became public and
the source said the president did not
have a need to know
that is an interesting statement
roy newcastle indiana please go ahead
yes uh kudos to uh c-span and you peter
and uh to uh anna jacobson and i just
have a little question here
i've talked with uh carol rosin that was
uh there for a while a right arm
to uh von braun uh in his latter days
and uh i've communicated with her with
skype email and talking with her and i
just wonder if you know anything
anything about her whereabouts and if
she's still involved with uh dr steven
greer and the such continue
i don't i i don't do any of those names
ring a bell besides
von braun's no
where did he end up in life
von braun yeah uh he worked in the
defense contracting industry but from
my read on
documents about him
from the government is that
you know after the apollo program ended
so abruptly it was
extraordinary distressing to him i mean
where do you go from there he was it was
such a high to be
the kind of most famous scientist in the
country during the apollo era
and then
you know people gave up on that program
um very difficult time vietnam war
and von braun
uh sort of the way i read it lost his
um
he lost his way and he became
despondent um and i write about that in
paperclip and then he's diagnosed with
with cancer and um and he died very very
quickly greg clearwater florida please
go ahead with your question or comment
for andy jacobson
yes uh thanks for taking my call i have
a question about the current state of
the art of secret aircraft technology in
the u.s
because the sr-71 and a-12 spy planes
were 1950s technology
the f-117 stealth fighter was 1970s
technology and the b-2 bomber is
1980s technology that's a long time ago
have you heard about anything uh about
current state-of-the-art exotic aircraft
being operated by the us and their
capabilities and just a footnote i do
know about the air force's
x-37b space plane one of which is still
in orbit after 600 days
in space
i think you nailed it with that last
program that's one of the more
interesting ones i know about and i
write about it in the pentagon's brain
the way i would um approach that answer
is to say like if you look back at the
technology in the 1960s with the a12 ox
car and you consider
um
going 2
400 miles an hour then you know uh in
under these secret programs you can
kind of figure out what must be going on
today based on the the information that
you talked about the programs that we
know about and then you kind of
can you know speculate on what is
unknown and again those programs are
kept secret because they are part and
parcel to national security i mean the
air has always been a important space to
dominate for the defense department
from page 364 of phenomena
the u.n turned to extra-sensory powers
to help it find saddam hussein's weapon
sites
this gets into the downfall of the
program because you had some of the
soldiers who had been trained to be
psychic
um
retiring from the military and taking it
upon themselves to
offer their services
outside
the military and that is that situation
you're talking about now that led to a
grave problem because the protocols
involved in remote viewing at that time
were still classified and so by bringing
uh the this the very subject
to the public that there was a press
release on that because the journalists
found that interesting
as they should
and then the kibosh was put on that and
it took a couple more years for the
program to really be revealed but that
was a
that was a former soldier going outside
of the military offering
private services to the u.n
since
robert lazar in 1989 revealing area 51
to the general public has there been
somebody else who has done this
that's a good question not specifically
related to area 51.
certainly the numbers of people
interested in that
are phenomenal
but
and and yes they're revelations all the
time but i think
lazar learned an interesting uh
you know came to an interesting
conclusion certainly in my interview
with him about what happens if you
reveal something that you're not
supposed to reveal
and the defense department
learned
how to deal with people who say
outlandish things or
out or people who say things that they
can
spin as outlandish or you know reflect
as outlandish and so
and also keep in mind when lazier
made his declaration i mean the world
was a totally different place in terms
of
our smartphones inter
you know information is king now and you
can learn so many different things in so
many different ways so it doesn't have
the same power that lazar had
going on abc tv i mean that was a big
deal
when you put in the request to visit
area 51 to whom did you put it in and
what was the answer
i requested to go with uh ed lovick you
know i presented it as wouldn't this be
a terrific way to make transparent to
the public um
and you know their response is brilliant
i mean it's always
um true to form
uh
and they and they you know they they
spin around
the facts because they can't actually
say
i refer to it as groom lake thinking
maybe they would you know
take the bait but they didn't and of
course they just it's like your request
to go somewhere that we're can't even
really say exists
has been denied what's area 12
out there there are all kinds of areas
out at the nevada test site
and they're divided up all of them
involve nuclear testing area 13 was
where there was the plutonium test area
25 was where they were building a
spaceship that was going to take us to
mars
using
nuclear uh weapons technology i mean you
could write a different book about every
one of those areas out there
if you drive
north of vegas on i believe it's high
state highway 95
you go right past nellis air force base
or kind of through it in a sense
um is that where area 51 is how far off
95 is area 51 area 51 is kind of
like north in a different direction
because it's inside the test site but
nellis has always played an interesting
role
because
um
they you know there are stories abound
about
pilots who
because everybody knows you cannot fly
over area 51 and every now and then
there's kind of like someone puts their
wing into the tip of the box so to speak
and there's kind of a report most of
which is redacted
but yes they they work hand in glove and
always have i mean that part of the
country with all these different
classified areas out there if you look
at a map between china lake and
california and you look in area 51 in
nevada
the test site these are huge swaths of
land where classified military
technology is
fully underway when you requested to
visit the headquarters of darpa which
you describe in in your book the
pentagon sprain as being in arlington
virginia suburb here
what was the
response same thing you know they they
really want to be able to control the
message i think more than anything
and the idea is
well if you keep a journalist out you're
definitely controlling the message
because they're not in
so that is an ongoing source of
frustration i think because
i do think that there is a
responsibility
by government to try and make the facts
known and to try and make some of these
facilities
available to people like myself but what
darpa said you know which they do have a
good point they are not a laboratory
um it's just administration that's going
on there or so they say um so they were
saying go you're gonna you're gonna do
better visiting the actual laboratories
and so i did and there's darpa's
headquarters on your screen
does nasa have an official position on
edgar mitchell and his turn towards esp
and
psychokinesis
you know they do i don't know of an
official position but you can definitely
i could in reading the documents you
could
uh get a sense of
i don't want to say disappointment but
that's the word that comes to mind um
you know they like
individuals who are part of their big
programs to
stick with the part stick with the
message so to speak and you know he had
some wild ideas um he became very
interested in the idea about aliens
toward the end of his life and he spoke
about it at length and i think a lot of
the
um
you know you kind of go where the love
is right for lack of a better expression
and so he's getting a lot of
um
let's say even nastiness from nasa i
mean they brought a lawsuit against him
at one point over some equipment
so
and he's being embraced by
individuals who lean towards some cons
what i would call
conspiratorial ideas about aliens
and he definitely leaned toward that way
and again it cost him you know
but i find that really interesting what
i also found
fascinating was
mitchell's relationship with uri geller
because
i interview geller at length in
phenomena and i
found him to be extraordinarily
interesting and dynamic
i also wound up at prime minister
benjamin netanyahu's house when i was
with uri geller in israel raising
extraordinary questions about whether or
not he works for mossad which is why he
left the cia program
um
but you know when i interviewed mitchell
he spoke so highly of geller and when i
interviewed geller he spoke so highly of
mitchell they were like foils for one
another
to mitchell uri geller represented
everything that is possible that idea of
the far reaches of man and and his
biological capabilities and to geller
mitchell represented
um
the great explorer the great hero
because he was young when mitchell went
to the moon he was in his 20s and he
told me that ed mitchell knowing about
geller's you know telepathy experiments
and his public persona
mitchell sent him a photograph
of himself on the moon and signed it and
you know said the equivalent of go urry
and geller said this just made him feel
amazing in the in this moment of doubt
because he was being attacked publicly
by james randy and every other
scientific skeptic and really dragged
through the mud and he said mitchell
gave him the kind of you know the
stamina and the energy and the and the
and the hopefulness to go forward so
they just have this fascinating
friendship over the decades that i found
uh really mysterious
finish the story about being at prime
minister netanyahu's house with yuri
geller
how did you get there
so
i mean
how did we get there the quest narrative
um
i was interviewing geller in
israel and i had specifically wanted to
spend a lot of time with him because
i wanted to
i figured that
if he was a magician and he was doing
this act by
pre-digitation what you know randy and
others do
magicians can bend spoons by just you
know a trick
i figured if i spend enough time with
geller um i might be able to see you
know a crack in the veil so to speak
which i never saw i mean i was with him
for several days for like eight and ten
hours a day
uh walking all over
uh tel aviv and everywhere we went
um
i mean he's so famous he's the most
famous person in israel it seems like
and everyone asked him to bend a spoon
and he did and you know i mean in these
remarkable circumstances and big soup
spoons in a kitchen once in the in a
restaurant i mean it was really and you
saw that i saw it happen i mean it was
just
you know and he doesn't really
necessarily touch the spoon that's what
i found fascinating um i saw him bend a
pair of hookah tongs for two
uh north africans who were there and you
know hookah tongs are crafted to
withstand extraordinary heat and and he
did that you know the hookah tongs are
like this and he kind of held his finger
it was remarkable but the one situation
i was curious about and i wasn't i told
him i wasn't really buying was this idea
that he worked for the mossad because he
told me that when he was a little boy
that had been his dream so i wondered
going back to this archetype the idea of
jung right oh maybe this is his kind of
childhood fantasy and i said that to him
um
i'm not buying it and what would the
mossad need you for the spoonbender
and he got angry with me and you know he
has a very big ego by his own admittance
um
and then a few hours later
we rock up to the residence of the prime
minister and what was amazing is
everybody knew uri geller i mean the the
agents the protective detail hey you
know we bend a spoon for us and he was
bending spoons and
it just had this very surreal quality to
it of like there is something going on
here that's outside the scope of
you know the journalists need to know um
and
i found it really fascinating and then
of course we were sitting there
uh in the residence and then geller
disappeared into the back
and i wondered
is this how the mossad works i i don't
know it's a mystery so
it
makes you more of a sheep than a goat
it makes me more of a sheep than a goat
you know i mean that kind of experience
um
but really it makes me open
to the idea i mean that's what
schmeidler said in those that scale it's
like
i'm open to the idea because i'm open to
the idea of
it's a quest to determine the not the re
you know to think about and and
what can be known what is man capable of
and if you think of the world we live in
now and this astonishing rate of
technology
um you know jung said it where when he
and the nobel laureate physicist
wolfgang paoli were
discussing esp they had a decades-long
debate esp is it fact or fantasy and
jung said
um
you can only judge what is possible by
the criteria of the age right so think
about what we've been talking about this
for hours now where we are now with
computer technology um i mean where we
are with space travel this was
the
this was science fiction
decades ago and now
it's all possible so if you
allow yourself to hold that idea
and not be
so judgmental against these ideas that
yes for millennium have been
you know
aligned with the supernatural have been
aligned with magic
but if you can
just hold the idea and think about it
i think there is
more to be revealed
don houston texas andy jacobson is our
guest
thank you for taking my call
i was in the air force
for eight years and i was in uh at
vandenberg
for five of those years
and um
some things happened at battenberg i
worked with nasa
and with the party started knowing
second half water and i met
i met carl sagan
i also met the colonel that was over a
project blue book
and um
there was rumors that and i saw a number
of officers uh landed
on a private aircraft
we were told they were majestic 12
people
and um
a few days before
this gathering of
or whatever you want to call them um
early afternoons
three ufos passed over our base
and all the power went out for about
15-20 minutes
and it was a it was a sac base um
we had missile silos but we weren't
a nuclear-armed missile base they uh
test-fired
missiles that would be used
uh if we did go to war with russia don
did you actually see the ufos yourself
yes i was uh i was at uh dog site uh
when when they passed over
and uh my uh work park has targeted
mateelli was outside the silo
and
other people were standing in the area
these
air police
were out there when
when they passed
they didn't pass they they came fast and
then they they came to a stop
and i i remember i looked at my tail and
they kind of looked at me and i
i you know i said look am i saying what
i'm saying or what and he kind of
laughed he said uh
i'm not sure but he said you know
i don't think we have anything in our uh
in our industry that can do these kind
of things burke and i said well you know
i
i said i think you're right and then
they they angled off right at a high
rate of speed
and then they came back about three or
four minutes later
and ubered right over to the mississippi
sites and then they hit it out towards
uh where the nasa
uh launched uv was communication
satellites and then sometimes it was
top sacred operations that then i guess
they were launching whatever
uh for the military um
and um
are you convinced on that these were
ufos
well
before this happened okay um
i i i didn't i walked the fence i didn't
say yeah we're not alone yeah we are
alone but um
i'm an irish catholic and i i told a
person one day it'd be ashamed
if uh you know the god that created the
universe
put us out here by ourselves all alone
all right don thank you let's hear from
annie jacobson on this or did you have a
question for him
so
ufo unidentified flying object
i write about this at length in area 51
unidentified flying object there are two
sides of the aisle those who say
they come from another galaxy let's say
and those who say
they are unidentified flying aircraft
meaning they are still classified
projects
and
one thing i can tell you
for certain is that ufos were part and
parcel to the early days of area 51
because the u2 was often mistaken for a
ufo the ox cart was often mistaken for a
ufo and i interviewed the pilots and the
scientists who were working on this and
the officials from the government who
were in charge of putting the kibosh on
those reports sometimes people who saw
them and again what they were seeing was
the ox cart okay
and they would see this shiny object
going at a speed that wasn't humanly
possible because
2 400 miles an hour was an unknown speed
to be able to fly in the early 1960s
so the fbi would knock at the door and
you know literally pay a visit to the
people who reported these to let them
know that they didn't see anything
strange and that created its own
new conspiracy because if the fbi shows
up at your door and tells them you
didn't see something that you know you
saw now that's not to completely
disregard all of those individuals who
firmly believe they have seen things in
the skies that cannot be explained i
just think there are different sides of
the argument
all your books have been bestsellers
does that surprise you
someone who spent decades
um
trying to get someone to read what i was
writing yes that surprises me it's the
best kind of surprise why'd you give up
on the great american novel
no one was buying the great and not the
great american novel from annie jacobson
you know um i mean i think it's
important to sort of pivot to uh where
the where the work is you know and when
i say work i mean you know employment um
when i became a reporter
um
that really changed things for me
because i was able to
accept that so much of writing at least
for me is craft you know it's just stay
at it and keep at it and ultimately you
will find
and narrate the story a couple of your
books are in the uh the movie mode
aren't they yes yes
that's the status all of them they all
are i mean they're actually in
television development and my new book
phenomena was just um
optioned by steven spielberg's amblin
and jason blum's blum house
so it's amazing because you have sort of
the old guard you know e.t right and
close encounters i mean let's face it
spielberg built this genre in the
fictional world well in the modern
fictional world um
and then you have blumhouse who are
responsible for
not only the
horror
genre becoming so popular they do all
the paranormal activities but they also
make really interesting
movies like whiplash uh documentaries
like the jinx and
that those
uh projects are all about what makes you
uncomfortable and i think in dealing
with phenomena this squishy science idea
this idea that's the center of a battle
between the skeptics and the
supernaturalists it makes people really
uncomfortable because you know they
think one thing and then they talk to
the other side and they think that thing
i mean i find that super interesting
because we have to ultimately you know
come to terms with our own belief set
belief set but a lot of times it's a
process the amazing thing about film and
television is they're sort of the gentle
way in to many of these subjects and
they spark an interest in the
non-fiction world i think they work part
and parcel
okay explain hollywood here you said uh
phenomena has been optioned by both
spielberg and by blum
how is it that two people can option the
same product well they team up so
they're like two great teams um and then
the content is created of how to move
forward i mean you see that operation
paperclip is in development with
brad pitt's company which is called plan
b
um and rat pack
which is brett ratner's company and they
they team up so a lot of times you have
and and pentagon's brain
uh you have jj abrams
bad robot the people behind star wars
working with warner brothers
so and and area 51 amc you know with
gail ann hurd the woman who co-wrote the
terminator
but again i think these these
science fiction is super interesting to
a lot of people
for my favorite theme the reaches of
what can be known so much
of science fiction
winds up becoming the truth and in fact
so many
scientists famous scientists nobel
laureates tell me that their ideas
come from reading science fiction as a
child
well george orwell was one of your
influences that you yesterday why yes
um i mean you know that idea of
what the future may be like
is very interesting to me and and i like
cautionary tales because you can see
what you want to avoid um or what you
hope to avoid
uh
you know the idea of dystopia
is a spooky one particular and
particularly important
this speaks to the pentagon's brain
the last chapters in the pentagon's
brain i wrote about
darpa's quest to
create a synthetic brain you know and my
visit out to los alamos to meet with
those scientists who are working on that
will artificial intelligence
lead us to a place
that uh
you know george orwell would have
written about or did write about
or will it liberate us you know it's
that it's that eisenhower question i
mean how do security and liberty live
side by side and now that artificial
intelligence
is
such a major player
everywhere you know the quest for it
because of course we have whether or not
we will achieve true sentience in
machines with something von neumann
predicted but we have yet to know
but the defense department is certainly
moving in the direction
of
marrying autonomous weapons drones with
artificial intelligence
i see danger in that i see the
cautionary tale
marsha
union bridge maryland email
were you ever threatened because of the
research you do for your books do you
know if you've ever been under
surveillance because of your books
look the capabilities of
the government are extensive you know in
terms of surveillance and i write about
that in all of my books i just really
keep my nose clean meaning
i'm just after the facts and
i
talk to scientists
who worked on very secret very
classified military programs and they
are aware of
what they can say and what they cannot
say
and that's really where the risk is so
i'm just i mean i'm very grateful that
scientists agree to talk to me because
it would perhaps be easier to say
i can't
because they're the ones that have to
toe that line and you know keep these
ideas in their mind okay i can talk
about that program and i can't talk
about that because you cannot disclose
classified information
period and that's the risk that they
take which is a far greater risk
i think than me as a reporter writing
narrative nonfiction
gene in hillsborough north carolina good
afternoon to you
hi i wonder if you could maybe
confirm or if you
say whether you've ever heard about this
rumor that was running around at one
technology company i worked for a long
time ago and that is special forces
delta and
seals get a chip embedded
for identification
purposes like after the
failed iranian hostage
attempt
uh they they got remains back and
after that they decided they needed to
do the to put chips into those guys so
they can
maybe identify remains easier
thank you sir
the chipping
technology is very controversial i mean
yes there's the chips in the body for
identification purposes i mean civilians
do that as well so but there's also the
chip in the brain
programs that i write about in the
pentagon's brain that i think are far
more of concern
and again they're
they're presented by darpa under the
rubric of warrior wellness under this
idea that brain wounded soldiers can you
know have a chip in their brain and it
can they can work on these programs to
you know in
bring back some some cognition
um but this is a very slippery slope
area and even the jason scientists who
i uh interviewed
advised the pentagon not to go in that
direction for fear of and this was an
exact quote it could lean to it could
lead to
you know
high quality brain control
and
when you have a
again that cautionary tale idea when you
have a warning
from a group of scientists who have been
advising the pentagon for decades
and the pentagon chooses to ignore that
i think it's important that those facts
be known and then the citizenry can
decide whether or not they think this is
a good idea putting chips anywhere in
people's bodies
but on the flip side then
what if the russians what if the chinese
are working on this and we don't want to
be caught
technologically surprised
and that's always the argument so you
really have to say is who's pushing the
science where and why right and yes
darpa uh is is absolutely
you know
on the cutting edge of all these
technologies but the russians also have
a darpa and so does so do the chinese
paul huntington beach california annie
jacobson is our guest we have about 15
minutes left
thank you very much for putting me on
i have a number of questions
the first question is
bob lazar and i'm sure you've discussed
bob lazar
the interesting thing is that by
coincidence lazar was hungarian
and apparently dr keller
recommended that he work on the reverse
engineering
of alien craft
so i wonder if you've already discussed
that or whether you'd like to discuss it
item number two
i visited wright patterson air force
base last year
and of course the
roswell incident
involved is the removal of debris
initially to a special hangar then right
paterson air force base
and i think from there it was spirited
away to area 51.
and unfortunately i haven't had the
opportunity
to read your books but i will
because i'm a neighbor
so that's another area the third area
that is fascinating is that
back in the 90s a
an american military gentleman a colonel
published a book
in which
he theorized based on his experience
and
proposed the fact that uh alien craft
and alien reverse engineering
uh was largely responsible for the
explosion of technological breakthroughs
that took place in the 50s
and that many of those breakthroughs
were done by darpa
uh and then disseminated
through the
private sector tell you what paul we'll
leave it at those three questions but
very quickly do you believe that on your
third question
it's it's hard to
disprove
because the explosion if you take a look
at the development of human civilization
there are timelines when
major discoveries are made
archimedes
aristotle uh the euclidean theorem
you've got isaac newton
but the huge concentration
uh in a three-decade period
of uh explosive discoveries
simply
is statistically
out of the
norm of human evolution at least i
certainly feel it is because
we're looking at computing we're looking
at bioengineering we're looking at the
discovery of the transistor we're
looking at the tremendous proliferation
of the use of silicon
and
is the additional
electronic discoveries but in particular
kelly johnson
skunk works and i'm sure you're familiar
with skunk works
the
aerodynamics
that emerged out of the skunk works and
subsequently
are so radically different
from the previous history of
aerodynamics
in particular the sharp aerodynamic
edges of the u2
all right
paul thank you for that and i apologize
um i think we got the gist
so many of these subjects are covered in
area 51 and uh you know from lockheed um
teller lazar
again these are all ideas if you think
about going back to what we were just
talking about what is possible in any
age okay the idea of
um
strange things in the sky has been
an issue that people have thought about
and contemplated and created art about
going back to pre-civilization
i visited the british museum while i was
writing the phenomena and looked at
these the earliest examples of what
people thought were ufos i looked at
cuneiform writings from king ashburna
panel's library
omens divination rulers back in 600 bc
would say who will win the war you know
i went to the oracle at delphi to kind
of
read and and feel what it was like
to work with prophecy so prophecy ufos
man civilization biology what is
possible these are all part and parcel
to all the subjects i investigate and i
just love the fact that there are ideas
that exist and we look as journalists we
go into the documentation we interview
people we present the stories
as best i present the stories that i do
in my books as best as i can based on
eyewitnesses based on
documentation and based on the work of
other journalists before me who have
laid the tracks down and so the story is
always evolving and changing and
transforming but ultimately it's going
in that direction about you know what do
we know about the past and how can we
use that as we move forward in the
future and make sense of this world that
we live in where technology is advancing
at this astonishing rate and yet we and
our ideas
our brains
are still relatively the same
what about his point
that
all of a sudden we had these great
technological leaps
beginning in the 50s well many
scientists talk about that idea of
knowledge kind of this the same
discoveries cropping up in different
parts of the world
at the same time and and that is super
interesting i mean one of the themes
that i write about in phenomena that i
did not that is new to my sort of you
know works if you will
um speaks a little bit to the reader's
question and to your point and it has to
do with this idea of where does
inspiration come from okay the eureka
moment
and i'll tell a story about the great
charles towns and what he told me in our
interview now charles towns won the
nobel prize in 19 nearly 1960s for the
laser okay arguably one of the most
important technological inventions of
the modern era
i mean military applications laser
weapons civilian use eye surgery uh the
laser printer
um
and i bring this up because the
scientific skeptics always go crazy on
this idea and on balance when you think
that the idea i'm about to tell you
comes from charles towns
okay it kind of puts things in
perspective so
i asked him to confirm with me
a kind of story that was out there about
him that the idea of the laser came to
him
while he was sitting on a park bench
and he said yes that is right that was
his eureka moment
now towns we learn
is a man of faith
so that eureka moment to him in his view
of the world and in his perspective
was
something that came to him from the
supernatural okay
and
this i think speaks to the the caller's
questions about where are these ideas
coming from and some people the sheep
will tell you
that
great moments are not limited to you
know i came up with this idea myself
sitting at my desk they often there are
three nobel laureates i write in the
book who all talk about these eureka
moments and who believe that these ideas
come from without and i think
the whole world and the narratives of
aliens and higher intelligence maybe
even consciousness that is touching upon
that theory that there is a greater
intelligence out there and i think that
it it's not i don't i think it's unwise
for me anyways to dismiss this
whole cloth to take the position of the
goat
and
essentially ridicule it i think the idea
of being open to it is far more
interesting and far more courageous
dick troy alabama you're on book tv
uh c-span thank you very much for the
last two two hours and 50 minutes this
has been absolutely captivating
uh
miss jacobson
i have a question but first of all i'd
like to tell you you just sold four
books
because i'm gonna buy them tomorrow
but what i what i'd like to know though
uh you you you made this
quotation twice
about attributing the eisenhower and his
uh impaired will speak
but uh the the
balance between
security and liberty
is
an informed public
or
i want to i want to know this
and
please don't consider this to be a mean
question because i don't mean for it to
be
but just how much
should
we know
about what's going on
and we'll get an answer in two seconds
dick will you just tell us a little bit
about yourself
i'm just
i try to be a writer
but
not very good at it
i'm not very wise either my knowledge is
very shallow i
really
couldn't
i don't even know shallow would be the
proper word of how ignorant i am about
what you're talking what kind of work
did you do are you retired
i taught school for a while but i've
been a lot of other things too
but uh
this has been a most most enjoyable show
and i wish you would write a bible liz
jacobson
there we go
thank you so much how much
should we know
another theme that i'm always writing
about because
when
you see some of the programs
declassified and you realize what was at
issue what was at stake
there is very good reason in many
instances
to keep those programs classified so
that the other side doesn't um
isn't aware of that and and then it
remains a true defensive measure
there lies the conundrum of the military
industrial complex and i think your the
caller's question is actually brilliant
because
the military-industrial complex exists
for a purpose for national security but
if there if their goal is to speed up
the
revelations
then you also have what one defense
department official described to me as a
self-licking ice cream cone
right so in other words if you could
have a great weapon system um that that
stayed classified the and the other
intelligence community on the other side
knew about it and couldn't defend
against it
and the goal was to keep us keep that
the two powers in check then essentially
you have an effective
weapon system but the minute that system
becomes known like the you know the
f-117
then
that becomes obsolete and it creates an
entire new vacuum i.e new business for
the defense contractors to create a new
weapon system so
it's it's a brilliant question and i
think it's there is no easy answer but
the the investigation the investigator
in me is infinitely interested in in
pursuing that thought and finding out
what i can
and presenting those facts to the public
this is an email from joe
which one or two
programs would you like to see released
to the public tomorrow
which one or two wake you up in a cold
sweat
i mean that's a great question but i you
know i don't know because i think the
old
really and truly the the unknowable
programs are the most interesting and it
never ceases to amaze me
when you learn about a program
that
you know no one knew about before that
then you really know the government's
doing its job of keeping things secret
but if i had to say
looking back i think the weapons tests
that we did in space
are extremely interesting and i would
like
i know that a lot of those are still
classified because i've reported on
those
and that speaks to the space race and
there is talk right now with the current
administration
excuse me of rebooting the space race i
think that is extraordinarily dangerous
for a number of reasons and i be
first and foremost because they're also
talking about perhaps a return to
nuclear testing um that's frightening
and if you look at the weapons tests
that were done in space
you get a sense of how dangerous this
all can be
merlin
ocean ohio please go ahead with your
question or comment for annie jacobson
yeah this is mr jacobson and
thanks for having me
i'm
93 years old
and uh
my grandfather's uh first name was
torvill
torvill jacobson
that was leif erikson's brother
so
i i don't know whether danny reynolds is
or not but i thought i'd bring it up but
anyway the question i wanted to ask you
do they the government still have all
that material they picked up at oswald i
mean that uh
yeah
over in oswald the city of oswald in
roswell merlin jacobson of goshen ohio
93 years young thank you for watching
amazing you have you have the adventure
of spirit in your blood
as for the roswell remains we don't know
where they are
do we know that there were remains
we'll get you a little bit more water
sorry about that
um i mean it depends who you ask about
the remains i write about that in in
area 51 i think that's one of those
mysteries and maybe to your earlier
caller
if there was a program that could be
declassified can you imagine if roswell
was really declassified
annie jacobson is the author of four
books her first came out in 2011 area 51
uncensored history of america's top
secret military base
operation paper clip came out in 2014
and that was the secret intelligence
program
that brought nazi scientists to america
the pentagon's brain
an uncensored history of darpa america's
top secret military research agency came
out in 2015
and her most recent book
is phenomena the secret history of the
u.s government's investigations
extra sensory perception and
psychokinesis
she tells us that her next book will
have something to do with the cia that
leaves it pretty broad i guess
do you enjoy the book tour
i love it i love getting out there on
the road and talking to people who like
to read it reminds me of that image that
we talked about of edgar mitchell the
man on the moon reading you know and you
think about this idea the archetype of
reading of knowledge um
couldn't i often say i have the best job
in the world i mean i get to
write
books
and listen to
what readers think about and what
the experience of reading the books and
then how it influences them in their
lives and their thinking and their as
they become more of an alert and
knowledgeable part of the citizenry
let's hear from barbara in newark new
jersey hi barbara
hi speaking about um uh
um
near-death experiences and extrasensory
perception
um
i had a near-death experience and and i
think the brain is
is more powerful than any computer
also have you heard of dark social
it's supposed to be something where
on the internet people can read
what you write on facebook or in any
kind of blog or anything and then they
take it and they write it
and claim it as their own and then when
you go to
um
verify your own writing you're being
told that you're be you're plagiarizing
yourself
now hey barbara before you you go you
talked about near-death experiences what
was yours
um i fell on concrete slipped and hit
the back of my head on concrete and i
had no um
nothing to
prevent
my whole weight hitting just on the back
of my head
and i was out for i don't know how long
but when i got um in the ambulance
um i saw
uh in
i don't know whether it was vertigo or
what it was but it was
like a
jet
speeded up
rocket ship speed
um
like a um
in front of my eyes but it was it was
going from
left to right or right to left
and it it was like a uh what would you
call it a
um
like a slot machine going in front of my
eyes all right i apologize we're almost
out of town near-death experiences were
though have those been investigated as
well yes i mean i write about them in
the book phenomena because
that's that conversion moment for a lot
of people where they have a near-death
experience
and they come back from that with
extreme conviction
about what they are now going to pursue
and it often has as the caller explained
to do with consciousness you know what
is the brain capable of because if you
go somewhere else come back
you certainly have a different
perspective and i find that super
interesting
medical research involved in a lot of
the things that you've
looked at yeah absolutely human
physiology i mean that's where we are
today with the esp programs um
instead of the parapsychologists you
have neurobiologists
neurophysiologists looking inside the
brain and inside the body but the body
and working to map
the human brain
is a remarkable concept
particularly when you put the military
in the mix because the military is
working to enhance
human functioning enhance cognition
and ultimately to weaponize these
systems are there civilian applications
like all things there is dual use
for the last three hours annie jacobson
has been our guest on book tv thank you
thank you
c-span where history unfolds daily